TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE IS
CALLED TO ORDER. GOOD AFTERNOON
AND WELCOME EVERYONE THE HEARING
ROOM IS OPEN TODAY FOR
ATTENDANCE OF THIS HEARING ANY
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC ATTENDING A
HEARING IS ENCOURAGED TO WEAR A
MASK WHILE AT ALL TIMES WHILE IN
THE BUILDING WE ENCOURAGE THE
PUBLIC TO PROVIDE WRITTEN
TESTIMONY BY VISITING THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. PLEASE NOTE
THAT ANY WRITTEN TESTIMONY
SUBMITTED TO THE COMMITTEE IS-CONSIDERED PUBLIC COMMENT AND
MAYBE READ INTO THE RECORD OR
REPRINTED EVERYONE IS ENCOURAGED
TO WATCH THE HEARING FROM ITS
LIVE STREAM ON THE ASSEMBLY'S
WEBSITE. YOU CAN TESTIFY IN
PERSON IN THE HEARING ROOM- OR
BY USING OUR TELEPHONE SERVICE.
WE WILL ALLOWED FOR TWO MINUTES
EACH FOR TWO PRIMARY WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT AND IN OPPOSITION FOR
EACH BILL. ADDITIONAL WITNESS
COMMENTS WILL BE LIMITED TO YOUR
NAME ORGANIZATION AND POSITION
WE WILL NOT ACCEPT. ANY
TESTIMONY. OF AN EXPLANATORY
NATURE AFTER THE TWO- OF MAIN
WITNESSES AFTER THAT IT WILL
JUST BE I AM SO AND SO AND I
SUPPORT THANK YOU I AM SOAND SO
ON I OPPOSE. AND YOUR
ORGANIZATION IF THERE IS ONE.
ADDITIONAL WITNESS COMMENTS WILL
BE LIVE- BECAUSE WE HAVE I THINK
FIFTEEN BILLS TODAY FOURTEEN
BILLS TODAY AND THEY'RE OF A
SUBSTANTIAL. THE CONTENT WE'RE
GOING TO BE LIMITING THE TOTAL
PUBLIC COMMENT AFTER THOSE TWO
PRIMARYWITNESSES TO FORTY FIVE
MINUTES PER BILL- WE WILL START
WITH THOSE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
CORE HERE IN THE ROOM AND THEN
MOVED TO TELEPHONE TESTIMONY. TO
USE OUR TELEPHONE SERVICE THE
NUMBER TO CALL IS. 877-692-8950
SEVEN AND THE ACCESS CODE IS
EIGHTEEN FIFTY ELEVEN HUNDRED
AND IF YOU DIDN'T WRITE THAT
DOWN. IT'S ALL AVAILABLE ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE YOU CAN FIND
US THAT WAY. IF YOU HAVE ANY
PROBLEMS CALLING IN YOU CAN CALL
OUR- COMMITTEE DIRECTLY AT NINE
ONE SIX THREE ONE NINE AT TWENTY
NINETY THREE AND WE WILL TRY TO
HELP YOU WITH ANY TECHNICAL
ISSUES. FOR WITNESSES CALLING ON
THE PHONE LINE YOU'RE GOING TO
BE PLACED IN A QUEUE UNTIL YOUR
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT. YOU MUST MOVE YOUR MUTE
YOUR DEVICE WHEN YOU YOU ARE IN
THE LINE BECAUSE IF WE PICK UP
AND YOUR DEVICE IS NOT MUTED
WILL GET AN ECHO AND WE WILL BE
IMMEDIATELY DISCONNECTED AND
HAVE TO TRY CALLING IN. AGAIN
NOW FINALLY THE ASSEMBLY HAS
UNFORTUNATELY EXPERIENCE A
NUMBER OF DISRUPTIONS. TO OUR
COMMITTEE AT OUR FLOOR HEARINGS
IN THE LAST FEW YEARS. BECAUSE
WE HAVE LIMITED AMOUNT OF TIME
ANY- CONDUCT THAT DISRUPTS
DISTURBS OR OTHERWISE IMPEDE THE
ORDERLY CONDUCT OF THIS HEARING
IS PROHIBITED. SUCH CONTENT A
SUCH CONDUCT MAY INCLUDE.
TALKING OR MAKING LOUD NOISES
FROM THE AUDIENCE UTTERING LOUD
THREATENING OR ABUSIVE LANGUAGE.
SPEAKING LONGER THAN THE TIME
ALLOTTED. EXTENDED DISCUSSION OF
MATTERS NOT RELATED TO THE
SUBJECT OF THE BILL AND OTHER
DISRUPTIVE ACTS. TO ADDRESS ANY
DESERVED IS WRAPPED OF CONDUCT I
WILL TAKE THE FOLLOWING STEPS.
IF AN INDIVIDUAL DISRUPTS OUR
HEARING PROCESS I WILL DIRECT
THEM TO STOP AND WARNED THEM
THAT CONTINUE DISRUPTIONS MAY
RESULT IN REMOVAL FROM THE
BUILDING. I WILL ALSO DOCUMENT
ON THE RECORD THE INDIVIDUAL
INVOLVED AND THE NATURE OF THE
DISRUPTIVE CONDUCT. I MAY
TEMPORALLY TEMPORARILY RECESS OF
THE HEARING. IF THE CONDUCT DOES
NOT STOP I WILL REQUEST THE
ASSISTANCE OF THE SERGEANTS AND
EXCLUDING THE INDIVIDUAL FROM
THIS BUILDING. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR COOPERATION WITH THAT WE'RE
GOING TO BEGIN OUR HEARING. OF
MADAM SECRETARY COULD YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
HEY WHERE'S. IT'S YEAH THERE WE
GO FRIEDMAN. FRIEDMAN HERE FONG
ON HERE BERMAN. BERMAN HERE
CUNNINGHAM. DALY DALY HERE
DAVIES DAVIES HERE GIPSON.
GIPSON HERE KALRA OVER HERE WE-
WE'LL BE HERE HELLO. THE VARIANT
. WHEN. WHEN HERE DONALD. DONALD
WARD ORDER HERE WICKS WICKS HERE
. WE HAVE A QUORUM. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND WE HAVE ONE OF
MEASURE ON CONSENT TODAY AB
TWENTY FIVE OH NINE BY MR FONG
IS THERE A MOTION ON THE CONSENT
FILE. WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND- SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. I WAS ON CONSENT
FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN IPHONE FONG
I BERMAN. BERMAN I CUNNINGHAM.
DALY DALY I DAVIES DAVIES I
GIPSON GIPSON I KALRA KALRA I
LEE THREE I BLEW. HELLO I
NAZARIAN WHEN I O'DONNELL. FORD
WARD I WICKS WICKS I. FOUR ZERO
OKAY THE CONSENT FILE IS ADOPTED
THAT BILL IS OUT I'M GONNA HOLD
THE ROLE OPEN FOR MEMBERS TO ADD
ON WE HAVE THIRTEEN BILLS TO
DISCUSS TODAY FIRST UP IS AB
SIXTEEN THIRTY EIGHT I SEE
MISTER KILEY IS HERE. YOU MAY
PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY SIR.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND THE
MISTER VICE CHAIR- I- I DO WANT
TO THANK THE CHAIR FOR GIVING
THIS BILL A PROMPT HEARING- IT
WAS INTRODUCED ON JANUARY
TWELFTH BUT WAS ONLY JUST
REFERRED TO COMMITTEE- THIS LAST
THURSDAY. THIS BILL IS VERY
SIMPLE IT WILL SUSPEND OUR
STATE'S GAS TAX SPECIFICALLY
ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTEEN THIRTY
EIGHT PLACES A SIX MONTH
MORATORIUM ON THE CALIFORNIA ON
THE COLLECTION OF CALIFORNIA'S
STATE EXCISE TAX ON GASOLINE
AMOUNTING TO FIFTY ONE CENTS.
PER GALLON. RIGHT NOW CALIFORNIA
HAS BY FAR THE HIGHEST GAS
PRICES IN THE COUNTRY THEY HAVE
REACHED TRULY UNIMAGINABLE
LEVELS NEARLY SIX DOLLARS PER
GALLON. THIS IS A WELL ABOVE THE
NATIONAL AVERAGE A DOLLAR AND
SIXTY EIGHT CENTS MORE THAN THE
NATIONAL AVERAGE AND IS SEVENTY
CENTS HIGHER THAN THE NEXT
CLOSEST STATE. THE EFFECTS OF
THIS GAS TAX ON THESE RECORD
HIGH GAS PRICES ARE EXTREMELY
REGRESSIVE. THAT'S WHY A RECENT
SURVEY SHOWED THAT 47% OF LOW
INCOME CALIFORNIANS SAID THAT
THE RISE IN FUEL COSTS IS POSING
A SERIOUS FINANCIAL HARDSHIP. IF
YOU'RE SOMEONE WHO HAS TO
COMMUTE A LONG DISTANCE TO WORK
OR MAYBE YOU HAVE KIDS YOU NEED
TO DRIVE TO SCHOOL OR OTHER
ACTIVITIES OR MAYBE LIVE IN A
RURAL AREA. WHERE THERE ISN'T
EASY ACCESS TO PUBLIC TRANSPORT
THEN THIS POSES EVEN MORE OF A
HARDSHIP THE FACT IS THAT NOT
EVERY CALIFORNIAN CAN AFFORD TO
HAVE A TESLA DELIVERED TO THEIR
HOME TOMORROW. AND MANY
CALIFORNIANS MANY OF HARD
WORKING CALIFORNIANS DO NOT HAVE
ALTERNATIVES TO DRIVING THEY
HAVE NO CHOICE BUT TO BEAR THESE
COSTS AND TO PAY MORE AND MORE
OF THEIR INCOME- TO FUEL COSTS.
THIS BILL PRESENTS A VERY SIMPLE
SOLUTION. IT IS A LOVER OF THAT
WE CAN PULL IMMEDIATELY IT HAS
URGENCY BECAUSE IT WILL TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY. IN ORDER TO
PROVIDE FOLKS WITH SOME MEASURE
OF RELIEF. FIFTY ONE CENTS A
GALLON WILL NOT BRING GAS PRICES
IN CALIFORNIA DOWN TO REASONABLE
LEVELS BUT IT WILL HELP MILLIONS
OF PEOPLE AND IT'S SOMETHING
THAT WE CAN DO RIGHT NOW. SIMPLY
BY PASSING THIS BILL. NOW I WANT
TO. RAINY ANSWER A FEW
OBJECTIONS HAVE BEEN RAISED THIS
BILL. THE FIRST IS THAT SOMEHOW
CUTTING THE STATE'S GAS TAX WILL
NOT RESULT IN A BENEFIT TO
CONSUMERS THIS NOTION HAS BEEN
THOROUGHLY DEBUNKED. THE
NATIONAL BUREAU OF ECONOMIC
RESEARCH FOUND A COMPLETE PASS
THROUGH OF BOTH FEDERAL AND
STATE DIESEL AND GASOLINE TAXES
TO CONSUMERS. MOREOVER ARE ONLY
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE HAS
FOUND THAT MOST OF THE CHANGE IN
THE TAX RATE LIKELY WILL BE
PASSED THROUGH THE PRICES AT THE
PUMP. BUT WE DON'T ACTUALLY NEED
TO LOOK AT STUDIES OR ANALYSTS
WE CAN SIMPLY LOOK AT WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN THE WORLD. OTHER
STATES LIKE MARYLAND AND GEORGIA
CHOSE TO SUSPEND THEIR STATE GAS
TAX AND THEY SOUGHT AN IMMEDIATE
REDUCTION IN THE PRICE THAT
CONSUMERS WERE PAYING AT THE
PUMP. THE SECOND OBJECTION. IS
THAT THIS WILL RESULT IN A LOSS
OF FUNDING FOR ROADS. FROM THE
PLAIN TEXT OF THE BILL THIS IS
CLEARLY FALSE. THE BILL WOULD
BACK FILL ANY LOSS OF FUNDING
FOR ROADS OUT OF THE STATE'S
GENERAL FUND AND LET'S REMEMBER
THAT WE HAVE A VERY LARGE
SURPLUS. RIGHT NOW. FINALLY I
WANT TO ADDRESS THESE VARIOUS
REBATE PROGRAMS THAT HAVE BEEN
OFFERED BUT BY MEMBERS OF THIS
LEGISLATURE. AND BY THE
GOVERNOR. I THINK THAT REBATES
ARE A GOOD IDEA IN FACT I THINK
WHEN THERE'S A SURPLUS THIS
SHOULD BE PRETTY MUCH AUTOMATIC.
WE SHOULD GIVE THE MONEY BACK TO
THE FOLKS THAT WE GOT IT FROM. I
THINK THAT WHAT'S BEING PROPOSED
SHOULD ACTUALLY BE MUCH MORE
SIGNIFICANT I THINK IT SHOULD BE
PERMANENT I AM READY AND WILLING
AND EAGER. TO WORK WITH THE
GOVERNOR AND MEMBERS OF THIS
LEGISLATURE I'M GIVING
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE OVERTAXED
SOME MUCH NEEDED TAX RELIEF. BUT
THAT IS AN ENTIRELY SEPARATE
QUESTION. FROM WHAT TO DO ABOUT
THE IMMEDIATE AND SPECIFIC
PROBLEM. OF RECORD HIGH GAS
PRICES. WHAT I HAVE PROPOSED IS
A SPECIFIC AND IMMEDIATE
SOLUTION. WHICH IS TO SUSPEND
THE TAX THAT WE HAVE ON GAS
WHICH IS JUST ABOUT AS HIGH AS
ANY IN THE COUNTRY. THIS SHOULD
NOT BE A PARTISAN ISSUE. IN
CONNECTICUT FOR EXAMPLE THE
MEMBERS OF THAT LEGISLATURE
UNANIMOUSLY PASSED A BILL TO
SUSPEND THE STATE GAS TAX.
DEMOCRATS VOTED FOR IT
REPUBLICANS VOTED FOR IT. THE
BILL WAS SIGNED INTO LAW BY THE
VERY LIBERAL GOVERNOR ADAMANT. I
CAN ASSURE YOU THAT YOUR
CONSTITUENTS WILL BE GRATEFUL IF
YOU TAKE THIS STEP TODAY TO
PROVIDE SO MANY WHO ARE
STRUGGLING WITH A LITTLE BIT OF
A RELIEF. AND I CAN EQUALLY
ASSURE YOU THAT THEY WILL BE
DUMBFOUNDED IF THIS LEGISLATURE
AGAIN REFUSES TO TAKE THIS
MODEST SIMPLE EASY AND
COMMONSENSE STEP. HERE WITH ME
TODAY TO TESTIFY IS ONE OF THE
MILLIONS OF CALIFORNIANS RIGHT
NOW IS STRUGGLING. WITH THESE
OUTRAGEOUS GAS PRICES ANDREW
LEOPARD. I DO TOO TWO MINUTES
SIR YOU CAN TESTIFY THEY'RE
PROBABLY THERE WERE NEW IN THIS
ROOM SO WE'RE STILL FIGURING OUT
. IT WILL BE ON IN ONE MOMENT.
YOU HAVE TO PUSH THE BUTTON. ALL
RIGHT I'M MY NAME IS ANGELA
PROJECT COME TO YOU AS A
LIFELONG CALIFORNIA RESIDENT I'M
A FATHER A HUSBAND A MARINE
CORPS VETERAN- I AM A
RESIDENTIAL LOAN OFFICER AND I
SHARE. A SMALL NONPROFIT.
ROSEVILLE CALIFORNIA THAT'S
RAISED OVER SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR VETERAN AND CANCER
CAUSES- IN THE LAST FIVE YEARS-
MY WIFE OUR COMMUTES FOR WORK
AND- SHE DRAWS FROM APPOINTMENT
AS WOMEN EVERY DAY AND WITH THE
RISING COST OF GOODS AND
ESPECIALLY GAS. WE'RE HAVING TO
TAKE A LOOK AT EVERYTHING THAT
WE SPEND MONEY ON. WHETHER IT'S
GROCERIES WHETHER IT'S
EXTRACURRICULAR ACTIVITIES FOR
OUR TWO KIDS BEFORE IN A FIVE
YEAR OLD- SHE'S TAKING OUR KIDS
TO SCHOOL EVERY DAY AND SHE'S
DRIVING TO DRIVE FOR WORK AND
IT'S CAUSING. M. UNDUE HARDSHIP
ON US- HEARD I'VE HAD DISCUSSION
BECAUSE WE'VE HAD MANY MANY
FRIENDS LEAVE THE STATE JUST DUE
TO THE- RISING CRIME AND COSTS
OF. LIVING AND EVERYTHING ELSE
AND WE'VE SAID THAT HEY WE'RE
GONNA STAY IN WE'RE GONNA TRY
AND FIGHT IT OUT. BUT WITH THE
NOTION ARE WITH THE- PSSIBILITY
THAT SHE'S GOING TO HAVE TO LOOK
AT. EITHER PULLING BACK ON HOW
MUCH YOU WORKS OR STOP WORKING
AT ALL- JUST BECAUSE OF THE
RISING COST OF GAS- THAT MIGHT.
BE THE LAST. STRAW THAT BROKE
THE CAMEL'S BACK FOR US LEAVING
THE STATE. WHICH I REALLY REALLY
HATE TO DO SO- IF YOU COULD
PLEASE SUPPORT REPEALING THE GAS
TAX THAT WOULD BE A HUGE BENEFIT
TO MY FAMILY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH YOU'RE WELCOME- WE HAVE TWO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. WE'RE
FIRST GOING TO GO ON TO A
WITNESS ON THE TELEPHONE-
SEVERIN BORENSTEIN. IF THE
OPERATOR COMPLETES FINE MR BORN
SEEN. SHE. CAN YOU HEAR ME YES-
GOOD- HI I'M SEVERIN BORENSTEIN
I'M A PROFESSOR AT UC BERKELEY'S
HAAS SCHOOL OF BUSINESS AND
FACULTY DIRECTOR BANERJEE
INCLUDED HOSTAGE I JUST HAVE A
COUPLE OF COMMENTS SINCE I ONLY
A FEW MINUTES ONE IS WITH ALL
DUE RESPECT TO ASSEMBLY MEN
KILEY THE STUDIES THAT SHOW FULL
PASSED THROUGH AND I'VE DONE ONE
OF THEM- ARE WERE NOT DONE AT A
TIME WHEN THERE WAS SCARCITY. OF
CAPACITY TO PRODUCE GASOLINE AS
THERE SEEMS TO BE IN CALIFORNIA
RIGHT NOW ALIFORNIA SPOT PRICES
ARE WELL ABOVE THE REST OF THE
COUNTRY AND USUALLY THERE ARE
ABOUT TEN CENTS HIGHER AND THAT
GIVES ME GREAT CONCERN THAT IF
WE CUT THAT GAS TAX RIGHT NOW
AND ECONOMIC THEORY TELLS US
THIS- IT WILL NOT ALL BE PASSED
THROUGH SO I AM CONCERNED. THAT
SOME OF THIS WOULD BE- GO TO-
REFINERS AT A TIME WHEN THERE'S
A SCARCITY OF REFINERY CAPACITY
MY SECOND POINT I WANT TO MAKE
IS THAT THIS DOESN'T ADDRESS THE
ONGOING CHALLENGE OF GASOLINE
PRICES IN CALIFORNIA DUE TO WHAT%
I'VE CALLED THE MYSTERY GASOLINE
SURCHARGE WHICH IS THE EXTRA ON
AVERAGE THIRTY CENTS A GALLON
THAT APPEARED IN TWENTY FIFTEEN.
ABOVE THE HIGHER TAXES AND
ENVIRONMENTAL FEES- THAT
APPEARED AFTER THE TORRANCE
REFINERY AND HAS NEVER
DISAPPEARED IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
THAT COST CALIFORNIANS ABOUT
FOUR BILLION DOLLARS SO WHETHER
OR NOT THIS PASSES AND YOU
REPEAL ARE SUSPEND THE GAS TAX I
WOULD URGE YOU TO LAUNCH AN
INVESTIGATION WITH REAL
RESOURCES AND- REAL POWER TO
FIND OUT WHERE THIS EXTRA MONEY
IS GOING. THAT IS COSTING
CONSUMERS FAR MORE THAN BEING TO
THE TRANSITORY INCREASE WE'VE
SEEN RECENTLY- AND ALTHOUGH I AM
VERY SYMPATHETIC TO PEOPLE WHO
ARE PAYING A LOT MORE FOR GAS
LINE I'M ALSO VERY SYMPATHETIC
PEOPLE ARE PAYING A LOT MORE FOR
UTILITY BILLS RIGHT NOW AND FOR
RENT- AND- PARTICULARLY WITH
ELECTRICITY WHERE WE HAVE
OVERPRICED IT. DUE TO PUTTING
MANY THINGS THAT LED. WANT INTO
UTILITY BILLS- I WOULD URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER. TAKING
SOME OF THOSE PROGRAMS BACK AND
PAYING FOR THEM THROUGH THE
STATE BUDGET AND GIVING A
BROADER SET OF- CUSTOM CONSUMERS
NAY. A BREAK ON THEIR UTILITY
BILLS THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE HAVE ANOTHER WITNESS IN
PERSON JEREMY SMITH. WELCOME TO
COME TO THE DESK IF YOU LIKE.
THANK YOU JUST BE SURE YOU PUSH
THE MIKE BUT I'M. DO YOU HEAR ME
OK THE REGAL THANK YOU NICE TO
BE BACK IN FOR EVERYBODY IN A
HEARING ROOM THIS IS A VERY
EXCITING AND I WOULD BE REMISS
IF I DIDN'T MENTION THAT THIS IS
A BILL BY UNION WORKERS UNDER
PROJECT LABOR AGREEMENT HOPE YOU
ALL ENJOY IT WE'RE VERY PROUD OF
THE WORK THAT OUR MEMBERS. HERE
JEREMY SMITH YOUR BEHALF OF THE
STATE BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL ALSO IN
OPPOSITION- WE WANTED TO LET YOU
KNOW THAT WE FEEL THE PAIN AS
WELL THERE'S NO DOUBT THAT FUEL
PRICES ARE IN PRICES IN
CALIFORNIA SOME OF OUR MEMBERS
ARE PAYING. SIX SEVEN DOLLARS
FOR GAS AND DIESEL- DRIVING
HUNDREDS OF MILES A WEEK TO GET
TO WORK AS THEY DO IN THE
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY- THIS ON
TOP OF LAST YEAR'S MOST
CALIFORNIANS CAN BARELY MAKE IT
TOO MANY WORKING FAMILIES. ARE
MAKING HARD DECISIONS BE BUYING
GROCERIES IN THE WAGES AGAIN THE
GAS THEY NEED TO GET TO WORK OR
SCHOOL THIS IS WHY BE PUSH
POLICY MAKERS REVISED SOLUTIONS
OF THIS CRISIS. GRADING OTHER
CRISIS TO ADDRESS THIS CRISIS IS
NOT THE ANSWER THOUGH. SETTING
ASIDE THE THOUSANDS OF JOBS THIS
BILL PUT IN JEOPARDY ON ONGOING
AND FUTURE PROJECTS ALLOWING A
HIGHWAYS AND BY WAYS TO
DETERIORATE FROM LACK OF
MAINTENANCE WILL CREATE SAFETY
ISSUES. AND INFRASTRUCTURE
DEFICIT THEY'LL TAKE A
GENERATION TO CORRECT AS MANY OF
YOU REMEMBER ADDRESS THE ONE
THAT WAS THE FIRST TIME THE GAS
TAX HAVE BEEN RAISED IN TWENTY
THREE YEARS. WE SUSPENDED TODAY
WHO KNOWS. IF WE'LL EVER GET TO
GO BACK AGAIN. RIGHT NOW THESE
FUNDS OF. THOUGHT OF MIDDLE
CLASS- MIDDLE. ON MIDDLE CLASS
WAGES. OF ANNA AND JOBS ARE TO
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS UP AND DOWN
THE STATE- ANY DISRUPTION THOSE
FUNDS COULD LEAD TO. UNDUE DELAY
IS AN ONGOING PROJECTS. AS WE
OPPOSE THIS BILL WE ALSO URGE
LAWMAKERS TO PROVIDE RELIEF TO
CALIFORNIANS IN MULTIPLE FORMS.
WHETHER BEING A FORMER CHECKS
DIRECTLY TO RESIDENTS OR
OTHERWISE. DIRECT PAYMENTS
RESIDENTS WILL DO MORE QUICKLY.
THAN THIS MEASURE. WE ALSO ARE
TOUCH LEADERS LOOK BEYOND THE
PRICE THE POP IN THE IMMEDIATE
PARTIAL CHALLENGE OF THINK ABOUT
HOW WE GOT HERE. THE LAST YEAR'S
ACROSS ANYTHING IS THAT BEING AT
THE END OF THE SUPPLY CHAIN
WHETHER IT'S THE BABY FORMULA
TOILET PAPER OR OIL. IS NOT
WHERE WE WANT TO BE CURRENTLY
CALIFORNIA PORT 60% OIL FROM
PLACES LIKE THE AMAZON
RAINFOREST THE MIDDLE EAST. AND
TENS OF MILLIONS OF BARRELS OF
CRUDE OIL UNTIL PRESIDENT BY
SUSPENDED IT FROM RUSSIA. FOR AS
LONG AS CALIFORNIA'S USING OIL
AND GAS WE SHOULD DO BETTER AND-
WE CAN BE. WE CAN BY PRODUCING
MORE OIL AND GAS IN CALIFORNIA
UNDER THE STRICTEST
ENVIRONMENTAL LAWS IN THE WORLD-
I BEHALF OR EMBERS ACROSS THE
STATE FINALLY WE RESPECTFULLY.
REQUEST A NO VOTE ON SIXTEEN
THIRTY EIGHT A. B. SIXTEEN
THIRTY EIGHT. A POLITICAL PLOY
THAN A SUCCESSFUL PUT ALL
CALIFORNIANS AT RISK AND I WANT
TO JUST MENTION MADAM CHAIR. WE
GOT A TEXT FROM SOME OF OUR
FOLKS ON THE PHONE AT THE PHONE
LINES ARE FULL. I DON'T KNOW IF
THE EIGHTEEN THE OPERATOR CAN DO
ANYTHING ABOUT THAT BUT I WANT
TO LET YOU KNOW THAT. THERE'S
QUITE A FEW PEOPLE ON THE PHONE
LINE RIGHT NOW TRYING TO GET
ABOUT CAN'T. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AND THANKS LETTING US KNOW I
DON'T KNOW THE CAPACITY. HOW
THOSE LINES WORK BUT I WILL ASK.
SERGEANTS AND STAFF TO TRY TO
WORK THAT OUT SO THAT PEOPLE.
CAN GET THROUGH IF THEY'RE
CALLING IN. MAYBE WE CAN ASK
PEOPLE WERE LISTENING IF YOU'RE
NOT CALLING ON THIS BILL. MAYBE
TO HANG UP AND CALL BACK. IN A
LITTLE WHILE. AND LET THE PEOPLE
WHO ARE CALLING ON THIS BILL A
CHANCE TO. I'M REGION SO WE'RE
GOING TO TAKE FORTY FIVE MINUTES
OF ONLINE. OF TO OPPOSE. WE'RE
GOING TO FORTY FIVE MINUTES FOR
IN PERSON AND TELEPHONE
TESTIMONY. SO WE'RE GONNA START
WITH ANYBODY WHO'S IN THE ROOM
EITHER FOR OR AGAINST WE'RE
GOING TO MIX IT UP. SO ANYBODY
WHO WANTS TO SPEAK ON THIS BILL
AND AGAIN JUST NAME AN
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION. EVEN
IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. WE'LL START WITH ONE
NUMBER TWO THIRTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MADAM CHAIR. MADAM CHAIR
SIMPLY MELANIE DEVON MATHIS.
WE'RE GOING TO THE MICRON HOLD
ON A MINUTE DEVON. YEAH WE'RE
DOING IN PERSON NOT TELEPHONE
OPERATOR WE'RE DOING IN PERSON
TESTIMONY. MY APOLOGIES SORRY
SORRY IF I HAD MISSTATED SO JUST
NAME ORGANIZATION AND YOUR
POSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR. ARE WE ON ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER DEVON MATHIS TWENTY SIX
DISTRICT ON BEHALF OF THE HALF
MILLION PEOPLE THAT I REPRESENT
AND RURAL CALIFORNIA- HUMBLY ASK
THAT YOU SUPPORT REPEALING THE
STATE'S GAS TAX THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS MATT
CRIMMINS HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ABOUT A CONFERENCE OF
OPERATING ENGINEERS WE ARE IN
STRONG OPPOSITION WOULD
ENCOURAGE A NO VOTE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SEE NO ONE ELSE IN THE
ROOM WISHING TO TESTIFY. ON AB
SIXTEEN THIRTY EIGHT NOW WE WILL
GO TO THE PHONE LINES OPERATOR
IF YOU COULD PLEASE OPEN THE
PHONE LINES FOR ANY. SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION ON AB SIXTEEN THIRTY
EIGHT THANK YOU. THE MANAGER
AGAIN APOLOGIES I WILL GO TO ONE
TO THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. OKAY
OVER ONE ONE SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. PEOPLE CANNOT CALL
THROUGH IF YOU NEED TO STAY
UNTIL MIDNIGHT TO HEAR THE WILL
OF THE PEOPLE THEN YOU NEED TO
NEED TO DO THAT THERE IS NO
REASON OR JUSTIFICATION EXISTS
ALREADY HAS ALREADY PAUL WE
SUPPORT THIS BILL. MEXICO LINE
EIGHTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS DAVID HORROR I SAW. IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL I WANT TO
LET YOU KNOW THAT ON THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLY VIDEO
SCREEN LIKE MEDIA IS BLACK WE
CAN'T SEE ANYTHING. SO THANKS
TRY TO FIX THAT. BY NUMBER
NINETY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. ALL. YEAH ALL CALLS AGAIN IT SHOULD
BE IN THIS HEARINGS INTO AWHILE
OF WHAT WELL. ALWAYS NATIONAL
ALLIANCE SICK NINE GO AHEAD. HI
NATIONAL. YOU SHOULD NEVER. YEAH. THE CURRENT MY NAME IS WILLIAM
I MUST I INSURANCE ACCOUNT AND I
SUPPORT AB ONE SIX THREE EIGHT
NINE I FOR A VOTE THANK YOU.
IT'S NEXT TO A LINE TO FOURTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BUT DEFINITELY
KEEP ON COMING UP IN NAPA VALLEY
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. MEXICO
WINE TWO THIRTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. KIANA VALENTINE ON BEHALF
OF UNITED CONTRACTORS IN STRONG
OPPOSITION. MY NUMBER NINETY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI WENDY
JOHNSON WITH BOB JOHNSON
CONSTRUCTION IN WHY RICA
CALIFORNIA. PLEASE REPEAL THAT
THE GAS TAX YOUR TALENT. I'M
GOING TO FIFTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ONE TWO FIVE FORTY ONE IS
OPEN.
ONE ONE ONE OH SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI RICK SMILED FOR THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA DISTRICT
COUNCIL WAIVERS AND WE ARE IN
OPPOSITION OF AB IXTEEN THIRTY
EIGHT. UNDERLINE NUMBER SIXTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
ADAM CALLING FROM GLOUCESTER
COUNTY I REPRESENT EVERYONE
DRIVING THE VEHICLE AND I WOULD
REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT TO THE
EIGHTEEN SIXTEEN THIRTY EIGHT
FELT. MY NUMBER ONE ELEVEN
PLEASE GO. HELLO I'M A YOUNG
PERSON LIVING IN A CLIMATE
CATASTROPHE AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL. IT WILL MOVE ONLINE NUMBER
EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES YES GOOD.
BANNEKER MERYL MODERATOR THANK
THIS TIME BUILDING TRADES WERE
IN OPPOSITION AB ONE SIX THREE
EIGHT. IN LINE TO THIRTY ONE GO
AHEAD. TWO THIRTY ONE YOU WANT
IS OPEN. OKAY MOVE ON THE LINE
NUMBER SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YEAH THIS IS BILL
GENERALLY ARE YOU SEE AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE. NUMBER ONE
SEVENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS HAPPENING THIS YEAR SO
IF HE COST INSULATORS LOCAL
SIXTEEN AND WE STAND WITH THE
BUILDING TRADES IN OPPOSITION TO
SIXTEEN THIRTY EIGHT THANK YOU.
FIND ONE THIRTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I ONE THIRTEEN YOU LINE
IS OPEN. ROSS LAMB OPERATION
NEAREST WE OPPOSE THIS FOR THE
CIVILIAN TRADES. NINE ONE TWENTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO. YES
YOU I'M LOOKING PLEASE GO AHEAD
HI THIS IS BRANDY JOHNSON WITH
AIOLI AND WE ARE OPPOSING AB.
SIXTEEN THIRTY EIGHT. ONE TWO OH
EIGHT GO AHEAD. TWO ZERO EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MOVE ON THE
LINE TO THIRTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD- GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR COMMITTEE MEMBERS- THIS IS
DAVE PERSONAL OF THE OPERATING
ENGINEERS LOCAL THREE AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE. MY NUMBER ONE
NINETY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO. YES YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO. ARE YOU
THERE YES YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD ONE NINETY ONE.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT MY NUMBER IS
THIS IS A LISA BOGARDUS ORANGE
COUNTY. AND WE SUPPORT ONE SIX
THREE EIGHT AND THINK IT WILL
HELP INFLATION. BY REDUCING NOT
ONLY THE COST OF GAS THANK YOU
FOR NOT TAKING ANY TESTIMONY BUT
THANK YOU FOR CALLING. MY NUMBER
TWO SIXTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
I'M A RESIDENT OF ELDORADO
KILLING AND I SUPPORT THEM ASK
YOU TO VOTE YES FOR A. B.
SIXTEEN THIRTY EIGHT. ONE TWO
ZERO FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M
VERY TO DECCAN I REPRESENT SMALL
BUSINESS HERE IN CALIFORNIA AND
WE SUPPORT AB. SIXTEEN THIRTY
EIGHT. LINE TO TWENTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD- PLAN MARK HAS-
AND I AM A SENIOR CITIZEN MY
HUSBAND AND I AM A BUNCH EXTEND
IT COMES AND WE HEARTILY SUPPORT. SIXTEEN THIRTY EIGHT. NINE ONE
EIGHTEEN COULD GO AHEAD. I'M
WAITING TO DISCUSS ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY FIVE SIXTY TWO. OKAY SO
WE CAN MOVE ON THE LINE ONE
FIFTY THREE THEM IN TO BACK UP
WHEN IT'S THAT TIME. FIND ONE
FIFTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. CAN
YOU HEAR ME. COOPER YES PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS JOHNNY
US TO BUILD OUR BUSINESS ASIA
PER FARMWORKERS LOCAL FOR
SIXTEEN AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
AND STAND WITH THE BUILDING
TRADES. SPINE ONE FIFTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. ONE ONE FIFTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. LINE TWO ZERO SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO CAN YOU
HEAR ME. HELLO THIS TO GO AHEAD.
YES HI MY NAME IS SARAH
WINTERBURN I'M AN ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL TEACHER IN SANTA CRUZ
COUNTY CALIFORNIA AND I'M
CALLING TO STRONGLY SUPPORT AB
SIXTEEN THIRTY EIGHT. CALIFORNIA
EVEN GET TO WORK. THANK YOU.
LINE ONE TWENTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ONE TWENTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO. YES PLEASE GO
AHEAD ONE TWENTY NINE OH AREN'T
MIND BLOWING IN SUPPORT OF AB AT
SIXTEEN THIRTY EIGHT AND I AM
FROM MERCED CALIFORNIA THANK YOU. GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MANAGER
MEMBERS HAVE A LANDING ON BEHALF
THE AMERICAN COUNCIL OF
ENGINEERING COMPANIES OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. ONE TWO SEVENTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS THIS IS
JAMES THEREAFTER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE COUNCIL LABORS
IN STRONG OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
LINE TWO THIRTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS MEGAN
BROWER I'M A SINGLE DAD OF TWO
WHO QUALIFIED FOR AND RELEASE-
STRUGGLING TO GET MY KIDS TO
SCHOOL AND BASEBALL I AM VERY
MUCH IN SUPPORT OF THIS- AB
SIXTEEN THIRTY EIGHT. WINE TWO
THIRTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS GILBERT COULD
GET ON FROM LOCAL FOR THIRTY ONE
TEAMSTERS UNION AND AYE OPPOSED
AB SIXTEEN THIRTY EIGHT KILEY.
BLIND ONE OH ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH MY NAME IS JAKE WOOD WITH
OPERATING ENGINEERS AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE A. B. SIXTEEN
THIRTY EIGHT. LINE TWO ONE FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS PAUL HAYDEN I'M A RESIDENT OF
ELDORADO COUNTY AND I AM IN
SUPPORT OF SIXTEEN THREE EIGHT
BUT SUPPORT THE PEOPLE NOT THE
UNIONS THANK YOU. WHY NUMBER TWO
SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES MY NAME'S NICOLE JANA I'M
LIVE IN PLASTER COUNTY AND I
REPRESENT THE WORKING POOR AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT AB SIXTEEN
THIRTY EIGHT THANK YOU. ONE ONE
THIRTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO COMMITTEE MEMBERS THIS IS
MITCHELL BATTLE WITH THE
DISCOUNT PROVIDE WORKERS WE
STAND IN SOLIDARITY WITH THE
STATE BUILDING TRADES IN
OPPOSITION. NINE TO SEVENTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO CAN YOU
HEAR ME. YES PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
NAME IS SHANNON HEIL AND I'M
CALLING FOR ALL THE HARD WORKING
CALIFORNIA'S THE COMPARE REALLY
MAKE THE SCHOOL OR TO WORK
PLEASE PLEASE SUPPORT THIS BILL
WE NEED A BREAK HERE THANK YOU
SO MUCH. MY NUMBER SEVENTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
AMANDA CAN I TAKE A DRIVER IN A
RESIDENT IN CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
SUPPORT AT SIXTEEN THIRTY EIGHT
. THANK YOU. LINE TWO EIGHTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. TWO EIGHTY YARD
IS OPEN. YOU HEAR ME YES. YES MY
NAME IS LINDA MASTER AND IN FACT
ARE COUNTING AND I'M WITH THE
SENIOR CITIZENS WHO STRONGLY
SUPPORT AB SIXTEEN THIRTY EIGHT
MISTER KILEY THANK YOU. LINE TWO
FORTY SIX. IN. NINETEEN
CALLING IN POLICE. FOR BY NUMBER
TWO NINETY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD
. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR TODD
BLOOM SIGN FOR THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION OPPOSED EIGHTY
SIXTEEN THIRTYEIGHT THANK YOU.
NINE TO FIFTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD.
TWO FIFTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YEAH CHARLIE LOBBY THE
OPERATING ENGINEERS SAN
FRANCISCO AND STRONG OPPOSITION
TO SB. SIXTY THIRTY EIGHT. IN
LINE ONE FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD- MY GREENLEE WOULD ISSUE
SIXTEEN PAYER LARGE TRADE WAS
DOWN THE BILLING TRENDS IN
OPPOSITION. BLIND THREE HUNDRED
ONE THREE ZERO ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WE HAVE PEOPLE NOT EITHER
GOVERNMENT OR JUST GETTING
WARMED UP AND WE SUPPORT THIS
BILL. ONE TO NINETY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GABRIELLE GRAHAM
FOUNDER OF STAND UP SACRAMENTO
COUNTY- WE THE PEOPLE OF THE
TAXPAYERS STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL. IN ORDER. I WILL GO ON THE
LINE TO NINETY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. FIVE HEARING YES PLEASE
GO AHEAD OKAY GREAT- MY NAME IS
SHERRY A LOT SOME CALLING FROM
PLASTER COUNTY. IN FOR ALL
PURSUES A VERITY. IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB SIXTEEN THIRTY
EIGHT THANK YOU. LINE THREE OH
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME
IS BUT THE FISH- I AM ALSO YOUNG
PERSON THE CLIMATE CRISIS-
STANDING WITH THE UNIONS IN
OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL THANK
YOU. NINE TO FORTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO YES PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YEAH THIS IS JOSH BETTER
IN ORANGE COUNTY CALIFORNIA ARE
SUPPORTING YOUR FLOW ON THE U.
B. SIXTEEN THIRTY EIGHT THANK
YOU. NINE THREE HUNDRED AND
SIXTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS
HEATHER KELLER- TAXPAYING
RESIDENT OF SACRAMENTO COUNTY
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT AB SIXTEEN THIRTY EIGHT
PLEASE STAND WITH THE PEOPLE AND
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
NINE TWO HUNDRED NINETY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS MICHAEL
GENTRY AND THE DATA SCIENTISTS
CONTENT AND JUST GO AND I OPPOSE
THIS BILL BECAUSE OF ITS EFFECTS
ON CLIMATE CHANGE THANK YOU.
NINE EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ALL RIGHT HELLO. YEAH ONE
EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HAPPY ARE. HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES PLEASE GO AHEAD. MANY CLARA
. I'M A MODERATE CENTRIST KIND
BUILDING TRADES WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE AB ONE SIX THREE EIGHT
THE STANDARD STATE BILL TRICKS.
A. NINE TWO EIGHTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YEAH HELLO. STE GOOD
AFTERNOON. YES PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME. I ASKED
THE QUESTION CAN YOU HEAR ME
PLEASE GO AHEAD ONE TWO EIGHTY
SIX WE CAN HEAR YOU. OKAY I
REALLY SUPPORT THIS AS A MIDDLE
CLASS CITIZEN IN PAIN SO MUCH
TAXES IN MY COUNTY AND STATE.
AND I WAS A UNION MEMBER FOR
OVER THIRTY SIX YEARS I DON'T
SUPPORT WHAT THE UNION IS DOING
NOW. THANK YOU. NINE THREE
SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH
GOOD AFTERNOON DIAMETER CAN HEAR
BUSINESS OWNERS SACRAMENTO
COUNTY YOU WANT TO GET ERICA I
SUPPORT AB SIXTEEN THIRTY EIGHT
GOTTA GO TO THE SALON WORK THANK
YOU. NINE THREE THIRTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS MIKE
MATTER CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY NAME IS MIKE
MATTER ONE OF THE MAIN PROPONENT
ASSERTED THAT WE CALL OF GAVIN
NEWSOM I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL EVERYBODY WHETHER THEY WORK
FOR YOU IS ALL VERY HAPPY IF YOU
ARE ONLY TALKING GOODS THE
PROPORTION THANK YOU. ONE THREE
FIFTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI I
SUPPORT. EIGHTEEN SIXTEEN THIRTY
SIX. LINE TO NINETY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. I MAINTAIN PRACTICE OF
ORANGE COUNTY REPRESENTING ALL
HARD WORKING PARENTS AND I
SUPPORT AB SIXTEEN THIRTY EIGHT
THANK YOU. IN LINE THREE FIFTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. THAT. SB
FIFTY EIGHT. OKAY. MADAM CHAIR
WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME. OKAY THANK YOU WE'RE
NOW GOING TO MOVE IT TO BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS. OF MR LEE. THANK YOU
MA'AM JEFF RECOGNIZING ME FIRST
I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT OF
COURSE RIGHT NOW THEY'RE
CALIFORNIANS HURTING FROM THE
HIGH GAS PRICES OF COURSE WE
SYMPATHETIC TO THAT AND THAT'S
WHY THIS HOUSE ON THE WORK ON
OUR BUDGET. ARE GOING TO
PROPOSING ECONOMIC A
COMPREHENSIVE ECONOMIC RELIEF
FOR SHORT TERM PROBLEMS BUT ALSO
JUST BECAUSE THERE IS NOW THE
WAR IN UKRAINE. DOES NOT MEAN
THIS IS A LONG TERM PROBLEM THE
FOSSIL FUEL INDUSTRY HAS
HISTORICALLY ALWAYS TAKEN
ADVANTAGE OF UNSCHOOLED
UNCERTAINTY. GAS PRICES ROSE
WHEN THERE WAS A THREAT OF WAR
WITH IRAN RECENTLY WHEN THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION ASSASSINATE
SOLEIMANI WHEN THE US INVADED
OUR A ROCK AND LEADING UP TO THE
GULF WAR AND NOW THE CO AND NOW
THAT THAT WILL PRICE OR SLIGHTLY
DROPPING AS OF TODAY BECAUSE THE
COVERT LOCKDOWNS SHANGHAI. IT'S
YOU KNOW THE THING THAT I GET
REALLY IRKED ABOUT IS THERE'S
THIS LINE IT'S TOLD TO CONSUMERS
THAT THE PRICE OF GAS IS HIGH
BECAUSE OF GOVERNMENT. BUT THE
REASON WHY WE HAVE SB ONE IN THE
GAS TAX IS DEFINED THE VERY
ROADS THAT ALL THE CAR USERS
ENJOY THE HIGHWAYS BRIDGES. AND
EVEN PUBLIC TRANSIT. BUT WE
REALLY DON'T QUESTION. FOR SOME
REASON. IS THE GREED OF
CORPORATIONS OF FOSSIL FUEL
CORPORATIONS FIVE. FIVE
CORPORATIONS RULE ALMOST A
MILLION MONOPOLY ON OUR GAS
MARKET RIGHT NOW FIVE OF THEM.
AND THE FIVE. OUR CHEVRON
MARATHON PBF ENERGY PHILLIPS
SIXTY SIX AND BOLERO BOLERO THEY
HAVE THE MARKET POWER TO SELL
GASOLINE TO THEIR BRANDED
STATIONS OF THEIR CHOICE. AND
THEY ARE ALSO STILL AS ONE OF
OUR WITNESSES FROM ECONOMICS
ECONOMISTS POINTED OUT THEY
STILL CHARGING AND NEARLY FORTY
EIGHT CENTS PER GALLON MYSTERY
SURCHARGE THAT HAPPENED AFTER
THE TORRANCE EXPLOSION THERE'S
NO EXPLANATION FOR THAT. THEY'RE
REAPING IN THE PROFITS FOR IT
JUST LAST YEAR BLACK THE TOP
TWENTY FOUR FOSSIL FUEL
CORPORATIONS THEY LINE THEIR
POCKETS WITH A HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY FOUR BILLION DOLLARS IN
RECORD PROFITS A HUNDRED SEVENTY
FOUR BILLION DOLLARS THAT IS
ALMOST THE ENTIRE SIZE OF OUR
STATE BUDGET. SO WHEN THESE OIL
MONOPOLY. WHEN THE FOSSIL FUEL
CORPORATIONS HAVE A KNOBBLY ON
THE MARKET OF COURSE THEY CAN
CHARGE IF THEY WANT. AS THE
ARGONAUTS ALSO POINTED OUT THERE
IS NO GUARANTEE. THAT THE
SPENDING THE GAS TAX THAT'S ANY
SAVINGS. ON THE CONSUMER ARPITA
THERE'S NO GUARANTEE IN THIS
BILL OR IN REAL LIFE THAT THE
SAVINGS ARE PASSED ON THE
CONSUMER THERE'S NOTHING TO STOP
THEM FOR TAKING ADVANTAGE OF THE
NEXT GLOBAL CATASTROPHE. AND
UNCERTAINTY IN THE MARKET TO
RAISE GLOBAL LOW GAS PRICES AND
THAT IS BECAUSE UNFORTUNATELY WE
HAVE A DEPENDENCY. FEEL BY THE
FOSSIL FUEL CORPORATIONS ON
GASOLINE CARS THEY WANT TO
MAINTAIN THE STATUS QUO SO THAT
WE ARE. STOCK BUYING IT IN LAST
A GOOD THAT IS IN ECONOMICS ONE
A ONE GASOLINE IS IT IN ALASKA
GOOD THAT WE ARE UNFORTUNATELY.
HAVING TO PAY FOR BUT WE NEVER
QUESTIONED THE GREED OF THESE
CORPORATIONS. AND YOU KNOW THE
AUTHOR TALKS ABOUT SPECIFIC
SOLUTIONS. MY MEMBER OF CONGRESS
PARTNERING WITH MANY STATE
SENATORS EX SENATOR I'M SORRY US
SENATORS LIKE SENATOR WHITE
HOUSE SENATOR BERNIE SANDERS
SENATOR ELIZABETH WARREN JEFF
MARKLEY AND ED MARKEY. POSING I
WINDFALL TAX ON BIG OIL SO THAT
MONEY THAT THEY AREN'T FROM US
GOES BACK DIRECTLY TO HARD
WORKING CALIFORNIA'S OF THE
WORKING CLASS AND MIDDLE CLASS
AND SOMETHING I NOTICE A LOT IN
THE CONSTITUENT ARE. THE
FEEDBACK ON THE PHONES A LOT OF
PEOPLE ARE DIALING IN FROM
PLASTER COUNTY SACRAMENTO
COUNTY. I WHICH I BELIEVE ARE
SOME OF OUR COLLEAGUES
CONSTITUENTS AND I LOOKED IT UP.
BUT THOSE CONSTITUENTS JUST LIKE
MINE ARE BENEFITING IN THE NET
IN THE MILLIONS OF DOLLARS FROM
SB ONE PROJECTS ONE THING I SAW
WAS THAT JUST IN. PLASTER COUNTY
ALONE. LET'S SEE. YOU'RE SERVING
YOU GOT SIDEWALK IMPROVEMENTS
YOU HAVE ROADWAY IMPROVEMENTS
BACK THERE'S JUST A SIXTY SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS ALONE FOR
PLASTERS PULL A PLASTER
SACRAMENTO GATEWAY CORRIDOR THIS
IS REAL MONEY THAT IS GOING TO
IMPROVE THE DRIVER EXPERIENCE AS
WELL THE NOT JUST THE RIDGES AND
NOT JUST A TRANSIT BUT ALSO ALSO
IF FUNDS THE- LET'S SEE. IS THE
TWENTY ONE BUS ROUTES IN PLASTER
COUNTY AND AUBURN COUNTY AS WELL
SO THIS ALSO SERVES TRANSIT
RIDERS. AND THAT'S IMPORTANT
BECAUSE WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
FISCAL RESPONSIBILITY. AS OUR
PART ACROSS OUR TALKS ABOUT IS
JUST BECAUSE IN THIS BILL YOU
COULD BACK FILL THE GENERAL FUND
WE SHOULD BE NOTED THAT. THE
SURPLUS IS NOT CONSTANT IT IS
NOT A SHORT. AND IF WE- OUR TO
FIND OURSELVES IN IT ECONOMIC
DEFICIT THE MONEY THAT GOES
DIRECTLY TO CONSTITUENTS IN
ROADWAYS AND TRANSPORTATION CAN
EVAPORATE. AND BY DE FUNDING THE
ESSENTIAL MONEY WE'RE PUTTING
TOWARDS A ROADWAY IMPROVEMENTS
THE PROGRESS WE'VE MADE A COUPLE
YEARS IS FISCALLY RESPONSIBLE.
AND AGAIN LIKE A SORE WITNESSES
JUST BECAUSE WE POSIT FOR SIX
MONTHS IS NO GUARANTEE WE BRING
IT BACK. SO YOU KNOW I
DEFINITELY IT WOULD SYMPATHIZE I
UNDERSTAND HOW HARD IT IS RIGHT
NOW AND HOW HARD IT IS AT THE
PUMP BUT THAT IS NOT BECAUSE WE
ARE PAYING FOR ROADS IT'S
BECAUSE THEY ARE CORPORATIONS
OUT THERE. WHO ARE FRACKING THE
HELL OUT OF THIS A PLANET AND
OUR TRIP TRYING TO EXTRACT EVERY
CENT A PROFIT BEGAN FROM THE
CONSUMER. SO I HAVE A VERY
SPECIFIC SOLUTION AS WELL. MADAM
CHAIR. IF I CAN. YES I WOULD
LIKE TO MAKE A MOTION TO DO
PASSES A MAN'S. IF YOU'RE READY
FOR THAT. AND I'VE RECEIVED OKAY
. I LIKE TO MOVE AMEND THE
MOTION TO BE TO PASS AS AMENDED
AND THE AMENDMENTS WILL BE THE
FOLLOWING TO ONE STRIKEOUT ALL
CURRENT CONTENTS OF THE BILL TO
IMPOSE A NEW VEHICLE RAFEAL
WHISTLES ACTED I'M NOT GONNA
HAVE MY BILL THAT WE GET THAT
DONE AS SOON AS A LIST OF KILEY
MR KILEY PRESENTING A BELL I'M
NOT GIVING YOU GUYS A VESSEL.
BUT CONSIDER SOME OTHER.
MICROPHONE THERE IS A FIRST. WE
WILL FOLLOW THE PROCEDURE AS
OUTLINED IN OUR- RULES OF ORDER
AND YOU'LL HAVE A CHANCE TO
SPEAK I PROMISE YOU ART PRESS
EIGHT THANK YOU THANK YOU. TO
IMPOSE A NEW VEHICLE FUEL
WINDFALL PROFITS TAX ON GASOLINE
SUPPLIER GROSS RECEIPTS WHEN THE
PRICE OF A GAS GALLON OF
GASOLINE IS ABNORMALLY HIGH
COMPARED TO THE PRICE OF A
BARREL OF CRUDE OIL THREE
REQUIRED THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD
TO DETERMINE TAX A TAX RATE THAT
WOULD COVER ANY GASOLINE
SUPPLIES PROFIT MARGIN THAT
EXCEEDS. A THIRTY CENTSPER
GALLON FOR REQUIRED THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION TO
DETERMINE THE COMPONENTS OF THE
PROFIT MARGIN FIVE ESTABLISH A
NEW VEHICLE FUEL WINDFALL REBATE
FUND AND REQUIRE THE WINDFALL
TAX DOLLARS TO BE PAID TO THAT
FUND SIX REQUIRED THAT THE FUNDS
TO BE PAID BACK CALIFORNIA
GASOLINE PURCHASERS VIAA
REBATES SEVEN REQUIRE THE
FRANCHISE TAX OR TO ESTABLISH
HOW TO RE DISTRIBUTE THAT
REBATE. AND EIGHT REQUIRED THE
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD AND CC
CONSULT WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT THOSE ARE AMENDMENTS
MANAGER. OKAY I ALREADY WITHDREW
THE MOTION SO. IT WAY WAY WAY
WAY WAY WAY WAY TO SECOND. HOLD
ON ONE SECOND. I'VE NEVER HAD
THIS HAPPEN SO I'M JUST ASKING
THE PARLIAMENTARIAN WHAT THAT I
WANT TO MAKE SURE WE DO THE
CORRECT PROCEDURES- BUT JUST
EVERYONE TO SLOW YOUR ROLL FOR
ONE MINUTE.
OKAY FIRST I WANT TO KNOW THAT
WE HAVE A SECOND ON MR LEE'S
MOTION FOR MISTER KALRA. AMAZON
HAS MADE A MOTION TO DELAY THAT
THE MINUTES ON THE TABLE OKAY SO
WE WILL FIRST TAKE A VOTE. ON IT
IS THERE A SECOND AYE MR FONG'S.
MOTION YEAH YEAH. OKAY WE HAVE A
SECOND. SO WILL FIRST TAKE A
VOTE ON MISTER FOX MOTION TO LAY
MISTER LEE'S. AMENDMENT ON THE
TABLE SO OF. OKAY THAT MOTION IS
NOT MISTER FX MOTION IS NOT
DEBATABLE SO WE WILL GO RIGHT TO
A ROLL CALL VOTE ON THE MOTION
BY MR FONG TO LAY THE MOTION ON
THE TABLE CAN WE HAVE A ROLL
CALL PLEASE. FRIEDMAN OF
FRIEDMAN NOW FRIEDMAN NO FONG.
FONG I BERMAN BERMAN NO
CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM I DALY.
DAVIES DAVIES I GIPSON NO GIPSON
NO KALRA. KALRA NO. THREE ME NO
HELLO. HELLO NO NAZARIAN.
NAZARIAN NO WHEN. O'DONNELL WARD
. WARD NO WICKS NO WICKS NO. SIX
SIX EIGHT FIXATE THE MOTION
FAILS IT IS A MAJORITY OF THOSE
PRESENT AND VOTING I LIKE TO BE
A MANAGER I LIKE TO MAKE A
MOTION OFFERS STEPS TO MOTION TO
MOVE THE BILL IN PRINT. ONE OF
ORDER YES. DO WE JUST DID WE
JUST HAVE MISTER LEE AND
SECONDED BY MR CALLER SO THAT'S
THE MOTION BEFORE I BOUGHT A
RIGHT NOW I'M GOING TO FIND OUT
WHICH MOTION WE TAKE FIRST IS
GOOD THANK YOU FOR THE POINT OF
ORDER ALLOW ME TO JUST FIND OUT
FOR SURE WHICH MOTION WE TAKE
FIRST. TRUST HERE THANK YOU.
OKAY WE'RE GOING TO BE TAKING UP
MR FONG. WE HAVEN'T BEEN IN
MOTION TO WE HAVE A SECOND. ON
YOUR MOTION. OKAY SO WE'RE GOING
TO BE TAKING UP MR FONG'S MOTION
FIRST- SO CAN WE HAVE A REAL
CARD I CAN OPERATE A CLOSE.
WE'RE GONNA LOVE YOU TO CLOSE
AFTER WE FINISH WITH THESE A
SUBSTITUTE MOTIONS THAT ARE ON
THE FLOOR THAT WILL GIVE YOU AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CLOSE. SO CAN WE
HAVE A ROLL CALL FOR MR FONG'S
MOTION PLEASE- FRIEDMAN. NO
FRIEDMAN NO FONG. FONG I BERMAN
BERMAN NO CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM
I DALY. DAVIES DAVIES I GIPSON
NO GIPSON NO ALL RIGHT. ALL
RIGHT NO WE THREE NO HELLO.
HELLO NO. THE VARIANCE. NAZARIAN
NO. WHEN. DONALD WARD WARD NO
WICKS WICKS NO. THREE NINE THREE
NINE THAT MOTION FAILS NOW WE'RE
GOING BACK TO THE ORIGINAL
MOTION BUT ON BOTH LEVELS FROM
THE BILL. MADAM CHAIR MAY MAY I
ASK- WE HAVE NOT SEEN THE
AMENDMENTS AND PRINT IS THERE A
WAY THAT. THE PAYMENTS ARE
AVAILABLE ARE THE AMENDMENTS
AVAILABLE TO BE SHOWN TO THE
MEMBERS I THINK WE PRUDENT
BEFORE WE VOTE ON. THIS THAT WE
ACTUALLY SEE THE AMENDMENTS AND
PRINT. AND THAT'S PURSUE AFTER
MY PHONE THAT'S PURSUANT TO RULE
SIXTY EIGHT POINT FIVE. I
REQUEST. THE MINISTRY PLACEMENT
IN THE MOMENTS IN PRINT. I'M.
THE OFF THE AUTHOR OF THE
AMENDMENTS IS OFFERING TO
PROVIDE THE AMENDMENTS AND
WRITING BUT WE WILL HAVE TO
RECESSES IN ORDER TO PROVIDE
THAT TO YOU THAT'S WHY A WILL
CRAPPIE TO RECESS. THIS IS YOUR
GOVERNMENT FOLKS RIGHT HERE.
ABSOLUTELY DISGRACEFUL.
RIGHT WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO IS
WE'RE GOING TO PASS TEMPORARILY
ON THIS ITEM WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE THE HEARING WITH OTHER
BILLS TO GIVE MISTER LEE'S STOP
A CHANCE TO BRING DOWN BY HIS
SUBSTITUTE- OF HIS AMENDMENTS TO
THE BILL AND SO WE WILL PASS
TEMPORARILY AND WILL CONTINUE
WITH THE NEXT BILL WHILE WE MAKE
THAT. WHILE WE FOR FILLED MR
FONG'S REQUEST THANK YOU. FOR
THE PEOPLE. OUR NEXT BILL IS AB
TWENTY FIVE SIXTY TWO BY MISTER
BENNETT I SEE THE AUTHOR IN
ATTENDANCE AND SIR YOU MAY
PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR
. GO AHEAD AND PROCEED YES THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR OF AS
WE OF ALL FROM A FOSSIL FUEL
ECONOMY I BELIEVE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND CALIFORNIANS WILL
BE MUCH BETTER OFF IF WE HAVE A
HEALTHY COMPETITION BETWEEN
HYDROGEN FUEL CELLS AND ELECTRIC
BATTERY TECHNOLOGY. I BELIEVE AB
TWENTY FIVE SIXTY TO HELP
ADVANCE THIS GOAL. THERE'S BEEN
A STEADY EFFORT BY SOME TO
EXPAND THE NUMBER OF HYDROGEN
FUELING STATIONS APPROVED AND
FUNDED BY THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. BUT SENSE GOVERNOR
BROWN'S EXECUTIVE ORDER IN TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHTEEN THOSE
EFFORTS HAVE NOT BEEN
SUCCESSFUL. WE HAVE STAYED AT
SIMPLY TWO HUNDRED HYDROGEN
FUELING STATIONS CURRENTLY THERE
ARE ONLY TWO HUNDRED HYDROGEN
FUELING STATIONS THAT ARE
ASSURED BY THE LEGISLATIVE
MANDATE. AND BUDGET FUNDING. THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION HAS
STATED THAT A HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
OF THOSE TWO HUNDRED. MAY
ALREADY BE ENCUMBERED IN SOME
WAY AND ONLY THIRTEEN OF THEM.
CAN SERVICE MEDIUM AND HEAVY
DUTY VEHICLES. AN EXPANDING
DEMAND FOR HYDROGEN BY PORTS AND
HEAVY DUTY TRUCKS WILL BE A
VALUABLE STIMULUS FOR US TO MAKE
GREEN ELECTROLYSIS HYDROGEN MORE
COST EFFECTIVE. AND I THINK WE
ALL RECOGNIZE THE GREEN HYDROGEN
IS THE KEY FOR HYDROGEN
TECHNOLOGY TO BECOME TRULY A
COMPETITIVE FUEL ALTERNATIVE
FUEL AS WE TRANSITION FROM
FOSSIL FUELS. CONTENTIONS THAT
LIGHT DUTY VEHICLES CANNOT
SAFELY FUEL ITS STATIONS THAT
SERVICE HEAVY DUTY TRUCKS IS
SIMPLY NOT ACCURATE. DIESEL
LIGHT DUTY CARS AND FUELED
SAFELY AT TRUCK STOPS FOR
DECADES. HI MYSELF ONLY DIESEL
RABBIT FORTY YEARS AGO AND FUEL
REGULARLY AT TRUCK STOPS ROVER
TEN YEARS. THERE IS BROAD
CONSENSUS IN THE SCIENTIFIC
COMMUNITY THAT HYDROGEN HAS MANY
VALUABLE BENEFITS FOR HEAVY DUTY
SHIPPING. EVERY DUTY TRANSPORT
AND HEAVY DUTY TRUCKING THIS
BILL DOES NOT DOWNGRADE THE
EFFORT FOR LIGHT DUTY VEHICLES
IT'S AN ATTEMPT TO BE SURE THAT
WE GET THE MAXIMUM VALUE FROM
THE TAXPAYERS INVESTMENT IN
HYDROGEN FUELING STATIONS. AT
LEAST USE THE FEW REMAINING
STATIONS TO GET STARTED ON THE
MINIMUM HYDROGEN FUELING
STATIONS NEEDED TO ATTRACT MORE
INVESTMENT. IN THE CHICKEN AND
EGG PROBLEM THAT WE HAVE NOBODY
WANTS TO BUY HYDROGEN TRUCKS IF
THERE ARE FUELING STATIONS
NOBODY WANTS TO BUILD A FUELING
STATIONS IF WE DON'T HAVE THE
TRUCKS. AND HELP HYDROGEN LAUNCH
SO IT CAN COMPETE ON ITS OWN
WITHOUT FUTURE SUBSIDIES AFTER
THE INITIAL START UP INVESTMENT
THAT MARKET ECONOMIES ALMOST
ALWAYS HAVE TO DO. THE SOLVE
THIS CHICKEN AND EGG PROBLEM SO
THANK YOU I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. UP AND ON THE
LINE TO TEST A FIRE
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE PORT OF
HUENEME ME. THANK YOU- OPERATOR
WE HAVE TWO WITNESSES BY PHONE
TRIALS PETA FOR AN ADAM IF YOU
GOT IF YOU CAN FIND THEM FOR TWO
MINUTES APIECE THANK YOU. CHILD
SUPPORT WE'RE HERE. GO AHEAD
PLEASE. YES THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ON BEHALF OF THE OXNARD HARBOR
DISTRICT IN THE QUARTER ONE
EVENING I WOULD LIKE TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY PROVIDED TESTIMONY
MY NAME IS HILD CREDIT FOR AN
ENVIRONMENTAL MANAGER FOR THE
PORT WHY NINI I WOULD LIKE TO
GIVE YOU SOME INSIGHTS INTO THE
PORTS APPROACH FOR CLEAN ENERGY
FUTURE. FIRST JUST SOME QUICK
BACKGROUND WE ARE THE ONLY DEEP
WATER COMMERCIAL SEAPORT BETWEEN
LA AND SAN FRANCISCO IN SERVICE
A CRITICAL LINK FOR AGRICULTURAL
AND AUTOMOTIVE PRODUCTS BOTH THE
CENTRAL AND SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
AND WE'RE A TOP TEN U. S. PORK
BUT REFRIGERATED CONTAINERS AND
AUTOMOBILES. THE PORT IN RECENT
YEARS HAS BEEN THE BRIGHTEST
SHINING STAR IN THE VENTURA
COUNTY ECONOMY AND WHILE THE
REST OF THE COUNTY GDP HAS
STAGNATED. SUPPORTED SUCCEEDED
IN GROWING ITS CARGO THROUGHPUT.
IT'S BENEFITS THE COMMUNITY. ALL
WHILE REDUCING ITS ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACT ON SURROUNDING
COMMUNITIES. SINCE TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT. DIESEL PARTICULATE MATTER
EMISSIONS IN THE PORT HAVE
DECREASED BY ALMOST 80% AND IN
NOVEMBER OF LAST YEAR OR BOARD
OF HARBOR COMMISSIONERS APPROVED
A RESOLUTION COMMITTING THE PORT
TO A FUTURE OF ZERO MISSION
OPERATIONS. SINCE TWENTY
THIRTEEN THE COURT HAS BEEN
IMPLEMENTING A LONG TERM
SUSTAINABILITY PROGRAM AND IN
TWENTY FOURTEEN CONSTRUCTED A
HIGH VOLTAGE SYSTEM ALLOWING
OCEAN GOING VESSEL TO PLUG INTO
QUEEN CREEK POWER WELL DOCTOR.
SHORE POWER PROJECT HAS SHOWN
INCREDIBLE BENEFITS IN REDUCING
AIR QUALITY IMPACTS AND THE
COURT IS CONTINUING THIS
ELECTRIFICATION WITH THE
INSTALLATION OF ADDITIONAL
INFRASTRUCTURE TO POWER. OTHER
PIECES OF HEAVY DUTY EQUIPMENT
INCLUDING YOUR TRACTORS CRANES
AND TUGBOAT. IN OUR TEN YEARS OF
OPERATING THIS TYPE OF EQUIPMENT
WE'VE LEARNED THAT THE
CHALLENGES OF TRANSITIONING AWAY
FROM FOSSIL FUELS GO BEYOND THE
EQUIPMENT ITSELF. AND THAT THE
FUELING INFRASTRUCTURE IS ONE OF
THE MOST EXPENSIVE AND MOST
CRITICAL PIECES OF THE PUZZLE.
WE SEE OUR CLEAN ENERGY FUTURE
AS ONE THAT RECOGNIZES THIS
INFRASTRUCTURE CHALLENGE AND
ADDRESSES IT THROUGH CAREFULLY
ENGINEERED INVESTMENT IN CLEAN
ENERGY FUTURE. BITING BOTH LONG
TERM SUSTAINABILITY IMPROVEMENTS
IN THINGS LIKE CLEAN GREEN
HYDROGEN AS WELL AS- CLEAN GRID
POWER. FROM THE STANDPOINT THE
BENEFITS TO THE COMMUNITY AND
THE ENVIRONMENT WHICH ARE
INEXTRICABLY LINKED A ZERO
EMISSION FUTURE FOUNDED IN THE
COURTS WILL HELP BE PROVIDED BY
THIS LEGISLATION AND ALLOW FOR
THE EVOLUTION OF LOCAL PROJECTS.
THAT CAN ACCELERATE INNOVATION
ALL WHILE REDUCING EMISSIONS AT
THE SAME TIME AND OUR PORT
COMMUNITIES THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. HELLO MADAM BAKER ON BEHALF OF
THE OSCAR HARBOR DISTRICT
REPORTED BY NAMING I WOULD LIKE
TO THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE THIS
TESTIMONY ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE SIX
TWO. MY NAME IS ADAM BEGA AMBIK
MEDIA OUTREACH SPECIALIST FOR
THE PORT WHY NINI REPORTED
RECENTLY BEGAN AN IN DEPTH
TECHNICAL ANALYSIS OF ENERGY
SUPPLIES TO OPERATE WITH ZERO
EMISSIONS WE SEE THE NEED FOR A
COMBINATION OF THE EASTFIELD
TECHNOLOGY IN THAT BATTERY
ELECTRIC WILL NOT BE THE RIGHT
FUEL FOR EVERY APPLICATION. THE
QUICKNESS LIKE SHIPS IN LONG
HAUL TRUCKING WILL BE BETTER
SERVED BY FEEL LIKE GREEN
HYDROGEN THIS REPORT TENER
DISTRIBUTION NETWORK POWERED BY
GREEN HYDROGEN IN CRITICAL
LOCATIONS LIKE THE COURT OF
ARMENIAN WILL ENABLE THE
TRANSITION AWAY FROM FOSSIL
FUELS TO BE ACHIEVED MORE
QUICKLY AND WITH GREATER
BENEFITS OUR LOCAL COMMUNITY.
THE OXNARD REGION OF THE NUMBER
SMALL. THAT A SYSTEM OF SUPPLY
CHAIN PROCESS. SUCH AS TRUCKING
COMPANIES AND OTHER SMALL
MANUFACTURING BUSINESSES. THESE
COMPANIES DO NOT HAVE THE BAND
WITH THE TIME OR THE EXPERTISE
TO PURSUE INCENTIVE FUNDS ARE
TRANSITIONING THEIR EQUIPMENT.
ADDITIONALLY AND PERHAPS MORE
IMPORTANTLY THEY DO NOT HAVE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDED THE POWER
CLEAN EQUIPMENT. MANY OF THESE
INDEPENDENTLY OWNED TRUCKS ARE
DRIVEN HOME AT THE END OF THE
DAY. ARE PARKED IN FRONT OF A
HOME. PHONE SURE AN EQUITABLE
ACCESS TO CLEAN ENERGY
INFRASTRUCTURE WILL BE CRITICAL
TO ENSURING THAT COMMUNITY LIKE
OXNARD. AND PORT HUENEME ME ARE
NOT LEFT BEHIND IN THE CLEAN
ENERGY TRANSITION. ACCESS TO
INCENTIVE FUNDING FOR EQUIPMENT
PLUS THE INFRASTRUCTURE ENABLING
THE UTILIZATION. OF A REGIONAL
CLEAN ENERGY HUB MICHAEL GREEN
HYDROGEN FUEL IN CENTER WILL
HELP ENSURE THAT THOSE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THAT HISTORICALLY HAVE
HAD. THE LEAST ACCESS TO CLEAN
ENERGY OPPORTUNITY WILL BE GIVEN
EQUITABLE OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
FUTURE OF INTER COUNTIES CLEAN
ENERGY ECONOMY. ADDITIONALLY WE
SEE A MAJOR OPPORTUNITY TO HELP
REINVIGORATE THE HOLLY MIDDLE
CLASS OF INTER COUNTY WITH THE
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT. AND JOB
TRAINING. FOCUSED AROUNDA CLEAN
ENERGY FUTURE FOR VENTURA
COUNTY. WE ALL KNOW THE VENTURA
COUNTY HISTORICALLY HAD A
THRIVING POSSIBILITY STRUCTURE
INDUSTRY. WE FEEL THE TIME HAS
COME AND URGENTLY NEEDED TO
ADDRESS THE CLIMATE CRISIS TO
BEGIN GROWING THE CLEAN ENERGY
INDUSTRY IN THE COUNTY OF
VENTURA. AND THIS BILL ONE ABLE
GREEN HYDROGEN TO BE CENTRAL TO
THAT TRANSITION FOR SPECIFIC
APPLICATIONS. IN OUR COMMITMENT
TO THE COMMUNITY WE FEEL AS
THOUGH GREEN HYDROGEN MUST BE
THE ONLY OPTION RELATED TO HIGH
DEMAND FIELDS GREY AND BLUE
HYDROGEN DO NOT MEET THE
STANDARDS OF SUSTAINABILITY. BUT
THE PORT WILL REQUIRE AT THE
STEWARD OF A VERY UNIQUE AND
VERY SPECIAL CONCERN BY MEN.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU WERE GOING
TO MOVE NOW TO THE OPPOSITE TO
OPPOSITION WE HAVE FIRST UP-
SOMEBODY IN PERSON FROM THE CULT
FROM WE HAVE TO RESET A- COOK
FROM A CALIFORNIA HYDROGEN
COALITION. WELCOME.
MIKE YEAH THAT MAKES SENSE I'M
MAY I TROUBLE ONE OF THE
SERGEANTS TO PASS OUT A DOCUMENT
BEFORE I. WELL THANK YOU FOR
THAT GRACE TURN MEMBERS TERESA
KOK HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA HYDROGEN COALITION IT
IS SINCERELY WITH A HEAVY HEART
THAT I COME HERE TODAY IN
OPPOSITION- OF THE LETTERS THAT
ARE BEING DISTRIBUTED TO YOU NOW
IS A COALITION OF MORE THAN
THIRTY HYDROGEN AFFILIATES THAT
HAVE SEEN AND REJECTED THIS
PROPOSAL BY THE ENERGY
COMMISSION AND WHILE I DON'T
SPEAK FOR ALL OF THEM HERE TODAY
I DO WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU
ARE AWARE OF THIS PROCEEDING
ACTIVELY HAPPENING AT THE ENERGY
COMMISSION AND THAT YOU ARE.
AWARE OF THESE CONCERNS AND- ALL
JOB RIGHT AND I WOULD OFFER THAT
THIS BILL IS UNNECESSARY AND
HARMFUL TO A MARKET THAT IS
STILL TRYING TO FIND ITS FOOTING
IN CALIFORNIA AS ARE A TERRIFIC
BUDGET STAFF HAVE NOTED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S TEN BILLION DOLLAR
AYE PROPOSAL LAST YEAR AND THIS
YEAR 62% OF THOSE ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLE INFRASTRUCTURE AND
VEHICLE DOLLARS ARE GOING TO
HEAVY DUTY SO I WOULD OFFER TO
THIS COMMITTEE WE DO NOT HAVE A
HEAVY DUTY FUNDING PROBLEM WE
HAVE A HYDROGEN ALLOCATION
PROBLEM AT THE AIR RESOURCES
BOARD AND WITH THE ENERGY
COMMISSION. OF THE MORE THAN SIX
BILLION DOLLARS AND THAT IS
BEING PUT FORWARD TO ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLE INFRASTRUCTURE
SPECIFICALLY BEARD THROUGH THE
STATE OR ARE INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITIES OR SETTLEMENTS WITH
COMPANIES LIKE ENERGY AND
VOLKSWAGEN. THREE POINT 7% OF
THOSE DOLLARS ARE BEING DIRECTED
TOWARD HYDROGEN INFRASTRUCTURE.
SO AGAIN I WOULD OFFER WE DO NOT
HAVE A HEAVY DUTY FUNDING
PROBLEM WE HAVE AN ALLOCATION
PROBLEM IN THE STATE. WE ARE
DEFINITELY NOT HELPING BE HEAVY
DUTY NETWORK BY OBLITERATING IT
LIGHT AND MEDIUM DUTY VEHICLE
INFRASTRUCTURE. SWITCHING GEARS
VERY QUICKLY WHO DOES THIS
PROPOSAL HARM THIS PROPOSAL
HARMS THE 40% OF CALIFORNIANS
THAT LIVE IN APARTMENT COMPLEXES
WHERE CHARGING INSTALLATION IS
GOING TO BE. IN ALL LIKELIHOOD
DELAYED AND NOT DEVELOPED IN
AMOUNT SIGNIFICANT ENOUGH TO
MEET THE NEED THE 13% OF SUPER
COMMUTERS THAT LIVE IN
CALIFORNIA AND HAVE LENGTHY
COMMUTES TO AND FROM WORK EVERY
SINGLE DAY. ALSO OUR MEDIUM DUTY
VEHICLES THEIR RESOURCES BOARD
SCOPING PLANS INITIAL- ESTIMATES
FIND THAT IN THE MEDIUM DUTY
VEHICLE CLASS MORE THAN 50% OF
THESE VEHICLES ARE EXPECTED TO
BE FUEL CELL THEY'RE NOT GOING
TO BE REFUELING AT THE PORT OF
LA OR LONG BEACH THEY NEED THESE
I HAVEN'T. PASSENGER VEHICLE
STATIONS THAT WERE ALL VERY
FAMILIAR WITH AND I'M SORRY YOUR
OVER THE TIME I'M SURE. THAT'S
JUST YOU KNOW I WOULD SAY ALSO A
VOTE FOR THIS BILL IS PUTTING UP
ANOTHER BARRIER TO THE
TRANSITION OF THE OIL AND GAS
INDUSTRY INTO HYDROGEN- AND
AGAIN ALL THE VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES THAT THIS COMMITTEE
IS MOST INTERESTED IN PROTECTING
IN THE ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE
DISCUSSION. IS HARMED BY THIS
BILL THANK YOU CHAIR FOR YOUR
GRACE THANK YOU AND WE DO HAVE
ANOTHER SPEAKER IN OPPOSITION-
THEY ARE ON THE PHONE- IT IS
SERAPH AT SEVEN OPERATOR IF YOU
CAN PLEASE FIND MISS FITZSIMMONS. HELLO I'M AVAILABLE FOR
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GREAT THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS SEARCH
THE PLAN IN THE POLICY DIRECTOR
AT THE CALIFORNIA HYDROGEN
COUNCIL A TRADE ASSOCIATION THAT
REPRESENTS OVER ONE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY FIVE MEMBER ORGANIZATIONS
WORKING TO COMMERCIALIZE
RENEWABLE HYDROGEN ACROSS THE
ENERGY AND TRANSPORTATION SPACE
BECAUSE I LIKE TO START BY
THICKENING EVERYTHING THAT TREAT
THE COOK IT'S SAD BECAUSE
UNFORTUNATELY THIS IS THE TIME
WHERE HYDROGEN SHOULD BE UNITED
WERE AS WE ARE WITH CHD. AND NOT
DIVIDED WE SHOULD ALL BE WORKING
TOWARDS IMPROVING OUR
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR TO BE
DECARBONISE DEMETER AIR QUALITY
GOALS AND WE CAN'T BE DOING THAT
IF WE CONTINUE THE CONVERSATION
CAME OUT LIGHT DUTY OF COVERED
FOR HYDROGEN REFUELING I'M A
FUEL CELL ELECTRIC FUEL CELL
ELECTRIC VEHICLE DRIVER MYSELF
AND I'M TELLING YOU THE ACCESS
TO STATIONS IS CRITICAL FOR
LIGHT DUTY DRIVERS. THE IDEA
THAT HEAVY DUTY THE ONLY STATE
WITH HYDROGEN IS THAT CORRECT
ALTHOUGH WE HAVE MEMBERS IN
HEAVY DUTY THAT WE FULLY SUPPORT
FUNDING FOR HEAVY DUTY STATION
BUT THE VERY SEPARATE POCKET
THAT NEEDS TO REMAIN FUNDED AND
FUNDED WITH PARITY AT THE
COMPARED TO BATTERY ELECTRIC
VEHICLES ON THE LIGHT DUTY SIDE
IT IS THERE'S NO PARITY WITH
BATTERY ELECTRIC VEHICLE. THAT'S
CHARGING THEIR VEHICLES ON THE
GRID AND THE GREATEST ON AVERAGE
ONLY 33% RENEWABLE WHERE YOU
LOOK AT ALL THE HYDROGEN FUELING
STATIONS AVAILABLE MAJORITY ARE
AVAILABLE TO LOW CARBON FUEL
STANDARD FUND WHICH REQUIRES
THEM TO BE A CERTAIN PERCENTAGE
OF RENEWABLE FUELAND MAJORITY
OF THOSE STATIONS ARE 90%
RENEWABLE OR GREATER. THE TO
START GIVING FUND FOR THE
BATTERY ELECTRIFIED FOR LIGHT
DUTY VEHICLES WERE ON AVERAGE IS
ONLY 33% RENEWABLE WILL REALLY
NOT BEATING OUR DECARBONISATION
AIR QUALITY GOALS THE DISCUSSION
SAYING BUT LIKE IF HE IS FUNDED
IS NOT CORRECT CALIFORNIANS NEED
ANOTHER OPTION FOR THEIR MISSION
VEHICLES THAT REQUIRE THAT
REQUIRE LONG RANGE OPTIONS SHORT
REFUELLING AND ALSO AN
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE A DIVERSITY
IN OPTIONS FOR GREITENS TO BE
PLEASE. RECOMMEND A NO VOTE
AMONG THE MEN DID BECAUSE WE DO
SUPPORT FUELING AIRPORTS WE DO
IDENTIFY THE COMMUNITIES NEAR
THE PORT NEED AN OPTION TO PUT
FORTY SHILLINGS. NEAR COURT NOT
AT WORK. BECAUSE IT WOULD BE
SAFE FOR LIGHT DUTY VEHICLES ARE
GOING TO BE. LOCATION AT. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME TODAY. I HOPE
THAT YOU. WHAT AMENDED THAT TELL
NEAR. OF BE A CO ITSELF THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND NOW
WE'RE TO A TESTIMONY FOR OREGON
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM. SEEING
NOBODY. IN PER TO TEST OPERATOR
CAN YOU PLEASE OPEN UP THE
PHONES FOR SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
FOR AB. TWENTY FIVE SIXTY TWO.
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK ON AB
TWENTY FIVE SIX TWO PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN THEY ARE AT THIS TIME.
AND WE'LL START WITH LINE THREE
SIXTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. OKAY
THE DROPPED OUT OF Q. ONE THREE
SEVENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THREE SEVENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. OKAY WE'LL MOVE ON KNOWING
HOW TO RECHARGE IT. NINE THREE
SEVENTY SIX WE GOT. GARY YES
PLEASE GO AHEAD HI SIR I'M GONNA
I'M GONNA DIFFER ON THE- THE
CURRENT BILL THANK YOU. LINE
THREE NINETY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS MICHAEL PIMENTEL OF THE
HALF OF THE PACIFIC MERCHANT
SHIPPING ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU. NINE ONE SEVENTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES HI MY NAME
IS JONATHAN PARKER SANDRA ON THE
OFFICE REDSHIRTING WE ARE IN
OPPOSITION OF THE BILL THANK YOU
. LINE FOUR HUNDRED PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I AM IN OPPOSITION A. B.
SIXTEEN THIRTY EIGHT I MEAN I'M
IN SUPPORT AT SIXTEEN THIRTY
EIGHT THAT TO REMOVE THE GAS
OKAY THIS IS THE WRONG OPERATOR
PLEASE MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE
THE CORRECT PEOPLE FOR THE
CORRECT BILL IN Q. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NINE ONE NINETY TO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
STEVE WITH A TWO ZERO WOULD BE
OPERATE PIALA LARGEST NETWORK OF
HYDROGEN STATIONS IN CALIFORNIA
AND WE ARE OPPOSED TO THE BILL.
IT DOES NOT CONSIDER THE PROPER
PLACEMENT OF STATIONS FOR LIGHT
DUTY VEHICLES AND WE SUPPORT
HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES AND THEIR
APPROACH TO THE STATE WILL BE
CRITICAL BUT THEY DSERVE THEIR
OWN FUNDING STREAM. THAT IS
ALREADY- EFFORT UNDERWAY FOR
THAT TODAY BUT TO TAKE MONEY
FROM THE LIGHT DUTY VEHICLE
INFRASTRUCTURE IS THE WRONG WAY
TO DO IT. TRYING TO NINETY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. IT GABRIELLE
INGRAM I AM IN OPPOSITION OF THE
BILL. ONE SIXTY PLEASE GO AHEAD
. YOU CAN REALLY START. AFTER
COUNTY. ONE FOUR ZERO TWO GO
AHEAD. FOUR ZERO TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. FOUR ZERO TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. FIND
ONE EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YEAH HI MY NAME'S STEVEN
MACKINTOSH I'M A FUEL CELL
ELECTRIC VEHICLE DRIVER HERE IN
SANTA BARBARA CALIFORNIA AND
MANAGING PARTNER OF HYDROGEN
POWER PARTNERS AND I URGE YOU TO
VOTE NO ON AB TWENTY FIVE SIXTY
TWO. NINE THREE SEVENTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AFTER MY PRIDE
PLASTER COUNTY NO ON AB TWENTY
FIVE SIXTY TWO THANK YOU. NINE
THREE SIXTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD
. HI SIR WILLIAM I HOMES AB TWO
FIVE SIX TWO THANK YOU. THE
MANAGER WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE'RE GOING TO TAKE
THE DISCUSSION NOW TO THE
COMMITTEE TO SEE IF THERE'S ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS ON THIS
BILL FOR THE PHONE NUMBERS
MISTER CUNNINGHAM. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR. I THINK THIS IS A
QUESTION FOR. THE OPPOSITION I
SHARE THE CONCERN THAT WE ARE
UNDER FUNDING HYDROGEN
INFRASTRUCTURE RELATIVE TO OTHER
FORMS OF ZERO EMISSIONS
VEHICLES- I THINK HYDROGEN HAS
TO BE PART OF THE ANSWER
ESPECIALLY WHEN WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT. POLLING THINGS HEAVY
PAYLOADS SHIPPING SIMPLY BECAUSE
THE WEIGHT OF THE BATTERIES FOR
EV'S BECOMES OF. ENGINEERING
PROBLEM RIGHT. SO I'M I TOTALLY
GET THE WILL OR NOT FUNDING THIS
WELL ENOUGH AND THE AUTHOR PUT
IT WELL WHEN HE SAID WE HAVE A
CHECK OR A PROBLEM I THINK
THAT'S RIGHT. BUT AS I
UNDERSTAND THIS BILL. THIS IS
SAYING OKAY WE'VE GOT A- GIVEN
PART OF MONEY THAT'S FINITE. AND
WE'RE GOING TO PRIORITIZE A TO
PROJECTS. LOCATED AT PORTS WHICH
MAKES SENSE BECAUSE YOU GOT A
SHIP. IN THE INLAND FROM A PORT.
OF FUELING STATIONS THAT SERVE
MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY TRUCKS
WHICH MAKES SENSE BECAUSE THAT'S
WERE HYDROGENS THE MOST.
EFFICACIOUS AND PROJECTS ALONG
FEDERALLY DESIGNATED OR STATE
DESIGNATED. OF GOODS MOVEMENT
HIGHWAYS WHICH MAKES SENSE TO ME
AS WELL SO I GUESS MY QUESTION
FOR YOU IS. WHAT WHAT'S YOUR
PROBLEM WITH ASKING TO
PRIORITIZE THINGS AND IN THAT
WAY IT SEEMS LIKE A LOGICAL
SEQUENCE TO ME GIVEN WE HAVE
THIS FINITE CONCERN OR IT'S
PERFECTLY VALID ANSWER THAT WE
JUST NEED MORE MONEY GOING INTO
HYDROGEN INFRASTRUCTURE. A
STATEMENT WITH WHICH I AGREE
WHOLEHEARTEDLY. THAT'S A GOOD
QUESTION ASSEMBLY MAN I THINK
IT'S A LITTLE BIT OF BOTH- YOU
KNOW THREE POINT 7% OF FUNDING
BEING DIRECTED TOWARD HYDROGEN
AND THIS MOM AND I'M TRYING TO
FIND FUEL ECONOMY AND WITH
EVERYTHING THAT'S HAPPENING- IN
EUROPE AND OURS THEIR MISSION
VEHICLE SEEMS A LITTLE. ABSURD
SO I DO THINK THERE IS A NEED TO
REALLY TRY TO LOOK AT WIDE ARE
FUNDING PERCENTAGES ARE. BUT
THEN ALSO I WILL SAY THAT I'D AS
IT RELATES TO THE LIGHT DUTY
MARKET YOU HAVE AT LEAST THREE
OF THE BIGGEST NAMES VEHICLE
MANUFACTURERS WITH
COMMERCIALIZED VEHICLES FOR SALE
ON THE ROAD NOW AND WE DON'T
WANT TO PULL THE RUG OUT FROM
UNDERNEATH THEM IN AN
EXPECTATION. OF A STATE WIDE
FUELING NETWORK THEY CAN SERVICE
THOSE VEHICLES. SECOND THING
THAT I WOULD OFFER THAT I THINK
SOMETIMES GETS LOST IN THIS
SPACE IS WHAT HAPPENS WITH
MEDIUM DUTY VEHICLE SO WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT LIKE CLASS THREE
TO CLASS SIX TRUCKS CONSTRUCTION
WORKERS BOX TRUCKS VANS AT
CETERA. THE IDEA THAT THESE
VEHICLES ARE GOING TO RE FUEL AT
THE PORT OR AT THE FREEWAY INNER
CHANGE DOESN'T REALLY ACCURATELY
OFF REFLECT WHAT MEDIUM DUTY
VEHICLES ARE DOING ON THE ROAD
THEY ARE IN THE COMMUNITY THEY
ARE GOING TO PROJECTS THEIR
REFUELLING AT THE CORNER GAS
STATION THAT YOU AND I USE FOR A
PASSENGER VEHICLES. AND SO
YOU'VE GOT ON ONE HAND THERE
RESOURCES BOARD MAKING
STATEMENTS AND COMMITMENTS ABOUT
THE AVAILABILITY OF FUELING
INFRASTRUCTURE AND CALLING FOR
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE
REQUIREMENTS THAT ARE GOING TO
DEPEND ON THESE VEHICLES WHILE
AT THE SAME TIME OUR INVESTMENT
IN THE FUELING INFRASTRUCTURE
ITSELF. IS NOT AT ALL ON PACE
WITH WHITES IN A REGULATORS ARE
SAYING WILL BE AVAILABLE. THAT
HELPS ANSWER. ANYWAY MISTER BUMP
. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR- ALLEN I
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR-
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL I THINK
IT IT TO. ASSAM IMPORTANT
QUESTIONS AND I AYE I- THINK OF
MISTER BENNETT YOU KNOW- THAT-
WE SEE EYE TO EYE ON- THE
EXPANSION AND DEVELOPMENT OF- A
GREEN HYDROGEN IN THE STATE IT'S
AN EXTREMELY IMPORTANT- PRIORITY
WE ARE- HOPEFULLY MOVING FORWARD
ON SOME OF THAT- FUNDING FOR
GREEN HYDROGEN IN THE BUDGET-
THIS YEAR- BUT WE REALLY COULD
USE A LOT MORE THAN OTHER PLACES
IN THE WORLD I THINK OR JUMPING
AHEAD OF US. OFF ON THAT- I ALSO
SUPPORT THE GOAL OF EXPANDING
MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY- A
HYDROGEN VEHICLES AND THEIR
ACCESS TO FUEL- I THINK THAT'S
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT BUT MIKE MY
CONCERN WITH THE BILL AND THE
REASON I'M GONNA. LAY OFF TODAY
IS THAT I THINK THAT IT- THE
BILL AS IT'S CURRENTLY WRITTEN.
I'M IS GOING TO DRAW MONEY AWAY
FROM THE LIGHT DUTY VEHICLE
SECTOR. ALL I KNOW THAT'S NOT
YOUR INTENTION AT LEAST AS YOU
KNOW WE'VE TO DISCUSS THE- OTHER
BILL THAT'S NOT YOUR INTENTION-
AND I APPRECIATE THAT. YOU'VE
AGREED TO CONTINUE TO WORK ON
LANGUAGE TO TRY AND- AVOID THAT-
THAT THAT OUTCOME. BUT I THINK-
AS- HAS BEEN HURT THIS AFTERNOON
THAT. WE YOU KNOW I AGREE WITH
THE SENTIMENT THAT'S BEEN
EXPRESSED- THAT WE NEED TO BE
VERY VERY. CONSCIENTIOUS ABOUT-
NOT HURTING THAT SECTOR OF THE
HYDROGEN. MARKET THIS IS A-
COMPLICATED WEB OF FUNDING- IN
MY VIEW IT'S BEEN UNDERFUNDED
FOR- FOR QUITE SOME TIME AND
THAT IS LEADING TO- OF THIS
CONFLICT OVER WHO'S GONNA GET
THE FEW DOLLARS. THAT OF THAT
THAT THAT ARE AVAILABLE- I WISH
THAT WEREN'T THE CASE BUT- YOU
KNOW SOME OF THIS IS THAT- A
COMPETITION OVER. SCARCE DOLLARS
AND- I THINK IT'S VERY VERY
IMPORTANT FOR US TO CONTINUE. TO
PRIORITIZE THE UC LAKE VEHICLE
MARKET IT- AS HAS BEEN SAID
THERE'S BEEN A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT
OF IN. VESTMENT IN THAT SECTOR
AND- WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE NETWORK IS BUILT
THAT WILL SERVICE THE VEHICLES.
THAT MANUFACTURERS ARE WILLING
TO PRODUCE THAT SAID AGAIN I
WANNA MAKE SURE IT'S UNDERSTOOD
THAT I DO SUPPORT EXPANSION OF
THE MEDIUM. AND HEAVY DUTY
VEHICLE SECTOR AND SO THERE'S
LOTS OF WORK TO BE DONE THERE
TOO THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE GOING TO
DO HERE- AND- I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE TO.
DISCUSS THIS WITH YOU. OKAY- ANY
OTHER COMMENTS BEFORE WE LET THE
AUTHOR CLOSE. OKAY SEE NONE
MISTER BENNETT WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE I WOULD AND IF IT IF IT
WITH THE CHAIRS INTELLIGENCE- I
WOULD LIKE TO RESTORE AND I HAD
PLEASE RESPOND TO SOME OF THESE
COMMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN MADE
JUST BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE VERY
MANY OPPORTUNITIES WHERE WE CAN
AS A GROUP TALK ABOUT- IT
IMPORTANT LEGISLATION LIKE THIS.
I'LL TRY TO BE BRIEF AND MAKE A
NUMBER OF POINTS NUMBER ONE AS
YOU SAID THE WORLD IS AHEAD OF
US IN TERMS OF HYDROGEN SO I
AGREE WE'RE NOT MAKING A
SIGNIFICANT ENOUGH COMMITMENT TO
HYDROGENSO AS A MISTER
CUNNINGHAM JUST POINTED OUT- HE
WANTS AND I THINK VIRTUALLY
EVERYBODY HERE WANTS MORE
FUNDING FOR HYDROGEN AS MANY AS
AS WE MOVE FORWARD. THERE'S AN
INTERESTING THING FOR SHOULD BE
AWARE OF IN THE LEGISLATION WAS
PASSED IN TWENTY THIRTEEN THE
CALL FOR THE HUNDRED HYDROGEN
FUELING STATIONS THAT THEN
GOVERNOR BROWN IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN TOOK TO TWO HUNDRED. IT
DOESN'T DEFINE WHAT KIND OF
HYDROGEN STATION BUILDER JUST
SAYS PUBLIC. JUST AS PUBLIC
FUELING STATIONS NOW IF IT'S AS
JUST PUBLIC FUELING STATIONS AND
YET THERE HAS BEEN I THINK AT A
SENSE THAT DOES ALL HAVE TO BE
LIGHT DUTY AND THAT'S IN FACT
VIRTUALLY WHAT'S HAPPENED IS
THEY HAVE BECOME LIGHT DUTY EVEN
THOUGH THERE'S NO- THERE'S NO
REQUIREMENT THAT THEY BE LIGHT
DUTY AND IT'S JUST SIMPLY THE
INTERPRETATION. OF THE ENERGY
COMMISSION TO OF SAID HEY PUBLIC
PROBABLY MEANS LIGHT DUTY AND
HEAVY THEY THEY HAVE MOVED THAT
DIRECTION I WITH THAT SO THE
MOST IMPORTANT THING THAT I'VE
HEARD HERE THAT I THINK IS A
MISSTATEMENT IN TERMS OF WHERE
WE ARE IS. THIS TAKES MONEY AWAY
FROM LIGHT DUTY. IF THIS
PROPOSAL ROLLS OUT THE WAY I
THINK IT SHOULD. THERE SHOULD BE
THE SAME NUMBER OF LIGHT DUTY
STATIONS. WITH THIS OR WITHOUT
THIS THE ONLY DIFFERENCE IS.
PERHAPS TWENTY OF THEM WILL BE
LIGHT DUTY STATIONS IN
CONJUNCTION WITH HEAVY AND
MEDIUM DUTY STATIONS. THAT DOES
NOT SEEM LIKE THE DEATH KNELL
FOR. LIGHT DUTY STATIONS IF THEY
HAVE A STENCH OF BILLY A HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY THAT HAVE BEEN
APPROVED IT'S JUST A SMALL
NUMBER THAT WOULD THEN. HAVE
BOTH BUT IT WOULD SEND A MESSAGE
THAT WE ARE SERIOUS ABOUT MAKING
THE MINIMUM INVESTMENT IN
HYDROGEN INFRASTRUCTURE. SO THAT
WE CAN ALSO LAUNCH IN THAT
SECTOR AS WELL AS LAUNCHING
LIGHT DUTY WE HAVE AT LEAST MADE
SOME MINIMUM INVESTMENT.
EVERYBODY HERE ARE MANY PEOPLE
HERE INCLUDING MYSELF WOULD LIKE
IT TO BE LARGER. THANK THAT THE
LIGHT DUTY- MARKET IS GOING TO
GO FASTER THAN WHAT A. R. B. AS
IS- SUGGESTING WHAT CC IS MAKING
THEIR DECISIONS ON. BUT THE
IMPORTANT THING FOR US TO
REMEMBER IS THAT C. ECT ENERGY
COMMISSION IS THE DECISION
MAKER. ON HOW MANY LIGHT DUTY
STATIONS ARE GONNA BE OUT THERE.
AND THEY HAVE STATED OVER AND
OVER TWO HUNDRED IS MORE THAN
ENOUGH. FOR THE NEXT NUMBER OF
YEARS. AND EVERY EFFORT TO TRY
TO GO BEYOND THAT HAS FAILED. SO
AS A NUMBER OF YOU HAVE SAID WE
HAVE A LIMITED RESOURCE THE ONLY
THING WE'RE SURE OF IS THERE'S
GOING TO BE TWO HUNDRED. THIS
BILL SIMPLY SAYS IF THERE'S ONLY
GONNA BE TWO HUNDRED AND WE'VE
ALREADY BUILT A LOT OF LIGHT
DUTY SHOULD WE HAVE SOME OF
THEM. BE BOTH LIGHT DUTY AND
HEAVY DUTY AT THE SAME TIME.
SHOULDN'T THEY BE LOOK AT JUST I
THINK IT'S THE BEST INVESTMENT
WITH THE REMAINING AMOUNT OF
MONEY NOW THEN WE CAN ALL GO
OUT. AND AS I'VE EVER HAD SAID
TO SOME OF YOU WE CAN ALL GO OUT
AND WHEN YOU HAVE. A HEAVY DUTY.
INFRASTRUCTURE MOVING FORWARD
AND HEAVY DUTY INDUSTRY INVOLVED
THEY WILL BE PARTNERS. IN
PUSHING FOR GREEN. HYDROGEN TO
MOVE FORWARD I REALLY WELCOME
THE FACT IT IS VERY RARE BUT YOU
HEARD THE PORT OF HUENEME ME
TESTIFIED TODAY. THAT THEY ARE
COMMITTED TO GOING A 100% GREEN
HYDROGEN YOU DON'T HAVE INDUSTRY
SAYING THAT TO US VERY OFTEN.
THAT'S THE PARTNERSHIP THAT
LIGHT DUTY VEHICLES NEED TO MOVE
FORWARD. SO FINALLY I WOULD JUST
SAY THAT- I HOPE YOU'LL CONSIDER
THE FACT THAT- STATEMENTS LIKE
OBLITERATE THE LIGHT DUTY.
VEHICLE MARKET. IS VERY HE HAS
IS THAT OVER STATEMENT RELATIVE
TO WHERE WE ARE. NO ONE'S GOING
TO GO TO THE PORCH TO FUEL UP AS
IF THE ONLY PLACE YOU CAN FUEL
UP HERE BY GOING TO A PART. OF
IT AND- SO. I JUST WANT TO
EMPHASIZE YOU HAVE THE
ADMINISTRATION OF SUBSTANTIALLY
HAS LOCKED US AT THE TWO HUNDRED
WHAT ARE WE GONNA DO WITH THOSE
TWO HUNDRED. I THINK COMMON
SENSE SAYS AT LEAST SOME OF THEM
SHOULD BE. HEAVY DUTY MEDIUM
DUTY AND LIGHT DUTY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR LETTING ME THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR LETTING ME
YEAH GO ON I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN IPHONE. THANK YOU AND I
WANT TO COMMEND THE AUTHOR FOR
HIS PASSION ABOUT THIS I HAVE TO
JUST CONFESSED TO ALL OF YOU
THAT. ONE I FLY FROM BURBANK ON
MONDAY MORNINGS USUALLY MISTER
BENNETT IS SITTING ON THE
AIRPLANE NEXT TO ME. AND ALMOST
EVERY TIME AS SOON AS WE SIT
DOWN HE TURNS TO ME AND SAYS CAN
I TALK TO FOR A FEW MINUTES
ABOUT HYDROGEN. US SO THIS IS
WHAT HE HAS BEEN THINKING ABOUT
NONSTOP. ALL YOU YEAR AND LAST
YEAR. ADDED SOMETHING THAT HE'S
VERY COMMITTED TO AND VERY
PASSIONATE ABOUT AND THAT'S VERY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE THIS IS A BIG
SUBJECT. AND A LOT OF OUR
DISCUSSIONS WITH OUR CLEAN
VEHICLE. THE COMMITMENT IN
CALIFORNIA ARE ABOUT HOW WE
INVEST IN INFRASTRUCTURE THAT'S
SUCH A HUGE PART OF MAKING SURE.
THAT PEOPLE FEEL COMFORTABLE
ENOUGH IN TRANSITIONING TO CLEAN
VEHICLES. AND WE ALSO KNOW THAT
SOME OF OUR MOST DIFFICULT TO
DECARBONISE. AND SOME OF OUR
MOST POLLUTING VEHICLES ARE
THOSE BIG CLASS EIGHT TRUCKS IN
OUR DRAYAGE TRUCKS. AND OUR PORT
CORRIDORS ARE ECONOMIC JUSTICE.
AND THOSE HEALTH IMPACTS FOR
YEARS SO THIS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT CONVERSATION. AND I
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR. AND HIS
COMMITMENT NOT ONLY TO MAKING
SURE WE FOCUS ON THOSE FOR THE
MOST QUARTERS KNOWS VEHICLES.
BUT ALSO MAKING SURE THAT WE
DON'T STOP THE- ADAPTATION OF
HYDROGEN WITH PASSENGER VEHICLES
AND I THINK HE'S REALLY TRYING
TO FIND THE BALANCE HERE. AND
WORKING WITH OUR PUBLIC AGENCIES
IN DOING THAT. AND I DO BELIEVE
THAT THE LEGISLATURE HAS AN
IMPORTANT ROLE TO PLAY IN TERMS
OF THAT WE CAN'T JUST LEAVE THAT
UP TO. OUR AGENCIES TO FIGURE
OUT A HUNDRED PERCENT. NOW I
KNOW THAT HE'S COMMITTED TO
CONTINUE WORKING WITH THE
INDUSTRY AND WITH THE OPPOSITION
AND I HAVE CONFIDENCE THAT HE
WILL. CONTINUE TO DO THAT TO
ADDRESS THEIR CONCERNS AND
HOPEFULLY AT THE END OF THIS. WE
HAVE HAPPY STAKEHOLDERS ON ALL
SIDES WITHOUT I'M GOING TO BE
VOTING I ON THIS AND I WOULD ASK
FOR- THE- SECRETARY TO OPEN THE
ROLE. AB TWENTY FIVE SIXTY TO DO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS FRIEDMAN.
HI FRIEDMAN IPHONE. FONG AND NOT
VOTING BERMAN BERMAN I
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM AYE DALY.
DAVIES. DAVIES NOT VOTING GIPSON
. KALRA KALRA I LI LI I MEDINA
I'M SORRY BLUE. BLOOM NOT VOTING
THIS AREA. THIS AREA AND I WENT
. WHEN NOT VOTING O'DONNELL.
WARD WARD I WICKS WICKS HI.
EIGHT ZERO. THANK YOU THAT BILL
IS OUT WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO AB TWENTY
TWO SIXTY FOUR BY MR BLOOM. AND
HE MISTER BLOOM YOU MAY CHANGE
PLACES AND PERCENT WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS THIS IS AB TWENTY
TWO SIXTY FOR A MEASURE TO
ENSURE THAT BUSY INTERSECTIONS
ARE SAFER FOR PEDESTRIANS. FROM
TWENTY TEN TO TWENTY NINETEEN
OVER FIFTY THREE THOUSAND PEOPLE
WERE STRUCK AND KILLED BY
DRIVERS. YES THAT WERE
PREVENTABLE AND AVOIDABLE.
LEADING PEDESTRIAN INTERVAL OR
LPI IS A TRAFFIC SIGNAL DELAY
THAT GIVES PEDESTRIANS A HEAD
START ACROSS THE STREET BEFORE
VEHICLES ARE ALLOWED TO TURN.
LPI IS ALLOW SLOWER MOVING
PEDESTRIANS TO SAFELY CROSS
INCREASE THE VISIBILITY OF
PEDESTRIANS AND REDUCE THE
LIKELIHOOD OF A COLLISION BY
MORE THAN THIRTEEN PERCENT. AB
TWENTY TWO SIXTY FOUR WILL
REQUIRE THE INSTALLATION OF L.
P. EYES DURING REGULARLY
SCHEDULED MAINTENANCE OF TRAFFIC
AND PEDESTRIAN SIGNALS AND WILL
ONLY BE REQUIRED AT BUSY
INTERSECTIONS SUCH AS RESIDENTS
AND BUSINESS DISTRICTS SAFETY
CORRIDORS AND AREAS WITH HIGH
CONCENTRATIONS OF CYCLIST. THIS
BILL HAS NO REGISTERED
OPPOSITION WITH ME TO TESTIFIED
SUPPORT IS CLAIRE THANK YOU THE
LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE FOR STREETS
FOR ALL. MAYBE SHE'S ON THE
PHONE. OKAY WE HAVE A OUR
WITNESS IN SUPPORT OF FROM
STREETS FOR ALL IF THE OPERATOR
COMPLETES FIND HIM HE'S ON THE
PHONE THANK YOU. THAT IS CALERES
ANG. HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
WE CAN'T. THANK YOU SO MUCH GOOD
AFTERNOON TO THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS CLARA BANG AND I
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
ON BEHALF OF STREETS FOR ALL.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM
HIGHLIGHTED TRAFFIC VIOLENCE
ISN'T URGENT AT THE DAM MAKING
CALIFORNIA. IN ADDITION TO THE
HIGH DEATH COUNT- NATIONALLY WE
HIGHLIGHT THAT IN OUR EXPERIENCE
HERE IN LOS ANGELES. CRASHES
HAVE INCREASED TO THE POINT.
WHERE PEDESTRIANS KILLED EVERY
THREE DAYS ON AVERAGE. WELL WE
SUPPORT ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOMS
BILL TO IMPLEMENT LEADING
PEDESTRIAN INTERVALS TO COMBAT
THIS RISING DEATH COUNT. THIS IS
A PROVEN SOLUTION. THAT WE KNOW
WORKS. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
HIGHLIGHTED FINDINGS FROM THE
FEDERAL HIGHWAY ADMINISTRATION
IN HIS REMARKS. WE WOULD ALSO
HIGHLIGHT THAT CALTRANS AND THE
L. A. DEPARTMENT OF
TRANSPORTATION HAVE FOUND OKAY
GUYS CAN REDUCE PEDESTRIAN
VEHICLE CRASHES. BY UP TO FORTY
TO SIXTY PERCENT. INDEED LPI
YOURSELF ACTIVE THE LOW COST
THAT THE FEDERAL HIGHWAY
ADMINISTRATION ESTIMATED THAT
LPS ACHIEVED. NEARLY FOUR
HUNDRED TIMES THE BENEFIT THAT.
THE DEATH BENEFITS THAN THEY
COST. WE ALSO EMPHASIZE THE L.
P. IMPROVED PUBLIC WITH WALKING
SURVEYS THE INTERSECTION WERE
OPEN AND PROGRAMS ABOUT 6290% OF
PEOPLE REPORTED FEELING SAFER
AND WERE MORE LIKELY TO USE A
CROSSWALK WITH AN LPI. AS WE
KNOW ENCOURAGING WALKING AND
ALTERNATIVES TO DRIVING HAS
COUNTLESS SOCIETAL BENEFITS
INCLUDING BETTER PUBLIC HELP
LOWER VEHICLE EMISSIONS AND
IMPROVE THE SITE- EQUITY.
INCLUDING WE SUPPORT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BLOOMS BILL AND WE ASK
THIS COMMITTEE FOR ITS AYE VOTE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. THANK
YOU I DON'T HAVE ANY OPPOSITION
ON FILE IS OR ANYBODY IN THE
ROOM WISHING TO GIVE TESTIMONY
ON THIS BILL. OKAY I'M NOT
SEEING ANYBODY OPERATOR COULD
YOU OPEN UP THE PHONE LINES FOR
A TESTIMONY IN FAVOR OR OPPOSED
TO AB. TWENTY TWO SIXTY FOUR. IN
THESE DIMINISH YOU WISH TO SPEAK
ON AB TWENTY TWO SIXTY FOUR.
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. WE'LL START WITH ONE
THREE SEVENTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. OKAY WE'LL GO TO MINUS
THREE EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ONE WELLS MARIN COUNTY
BICYCLE COALITION IN STRONG
SUPPORT. LINE THREE SEVENTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AFTER MY FIVE
PLUS YOU COUNTY OPPOSED. TO TWO
SIX FOUR. NINE ONE ELEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MARK LOOKED AT HER
BECAUSE- WHAT ABOUT THE EYES.
NINE THREE SEVENTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GARY YES WE CAN SIMPLY GO
AHEAD. HELLO ANDREW- INTO LEWIS
NOT BECAUSE WHENEVER COUNCIL
STRONG SUPPORT FOR A BI I THINK
YOU. LIE NUMBER NINETY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. DOVER
MALOLACTIC TANGO SAN GABRIEL
VALLEY STRONG SUPPORT. LINE FOUR
HUNDRED AND THIRTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. JOSHUA COOPER FROM NORTH
HOLLYWOOD IN STRONG SUPPORT. IN
MEDICARE WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
LET'S BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE AND SEE IF ANYBODY HAS
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. CENA
MISTER BLOOM WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE YES SIR. THANK YOU- AB AT
TWENTY TWO SIXTY FOUR WILL.
HASTEN THE DEPLOYMENT OF THIS
PROVEN STRATEGY- WILL REDUCE THE
NUMBER OF INJURIES. AND DEATHS
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR DRIVER.
THANK YOU- CAN WE HAVE A ROLL
CALL VOTE I WILL BE SUPPORTING
YOUR BILL TODAY. COMMONSENSE AND
WILL SAVE LIVES THANK YOU. AB
TWENTY TWO SIXTY FOUR DO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS FRIEDMAN. I
FRIEDMAN IPHONE. FONG I BERMAN
BERMAN I CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM
AYE DALY. DAVIES DAVIES I'D
GIPSON GIPSON I KALRA KALRA I LI
LI I HELLO I GREW AYE IN THIS
AREA. WHEN I O'DONNELL. WARD
WARD I WICKS WICKS I TOLD ZERO.
THANK YOU THAT BILL IS OUT.
TABLE. BECAUSE WE ARE WAITING
FOR AUTHORS WE'RE GONNA GO TO
MISTER WARD FROM AB TWENTY ONE
TWENTY MR WARD YOU MAY PROCEED
WHEN YOU'RE READY. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS I'M
PRESENTING AB TWENTY ONE TWENTY.
LOCAL BRIDGES ARE A CRITICAL
PART OF OUR TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE. THEY CONNECTS
RESIDENTS TO JOBS SCHOOLS
CLINICS GROCERY STORES RETAIL
STORES AND EVERYTHING YOU LOVE
DOING JOINT. AT THE CURRENT RATE
OF FUNDING THE PERCENTAGE OF
LOCAL BRIDGES DOESN'T NEED US
POOR CONDITION UNDERFEDERAL
STANDARDS WILL INCREASE FROM 11%
250% IN THE NEXT TWENTY YEARS.
AB TWENTY ONE TWENTY TACKLE THIS
PROBLEM HEAD ON BY ADJUSTING THE
FUNDING FORMULA 255% WHICH
ALLOCATES APPROXIMATELY THREE
HUNDRED TO EIGHT HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY FOR THESE
REASONS I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU AND YOU HAVE
A WITNESS IN SUPPORT. THERE YOU
ARE HELLO WELCOME. NOW WE'RE ON
GREAT BUT TRY TO BE BRIEF SINCE
YOU'VE HAD A LONG MEETING
ALREADY GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
FREEMEN AND MEMBERS OF THE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS BONNIE GORE AND I SERVE ON
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND
PLASTER COUNTY I'M HERE TODAY
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES IN
MY ROLE AS VICE CHAIR OF THE
HOUSING LAND USE AND
TRANSPORTATION POLICY COMMITTEE.
C. SACK AS A PROUD SPONSOR OF
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WARD THIS IMPORTANT BILL
WOULD ENSURE A FAIR AND NEEDS
BASED ALLOCATION ABRIDGE FORMULA
FUNDING FROM THE FEDERAL
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENT AND
JOBS ACT AB TWENTY ONE TWENTY
WOULD ALLOCATE A SIGNIFICANT
SHARE OF NEW FEDERAL BRIDGE
FUNDS TO HELP CLOSE THE
SIGNIFICANT FUNDING GAP FOR
LOCAL BRIDGE REPAIR AND
REPLACEMENT PROJECTS STATEWIDE.
IN TWENTY TWENTY COUNTIES AND
CITIES REGIONAL TRANSPORTATION
AGENCIES AND CALTRANS FUNDED A
STATEWIDE LOCAL BRIDGE NEEDS
ASSESSMENT. REPORT USED
INSPECTION DATA DETERMINE THE
NEED FOR BRIDGE REPAIR OR
REPLACEMENT PROJECTS AND ANALYZE
THE IMPACTS OF DIFFERENT FUNDING
SCENARIOS. JUST A FEW OF THE KEY
FINDING FINDINGS INCLUDE THAT
FORTY FOUR HUNDRED LOCAL BRIDGES
NEED TO BE REPAIRED. AND FOUR
HUNDRED FIFTY ONE OR SO
DETERIORATED THAT THEY MUST BE
REPLACED. THERE IS A SIGNIFICANT
DISPARITY IN THE CONDITION OF
STATE AND LOCAL BRIDGES. ELEVEN
AND A HALF PERCENT OF LOCAL
BRIDGES ARE IN POOR CONDITION
COMPARED TO ONLY THREE POINT 3%
OF STATE BRIDGES. WITH THESE
PROPOSED CHANGES TO THE FUNDING
FORMULA. IT WOULD INCREASE THE
FEDERAL FUNDING AVAILABLE TO
LOCAL BRIDGES FROM APPROXIMATELY
THREE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY TO APPROXIMATELY EIGHT
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY. THIS INCREASE IN
FUNDING WOULD ADDRESS AN ACUTE
NEED AT THE LOCAL LEVEL. IN MY
OWN COUNTY FOR EXAMPLE
APPROXIMATELY 25% OF COUNTY
MAINTAIN BRIDGES ARE IN FAIR OR
POOR CONDITION AND NEED TO BE
REPAIRED OR REPLACED. OUR COUNTY
IS CURRENTLY PURSUING FUNDING
FOR SEVEN BRIDGE PROJECTS AT AN
ESTIMATED COST OF A HUNDRED AND
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS. FOR
EXAMPLE THE FORTY NINE MILLION
DOLLAR WHYTE AVENUE BRIDGE
REPLACEMENT PROJECT WILL PROVIDE
A VITAL LINK BETWEEN THE
COMMUNITIES IN SACRAMENTO COUNTY
AND EMERGING RESIDENTIAL
COMMERCIAL AND INDUSTRIAL AREAS
OF PLASTER COUNTY. AND THEN AT
THE OTHER END OF THE SPECTRUM
THE FORTY FOUR MILLION DOLLAR
YANKEE JIM THIS BRIDGE
REPLACEMENT WILL PROVIDE IMPROVE
FIRE AND PUBLIC SAFETY ACCESS
BETWEEN THE FOREST TELLING
COLFAX COMMUNITIES. AND HELP
ENSURE SAFE WILDFIRE EVACUATION
EGRESS FOR THE PUBLIC. THESE
PROJECTS WOULD BE READY FOR
CONSTRUCTION AND TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR BUT BUT BUT DELAYED FOR
MANY YEARS WITHOUT THE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING ALLOCATED BY
AB TWENTY ONE TWENTY. SO AB
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY ONE
TWENTY ENSURES THAT LOCAL STATE
LOCAL AND STATE BRIDGES BENEFIT
FOR THE FEDERAL INFRASTRUCTURE
FUNDING. REPAIRING OUR CRUMBLING
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
WELL PUTTING CALIFORNIANS TO
WORK. COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE
STATE WILL BENEFIT FROM THESE
IMPORTANT FIX IT FIRST PROJECTS
THAT CONNECT COMMUNITIES PROVIDE
IMPORTANT EMERGENCY EVACUATION
ROUTES AND ADDING SAFE ACCESS TO
PEOPLE WALKING AND BIKING. FOR
THESE REASONS TO SEE SACK ASKS
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE ON AB TWENTY
ONE TWENTY. THANK YOU YOUR NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE
ANDREW ANTS WE HERE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF LOS ANGELES MAYOR ERIC
GARCETTI OTHER SUPERVISOR LAID
IT OUT VERY WELL SO I'M GOING TO
EVER NOT TO REPEAT ANY POINTS
THAT HAVE ALREADY BEEN MADE I'M
GONNA TRUNCATE MY TESTIMONY. AND
RECOGNITION OF THE LONG DAYS
VERY I'LL JUST ADD THAT THE CITY
OF LOS ANGELES HAS THIRTY SIX
PRIORITY BRIDGES IN NEED OF
REPAIR OR RECONSTRUCTION.
CURRENT ESTIMATES BRING THE COST
TO ADDRESS THESE ISSUES AROUND
EIGHT HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS. A LOCAL BRIDGES ARE A
CRITICAL PART OF OUR
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE.
OF NETWORK AND THEY CONNECT
MOTORISTS INCLUDING TRANSIT
VEHICLES. TO JOBS SCHOOLS
CLINICS AND ALL THE OTHER
IMPORTANT DESTINATIONS IN DAILY
LIFE. AS A COMMITTEE ANALYSIS
CORRECTLY POINTS OUT.
REHABILITATING AND REPLACING
THESE OLDER BRIDGES WOULD LIKELY
ALLOW FOR. THE INSTALLATION OF
SAFE ACCESS FOR BICYCLES AND
PEDESTRIANS- AND THESE DOLLARS
CAN BE USED FOR THAT PURPOSE.
UNDER THE FEDERAL LAW. AND FOR
THESE REASONS WE SUPPORT. THANK
YOU AND WE HAVE NO WITNESSES
REGISTERED IN OPPOSITION SO
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO TEST MONEY
FOR OR AGAINST THE BILL HERE IN
THE HEARING ROOM YOU CAN COME UP
AND STATE YOUR NAME IN YOUR
POSITION. GOOD AFTERNOON THAT
YES GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
COMMITTEE MMBERS JONATHAN CLAY
ABOUT THE COUNTY SAN DIEGO IN
SUPPORT. MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
SYLVIA SO LEASE SHAUN BEHALF OF
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS FOR THE
FOLLOWING COUNTIES BUTTE FRESNO
MADERA SAN JOAQUIN AND PLASTER.
ALL IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY ONE
TWENTY THANK YOU. JERRY MEMBERS
MARC WATTS- TONIGHT OR TONIGHT
TONIGHT TO THIS AFTERNOON-
BEHALF OF COUNTRY CUSTER COUNTY
RIVERSIDE COUNTY AND
TRANSPORTATION CALIFORNIA- DR-
AND I WOULD JUST LIKETO PUT A
PERSONAL NOTE IN. ONCE I HEARD
ABOUT YANKEE JIM IS BEING FIXED.
PLEASE THANK YOU I DON'T SEE ANY
FURTHER TESTIMONY IN PERSON CAN
WE PLEASE MOVE TO THE PHONE
LINES OPERATOR IF YOU CAN OPEN
THE LINES FOR BILL AB TWENTY ONE
TWENTY FOUR OR AGAINST THANK YOU
. IF YOU WISH SPIEGELMAN'S
LEGISLATION AB TWENTY ONE TWENTY
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. WE'LL GET A LINE
THREE NINETY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE KIANA VALENTINE ON
BEHALF OF UNITED CONTRACTORS IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NINE TWO
NINETY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON SIXTY BALK ABOUT
THE GOLDEN GATE BRIDGE HIGHWAY
AND TRANSPORTATION DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT. IN LINE FOR FIFTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MA'AM
TURN MEMBERS PROF BUCKLEY ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF SACRAMENTO
IN DECEMBER NOW CAN
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY IN
SUPPORT. NINE THREE SEVENTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. CATHLAMET
BRIGHT BUT YOU COUNTY IN SUPPORT
OF TWENTY ONE TWENTY. ONE FOUR
THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MA'AM SURE MEMBERS
THEM THEY CAN BEHALF IN EUROPEAN
COUNCIL OF INSURANCE IN
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU. WINE THREE
SIXTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU WILLIAM DR COUNTY IN
SUPPORT OF TWENTY ONE TWENTY
THANK YOU. NINE TO FORTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS EDWIN
BOARD BONE ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY SAN BERNARDINO AND ORANGE
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. IN LINE.
FIFTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD
AFTERNOON THAT MAN SHOT AT THEM
CREASE STRATEGIES CALLING ON
BEHALF OF SAN MATEO COUNTY AND
SACRAMENTO COUNTY AND THE PORT
OF AB TWO ONE TWO. ZERO THANK
YOU. MADAM CHAIR HAVE NO ONE
ELSE CAN QUEUE AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. SEEING NO MISTER WARD
LIKE TO CLOSE THANK YOU MANAGER
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST ARRIVAL
THANK YOU- WITH THAT CAN WE GO
TO A ROLL CALL. AB TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS FRIEDMAN HI
FRIEDMAN HI FONG. FONG I BERMAN
BERMAN I CUNNINGHAM. DALY DALY I
DAVIES DAVIES I GIPSON- AYE
GIPSON AYE KALRA. KALRA I LEE ME
I BLEW BLOOM I NAZARIAN. WHEN I
O'DONNELL O'DONNELL I WARD. WARD
WARD I WICKS. MUNI. TWELVE ZERO
ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT WILL LEAVE
THE ROLE OPEN WE'RE GOING TO GO
BACK NOW TO AB SIXTEEN THIRTY
EIGHT NOW THAT MR LEE HAS GIVEN
THE AMENDMENTS TO THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WE WILL GO NOW TO
DISCUSSION FROM THE COMMITTEE IF
THERE'S ANY- YES MR TRUMP MR
FONG. I THINK MEDICARE. LET'S BE
CLEAR ON WHAT'S HAPPENING RIGHT
NOW. THE BILL TO TEMPORARILY
SUSPEND THE STATE'S GAS TAX FOR
SIX MONTHS. PROVIDE IMMEDIATE
RELIEF THE CALIFORNIANS IS BEING
AND IS BEING SHOCKINGLY. TO
RAISE TAXES EVEN MORE IN
CALIFORNIA AND ON ENERGY OF ALL
THINGS. THERE IS NO DISPUTE THAT
CALIFORNIANS ARE PAYING
SUBSTANTIALLY MORE FOR GASOLINE
AND OTHER STATES AND THERE IS NO
DISPUTE THAT THE DIFFERENCE. IS
BECAUSE OF POLICY CHOICES
INCLUDING TAXES AND STATE
MANDATES THAT IS BEING IMPOSED
IN CALIFORNIA AND NOT ANYWHERE
ELSE. IF WE WANT TO TALK ABOUT
THE ENERGY MARKET AND WHY PRICES
ARE GOING UP RIGHT NOW WITH THE
UKRAINE. THE PROBLEM THAT WE'VE
GOT INTO EXISTED BEFORE THE
UKRAINIAN CONFLICT. IF YOUWANT
TO LOOK AT THE ISSUE OF FOREIGN
DEPENDENCE. OF OIL COMING INTO
CALIFORNIA. WE HAVE TO LOOK
OURSELVES IN THE MIRROR. WE ARE
GROWING IN OUR DEPENDENCE ON
FOREIGN OIL IN CALIFORNIA
BECAUSE OF THE POLICIES COMING
FROM THIS ADMINISTRATION AND
THIS BUILDING THIS LEGISLATURE.
IT'S BECAUSE OF THE POLICIES
HAVE BEEN IMPOSED ON CALIFORNIA
ENERGY PRODUCTION THAT IS
INCREASED OUR ENERGY FROM
FOREIGN COUNTRIES. 75% OF THE
OIL THAT COMES INTO CALIFORNIA
IS IMPORTED FROM FOREIGN
COUNTRIES ECUADOR SAUDI ARABIA
IRAQ 6% OF THAT 75% SINCE LAST
YEAR CAME FROM RUSSIA. EIGHTEEN
MILLION BARRELS OF OIL CAME FROM
RUSSIA THOUSANDS OF PERMITS. ARE
SITTING BEFORE THE GOVERNOR'S
DESK THAT WOULD ALLOW AN
INCREASE IN OIL PRODUCTION IN
CALIFORNIA. CALIFORNIA ENERGY
FOR CALIFORNIANS BY CALIFORNIANS
BUT WHAT IS BEING DONE NOTHING.
THE GOVERNOR IS DOING NOTHING
AND SO OUR FOREIGN OIL
DEPENDENCE IS GOING UP BECAUSE
OF THAT. AND BECAUSE OF THAT
FORMAL DEPENDENCE CALIFORNIA IS
MORE VULNERABLE IT IS MORE
AFFORDABLE. BECAUSE OF THE
INSTABILITY IN THE ENERGY MARKET
RIGHT NOW. SO WE WANT TO TALK
ABOUT ENERGY PRODUCTION I'M
HAPPY TO HAVE THAT DEBATE. LET'S
PRODUCE ENERGY IN CALIFORNIA
IT'S NOT WHETHER CALIFORNIA IS
GOING TO CONSUME ENERGY AND OIL
AND IT IN OUR STATE THE QUESTION
IS WHERE IS IT GONNA COME FROM.
IS IT A IS IT LIKE IS IT GONNA
COME FROM CALIFORNIA OR IS IT
GONNA COME FROM OTHER COUNTRIES.
IN CALIFORNIA IS A ENERGY ISLAND
. IN OTHER STATES INCREASED OIL
PRODUCTION. BECAUSE OF THE LACK
OF INFRASTRUCTURE AND BECAUSE OF
TRANSPORTATION COSTS IT DOESN'T
COME TO CALIFORNIA SO LET'S HAVE
THE ENERGY DEBATE. BUT RIGHT NOW
WE ARE DISCUSSING HOW TO PROVIDE
IMMEDIATE RELIEF TO CALIFORNIANS
THAT IS A VERY CRUCIAL TIME. AND
THESE AMENDMENTS. IMPOSE A NEW
VEHICLE FUEL WINDFALL PROFITS
TAX AND IF YOU LOOK AT THE END
OF COURSE THERE'S IS BIG DEBATE
ON ON WITH HOW THE PRICE OF OIL
IS AT A PRICE OF GASOLINE IS
DETERMINED. THE CDC HAS DONE THE
ANALYSIS. THEY'VE DONE THE
REPORTS THE GOVERNOR'S ASK FOR
INVESTIGATION DEPARTMENT JUSTICE
HAS DONE AN INVESTIGATION. 51%
OF THE PRICE OF GASOLINE COMES
FROM THE STATE GAS TAX 80% COMES
FROM. THE FEDERAL EXCISE TAX
THEN YOU HAVE CAP AND TRADE THE
LOW CARBON FUEL STANDARD OVER A
DOLLAR OF THE PRICE OF GASOLINE
IN CALIFORNIA IS BECAUSE OF
TAXES AND REGULATIONS. IT IS
PRETTY OBVIOUS THAT IF YOU
COMPARE THE PRICE OF GASOLINE IN
A CALIFORNIA TO OTHER STATES THE
DIFFERENCE IS THAT. IT'S THE
CALIFORNIA WAY THAT IS CAUSING
THE PRICE OF OIL IF THE PRICE OF
GASOLINE TO GO UP AND THAT THE
PRICE OF ENERGY PRODUCTION TO GO
UP AND WHY WE CAN'T PRODUCE. OIL
DOMESTICALLY. OTHER STATES HAVE
DONE IT AS THIS AS MR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KILEY AS MENTIONED
GEORGIA HAS SUSPENDED ITS TWENTY
NINE CENT GAS TAX. CONNECTICUT
AS PAT AS PASSED IN HAS
TEMPORARILY SUSPENDED ITS TWENTY
FIVE CENT GAS TAX MARYLAND HAS
TEMPORARILY SUSPENDED ITS THREE
CENT GAS TAX THIS IS NOT A NEW
IDEA. THIS IS A BIPARTISAN IDEA
WITH BIPARTISAN SUPPORT YOU
NASTY PASSED IN OTHER STATES.
AND OF COURSE THE REBATE DEBATE
AND WHAT THE WHAT THE OPPONENTS
HAVE SAID. THE REAL GIVING
RELIEF TO CALIFORNIA VOTERS
RIGHT NOW DRAKE TEMPERATE GAS
EXPANSION IS NOT MUTUALLY
EXCLUSIVE TO OTHER TAX RELIEF.
WE AGREE WITH THE OPPONENTS WHEN
IT COMES TO THE AFFORDABILITY
CRISIS IN CALIFORNIA THE
AFFORDABLE A CRISIS IN
CALIFORNIA IS REAL IT'S NOT JUST
GASOLINE IT'S HOUSING. ITS
UTILITIES IT'S GROCERIES AND WE
SHOULD LOOK OVER BUT WE SHOULD
LOOK AT THE OTHER POLICIES THAT
HAVE CAUGHT INCREASE THE COST.
OF ALL THOSE THINGS IN OUR STATE
. MAYBE WE SHOULD DEBATE LASTING
TAX RELIEF AN ACTUAL LOWER
INCOME TAX RATES IN CALIFORNIA
AND LOWER TAXES ON BUSINESSES SO
THAT PEOPLE ACTUALLY STAY IN
CALIFORNIA AND THAT. BUSINESSES
AND THAT CALIFORNIA'S THING
CALIFORNIA. BUT MAKE NO MISTAKE
ABOUT IT. THIS BILL THAT WAS
GOING TO PROVIDE IMMEDIATE GAS
TAX RELIEF. TEMPORARILY
COMPLETELY BACK FILLED BY THE
SIXTY BILLION DOLLARS SURPLUS IN
OUR STATE EVIDENCE THAT EVERY
CALIFORNIA'S OVERTAXED BUT WHAT
DOES THIS COMMITTEE WHAT IS
BEING PROPOSED IS IT TAKES A TAX
RELIEF BILL INCREASES TAXES.
THAT IS COMPLETELY. ASININE IT
MAKES NO SENSE COMPLETELY NO
SENSE. SO I AM ASKING FOR NO
VOTE ON THIS BILL UNFORTUNATELY
BECAUSE- THIS BILL THAT MISTER
COLLEY HAS PRESENTED WAS TO
PROVIDE IMMEDIATE RELIEF AND
WHAT HAS HAPPENED IS THAT NOW
THIS BILL HAS BEEN AND NOW IT
WILL INCREASE TAXES ON EVERY DAY
CALIFORNIANS AND THAT IS
UNACCEPTABLE. COMPLETELY
UNACCEPTABLE AND EVERYONE IN THE
PUBLIC EVERYONE WATCHING SHOULD
BE. ASHAMED OF THIS PROCESS. WE
NEED TO PROVIDE CALIFORNIANS
IMMEDIATE TAX RELIEF. THE COMMON
SENSE THING TO DO TO TEMPORARILY
SUSPEND THE STATE'S GAS TAX. SO
THAT THERE IS AN IMMEDIATE
RELIEF. NOT THIS WAITING ON WHAT
IS GOING TO COME FORWARD IN THE
FUTURE. I'M WAITING FOR THE
DETAILS I EAGERLY AWAIT A DEBATE
ON ADDRESSING THE AFFORDABILITY
CRISIS IN OUR STATE.
CALIFORNIANS DON'T HAVE THE TIME
. AND THEY DON'T HAVE THE MONEY
RIGHT NOW TO WAIT. SO I ASK FOR
NO ABOUT. THANK YOU THE STATUS.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I JUST
HAVE TO SAY THAT I'M DISGUSTED
BY THIS PROCESS. I KNOW I'M
DOING HERE. BUT THIS IS A
TRAVESTY OF PUBLIC POLICY
HAPPENING RIGHT NOW. WE HAVE ONE
MEMBER OF A COMMITTEE OF FIFTEEN
HAVE AMENDMENTS THAT ALMOST
NOBODY HAS SEEN AND NOW YOU WANT
ME TO VOTE ON THIS. THIS IS JUST
IMPOSSIBLE WE'RE WE'RE LOOKING
AT A BILL THAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
GO AHEAD AND CHANGE AND AS MY
COLLEAGUE SAID. WE'RE HERE TO
GIVE INSTANT RELIEF IF YOU COULD
HEAR THE PEOPLE FROM THE
MESSAGES AND ON THE RADIO IT'S
ALRIGHT ON THE PHONE SAYING WE
NEED HELP AND WE NEED HELP NOW.
BUT WHAT YOU GONNA DO YOU'RE
GONNA MAKE AMENDMENTS THAT WHO
KNOWS THAT IT'S GOING TO TAKE
SIX MONTHS A YEAR. IS THAT GOING
TO BE LONG ENOUGH TO THINK
THAT'S GOING TO HELP THEM THEN.
SERIOUSLY I MEAN YOU HAVE TO
HEAR THE VOICES OF THE PEOPLE
SAYING WE NEED HELP AND WE NEED
IT NOW YOU CAN'T TURN. YOUR
HEADS ON THIS. AND YET YOU'RE
DOING THIS. OUR OUR BILL RIGHT
HERE THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT IS
GOING TO GIVE RELIEF EMILY AND
WHAT'S AMAZING IS YOU TALK ABOUT
MONEY COMING FROM CONSTRUCTIVIST
ACTION WE HAVE ALMOST SIXTY
BILLION DOLLARS OF SURPLUS RIGHT
NOW THAT'S SURPLUS IS YOUR TAXES
THAT MONEY DOES BELONG TO YOU SO
IF WE CAN'T TAKE FOR BILLION
DOLLARS THAT WOULD COVER ABOUT
SIX MONTHS TO GIVE TO THE PEOPLE
IMMEDIATELY. AND WHAT GOOD IS
YOUR BILL GOING TO DO. I JUST
FIND IT AMAZING THAT NOBODY
WANTS TO HEAR THE VOICES OF
CALIFORNIANS. THIS IS A COMMON
SENSE BILL IN THANK YOU MISTER
KILEY A COMMON SENSE BILL THAT
WOULD HELP EVERYONE AND YES WE
HAVE WE HAVE IN PLACE RIGHT NOW
WITH UTILITIES WE HAVE IN PLACE
RIGHT NOW. WITH FOOD AND WE HAVE
SURPLUS YOU THAT CAN ADDRESS
THAT BUT RIGHT NOW PEOPLE NEED
TO SEAT AT THE PUMP AND IF YOU
CAN'T DRIVE TO WORK YOU CAN'T
WORK AND THEN YOU CAN'T PAY FOR
THE TWO LEADERS TO CAMPAIGN FOR
THE GAS. WE'RE HERE. WILLING TO
THROW. A LIFE PRESERVER TO
SOMEONE DROWNING AND YOU'RE
LOOKING LIKE YOU WANT TO TEACH
HIM HOW TO SWIM. THANK YOU. YES. THANK THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. I
AM. I AM BEYOND SHOCKED.
OFFENDED AND APPALLED. THIS IS
THE SAME SHENANIGANS THAT THE
CALIFORNIAN PEOPLE DO NOT LIKE
THEY DON'T WANT TO SEE IT THEY
DON'T TRUST US THIS IS WHAT
HAPPENS YOU DO I MEAN. MY
DISTRICT. THERE ARE PEOPLE MEET
YOU'RE LOOKING AT A GALLON OF
GAS IS MORE THAN A GALLON OF
MILK TODAY. PEOPLE ARE HAVING TO
CHOOSE BETWEEN. PUTTING A GALLON
OF MILK FOR THEIR CHILDREN ON
THE TABLE. OR TAKE THEM TO
SCHOOL OR GET TO WORK. AND
INSTEAD IF YOU LOOK AT THE
POLICY DEBATE LET'S DEBATE WHY
THIS IS A BAD IDEA TO SUSPEND
THE GAS TAX WHY ARE YOU SO
AFRAID OF CASTING I HAVE NO VOTE
JUST VOTE. WE'VE GONE THROUGH
THIS FOR WEEKS AND MONTHS NOW.
JUST VOTE NO IF YOU DON'T WANT
IT. TELL THEM TELL THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC BUT YOU DON'T
WANT TO SPEND THE GAS TAX WHY DO
WE HAVE TO KEEP ON THIS DEBATE
HI JACKING A BILL THAT IS TO
HELP RELIEVE IMMEDIATELY.
CALIFORNIA FAMILIES THE HARD
WORK IN CALIFORNIA THE MIDDLE
CLASS AND LOW INCOME CLASS. TO
GET TO WORK TO GET TO THE
DOCTOR'S OFFICE TO TAKE THE KIDS
TO SCHOOL TO GO TO THE GROCERY
STORE. WHY DO WE HAVE TO HIJACK
THIS BILL. YOU'RE LITERALLY
TAKING A BILL THIS IS SUSPENDED
GAS TAX AND NOW YOU CAN ADD MORE
TAXES TO WHAT'S HAPPENING TO
CALIFORNIANS. THERE'S SO MANY
THERE'S THOUSANDS OF OTHER
BILLS. IN THIS BUILDING THAT YOU
CAN HIGH JACK WHITE TODAY AND
YOU'RE GIVING US AN AMENDMENT
WITHIN SECONDS AND WE HAVE TO
VOTE FOR IT. THIS IS WHY. THEY
HATE CALIFORNIA THEY HATE OUR
STATE GOVERNMENT LOOK WHAT YOU
HAVE DONE TO DE DE DE LOOK WHAT
YOU HAVE DONE TO DMV. BUT TODAY
WE HAD TO VOTE TO EXTEND THE
INVITATION. BECAUSE THERE'S TO
OVER TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
APPLICANTS THAT HAVE NOT EVEN
BEEN ABLE TO GET THROUGH. TO GET
RELIEF WHAT ELSE IS LEFT FOR
CALIFORNIANS NOW. NOTHING. HOW
DO YOU EXPECT US TO SIT HERE
EACH OF US REPRESENTING OVER
HALF A MILLION PEOPLE. AND IT'S
OKAY. THEY NEED THE GAS TAX
RELIEF NOW. GAS STATIONS ALL
OVER MY DISTRICT THE CHEAPEST
ONE. COSTCO AND SAM'S CLUB ARCO. THEIR LINES ARE LIKE TWO HOURS. IT'S INCREDIBLE PEOPLE ARE
LITERALLY DRIVING FAR AWAY AND
WAITED FOR HOURS JUST TO GET A
DOLLAR TO RELIEVE WHY CAN'T YOU
SEE THAT TODAY. WHY ARE WE JUST
BEING SILENT AND PROLONGING THIS
. PAYING FOR ALL THESE FAMILIES. IT MAKES ABSOLUTELY NO SENSE
LET THE BILL GO THROUGH. LET IT
HAPPEN FEEL FREE YOU HAVE EVERY
RIGHT TO REPRESENT YOUR
CONSTITUENTS VOTE NO. WE DID
THIS ON THE FLOOR. WE'VE DONE IT
SO MANY TIMES AND ALL IT IS POLL
LONGER THIS AND MOVING IT HI
JACK AND DO ALL SORTS OF. FUNNY
BUSINESS. IT'S TIME TO JUST TAKE
A STAND WHAT YOU'RE WHAT THE
CALIFORNIA PEOPLE. THE MOM AND
POPS LIKE ME. PRESS THE DRIVE
THEIR CHILDREN I DROP MY TWO
BOYS TO SCHOOL THIS MORNING
BEFORE I GOT TO THE AIRPORT.
OVER THE WEEKEND. I TO DRIVE
INTO BASEBALL PRACTICE. TWO
DIGITS TO. TWO SWIMMING. AB THIS
THIS IS INCREDIBLE YOU'RE NOT
HELPING. THERE ARE THOUSANDS OF
BILLS AND MISTER LEE YOU'RE
WELCOME TO TAKE MY BILLS. I MEAN
COME ON LET'S STOP BEING A CHILD
ABOUT THIS YOU KNOW BETTER THAN
THIS. I'M ASKING YOU TODAY. LET
THE BILL GO FORWARD FEEL FREE TO
VOTE NOW THAT'S ALL WE DO ASK
YOU FOR TAKE A STAND EITHER WAY
HI JACKIE GASES PENSION RELIEF
BILL TO PUT IT MORE TAXES. ON
CALIFORNIA IS THE WRONG THING TO
DO. ANYONE ELSE. ALL MAKE A
COMMENT BEFORE WE GO TO THE
AUTHOR TO CLOSE. I AM I GUESS A
LITTLE APPALLED AND SHOCKED THAT
YOU ALL ARE SO APPALLED AND
SHOCKED BY THIS. THIS IS EXACTLY
OUR PROCESS THAT WE DEBATE A
PROBLEM AND WHAT THE SOLUTION IS
GOING TO BE WE DIDN'T INVENT ANY
OF THIS PROCEDURE THIS IS
LONGSTANDING PROCEDURE ABOUT
WHAT WE DO IN COMMITTEE. I DON'T
PROBLEM IS BEEN IDENTIFIED
RIGHTLY BY THE AUTHOR WHICH IS
THAT GAS PRICES ARE HIGH AND
IT'S HURTING PEOPLE WHO CAN'T
AFFORD IT. NO ONE HERE DISAGREES
WITH THAT. THE DIFFERENCES THAT
WE ARE TRYING TO POINT OUT AND
RECOGNIZE THAT THE PROBLEM HERE
IS THAT WHILE THE PRICE OF OIL
IS CONTINUING TO DROP THE PRICE
OF CRUDE OIL IS CONTINUING TO
DROP IN CALIFORNIA AND ACROSS
THE COUNTRY. PRICES IN
CALIFORNIA KEEP GOING UP AND NOT
BECAUSE OF THE SMALL INCREASE AT
THE GAS TAX TOOK LAST YEAR WHICH
WAS JUST A COUPLE OF PENNIES.
BUT BECAUSE THE OIL INDUSTRY IS
ADDING GIANT SURCHARGES WHICH
THEY HAVE NOT EXPLAINED TO THE
PUBLIC. IN ANY DEPTH EVEN THOUGH
THEY'VE BEEN REPEATEDLY ASKED
WHAT THOSE SURCHARGES ARE FOR.
THEIR CHARGED IN CALIFORNIA AND
NOT IN OTHER STATES. I KNOW THAT
THE SOME OF MY COLLEAGUES HERE
WHO SUPPORT THE ORIGINAL BILL
WOULD LIKE US TO ENGAGE IN THE
SAME KIND OF TRICKLE DOWN.
POLITICS THAT WE'VE SEEN IN THE
PAST YOUR BRAKES TO THE
CORPORATIONS LET THAN LARGE
CORPORATIONS CHARGE WHATEVER
THEY WANT. DON'T TAX THEM EVEN
THOUGH THEY HAVE MADE WINDFALL
PROFITS THIS YEAR AND LAST YEAR
. COMPLETELY UNPRECEDENTED
PROFITS IN THE OIL INDUSTRY
DON'T TAXES THAT INSTEAD OUT DO
ALLOW THEM TO CHARGE WHATEVER
THEY WANT AND HOPE IT TRICKLES
DOWN TO THE COMMON PEOPLE YES
THERE'S BEEN A PROBLEM
IDENTIFIED IN THIS BILL BUT
NOTHING IN THE ORIGINAL BILL AS
PROPOSED SAYS THAT EVEN A PENNY.
OF THAT TAX RELIEF GETS PASSED
THROUGH THE PUMP TO INDIVIDUALS
WE LEAVE IT UP TO THOSE BIG
CORPORATION TO THE SIDE BUT NOW
THAT THEY KNOW THAT PEOPLE WILL
PAY SIX DOLLARS A GALLON OR FIVE
FIFTY A GALLON THERE'S
ABSOLUTELY NOTHING THAT SAYS BUT
THEY DON'T JUST POCKET. THAT
EXTRA MONEY NOTHING SO BECAUSE
THIS PROBLEM IS SO GRAVE ONE OF
OUR MEMBERS HAS PROPOSED AN
ALTERNATIVE SOLUTION GO TO THE
HEART OF THE PROBLEM THOSE
WINDFALL PROFITS AND AT LEAST
SAY IF YOU'RE GOING TO PRICE
GOUGE. WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A
PIECE OF THAT AND GIVE IT RIGHT
BACK TO THE PEOPLE NOW THE
GENERAL FUND BACK FILLING. OF
THESE TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS
THAT THOUGHT THAT SOMETHING THAT
MR KILEY HAS NOT TOLD THE PUBLIC
HERE IS THAT BECAUSE OF
SOMETHING CALLED BEGAN LIMIT IF
THAT MONEY GOES INTO THESE
TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS AND IS
TAKEN OUT OF THE GENERAL FUND
MONEY THAT WOULD OTHERWISE HAVE
TO BE GIVEN BACK TO THE PUBLIC.
WON'T GO BACK TO THEM. SO ONCE
AGAIN THAT MONEY COMES OUT OF
THE POCKETS. OF INDIVIDUAL
PEOPLE TO PROTECT. TO PROTECT.
THE WINDFALL PROFITS OF THE OIL
INDUSTRY SO IT'S PROPER THAT
WHEN A PROBLEM IS IDENTIFIED.
THAT WE DON'T THINK. A SOLUTIONS
BEING OFFERED TO THAT SOMEBODY
WANTS TO MAKE A SUBSTITUTE
MOTION THAT ACTUALLY MIGHT HAVE
A CHANCE OF SOLVING THIS PROBLEM
AND THAT'S WHAT'S BEING DONE
HERE TODAY. BUT TO PRETEND THAT
THERE'S THAT WE'VE ANYTHING WE
OFTEN IN COMMITTEE SUGGEST OTHER
SOLUTIONS OF COURSE WE COULD
JUST VOTE THIS DOWN. WE KNOW WE
COULD JUST VOTED DOWN BUT WE'RE
ACTUALLY TRYING TO HELP HERE AND
TRY TO GIVE PEOPLE RELIEF AT THE
PUMP BECAUSE WE DO THINK THAT
IT'S IMPORTANT. SO I DO THINK
THAT. UGH UGH I THINK THAT THERE
IS SOME ISSUES HERE BUT I THINK
THAT THIS BILL CAUSES EXTRA
PROBLEMS WHICH IS TAKING AWAY
MONEY THAT RIGHT NOW IS GOING TO
TAXPAYERS SUPPORTED. WE KNOW
THAT THIS THIS GAS TAX WAS JUST
VALIDATED AGAIN BY THE PUBLIC
TWO YEARS AGO. AT THESE PROJECTS
THAT ARE IMPORTANT. TO KEEP
ROADS SAFE TO KEEP BRIDGES FROM
COLLAPSING TO INVEST IN
INFRASTRUCTURE WITH THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA SAID THAT THEY
WANT. BUT THAT MONEY WILL BE
PULLED OUT FROM UNDER THEM. AND
SO THE OTHER PROBLEMS THAT COULD
BE CREATED BY THIS. SO I CAN I
WILL BE SUPPORTING MR LEE'S
AMENDMENT AND WITH THAT I'LL GO
TO MISTER KILEY FOR HIS CLOTHES
. THE MANAGER ACTION BEFORE I GO
ON MY BECAUSE THIS IS A BRIEF
POINT OF CLARIFICATION IF YOU
THINK THIS ALTERNATIVE PROPOSAL
IS THAT IS A GOOD IDEA TO
SOLUTION. WOULD YOU LIKE TO PUT
YOUR NAME ON IT IS THE AUTHOR.
YOU ARE THE AUTHOR OF THIS BILL
MR KILEY. I'M OFFERING YOU THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE AUTHORED THIS
BILL WOULD YOU LIKE TO TAKE THAT
OPPORTUNITY. BUT NO I HAVE NOT.
HAD A CHANCE TO DIVE IN DEPTH
INTO THIS. WHAT DO NOT VOTE ON
IF YOU MOVE THIS BILL INTO THE
NEXT COMMITTEE I'LL BE HAPPY TO
PUT MY NAME ON IT MISTER KYLE.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO PUT YOUR NAME
ON IT RIGHT NOW. MISTER SMITH
THIS IS NOT HARD ORDER YEAH.
MADAM CHAIR OF YOU HAVE GIVEN
THE SPEAKER THE OPPORTUNITY TO
CLOSE AND I THINK IT'S HE HAS A
RIGHT- AS A PERSON BRING THIS
BILL BEFORE THE CLOSE AND NOT
DEBATE THE CHAIR WHETHER NOT SHE
SHOULD PUT HER NAME ON THE BILL
I THINK IT'S COUNTERPRODUCTIVE I
THINK THIS THE SPEAKERS ARE
CLOSE PORES CLOSE REMARKS SO WE
CAN GET ON WITH PEOPLE'S
BUSINESS THANK YOU. YEAH YOUR
YOUR POINT IS WELL TAKEN MISTER
KILEY YOU'RE CLOSING YOUR NOT
CROSS EXAMINING THIS IS NOT A
COURT YOU KNOW YOU'RE NOT THE
LAWYER CROSS EXAMINING HERE YOU
CAN CLOSE AND WE CAN MOVE THIS
BILL FORWARD AND THEN IT WILL
SEE WHAT HAPPENS IN THE NEXT
COMMITTEE WHEN YOU MOVE YOUR
BILL I SEE OKAY SO HERE'S THE
DIFFERENCE WE DO HAVE TO
PROPOSALS. I'M WILLING TO PUT MY
NAME ON MY PROPOSAL FONG IS
GOING TO PUT HIS NAME ON IT.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHEN IS ONE OF
HER NAME ON IT. SOME WOMAN
DAVIES WENT ABOUT HER NAME ON IT
YET. THIS IS YOUR PROPOSAL IS SO
ODIOUS. BUT YOU'RE ONLY GOING TO
ATTACH YOUR NAME ON. THIS
POLLUTED FOR YOUR NAME ON IT.
ESTERLY WHICH I. MADAM CHAIR
ORDER IS DO NOT PLEASE DIRECT MR
KILEY YOU'RE MAKING A STATEMENT
YOU CAN ASK WHATEVER QUESTIONS
YOU WANT BUT I'M GONNA ASK OUR
COMMITTEE TO NOT RESPOND TO YOU.
MAKE YOUR STATEMENTS. SO I THINK
THAT ABOUT SAYS IT ALL. WE ARE
GOING TO OWN OUR PROPOSAL YOU'RE
NOT EVEN GOING TO PUT YOUR NAME
ON YOURS SO LET'S JUST TAKE A
STEP BACK FOR A SECOND. HERE
WONDER WHY CALIFORNIA HAS THE
HIGHEST POVERTY RATE OF ANY
STATE IN THE COUNTRY. YOU WONDER
WHY. WE'VE NOW REACHED A
BREAKING POINT WHERE FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN OUR ONE HUNDRED
FIFTY YEAR HISTORY. ARE LEAVING
THE STATE THAT ARE COMING HERE.
EVER WONDER WHY THE VAST
MAJORITY OF CALIFORNIANS SAY THE
KIDS GROWING UP IN OUR STATE
TODAY WILL BE WORSE OFF THAN
THEIR PARENTS THINK ABOUT THAT.
THAT IS THE VERY DEFINITION OF
THE AMERICAN DREAM AND OUR
PEOPLE THINK THAT IT'S DEBT.
THIS USED TO BE THE STATE WHERE
ANYONE COULD GET AHEAD IT'S NOW
THE STATE THAT SO MANY CAN'T
WAIT TO LEAVE BEHIND. AND THAT
IS A TRAGEDY. AND THERE IS
ABSOLUTELY NO DENYING THAT IT IS
THE RESULT OF GOVERNMENT
POLICIES. AND THE PROCEEDINGS
HERE TODAY ARE A PERFECT EXAMPLE
OF THAT. THE ARGUMENTS RAISED
AGAINST THIS BILL ARE SELF
EVIDENTLY BOGUS. IF GAS PRICES
IN CALIFORNIA ARE ENTIRELY A
PRODUCT OF INTERNATIONAL EVENTS.
AND WHY DOES CALIFORNIA HAVE
MUCH HIGHER GAS PRICES IN ALL
FORTY NINE OTHER STATES. SEVENTY
CENTS HIGHER THAN THE NEXT
CLOSEST STATE. IF SPENDING THE
GAS TAX IS SOMEHOW. POLITICALLY
MOTIVATED THEN WHY DID EVERY
SINGLE REPUBLICAN AND DEMOCRAT
MEMBER OF THE CONNECTICUT
LEGISLATURE VOTE TO DO PRECISELY
THAT. WHY DID THE VERY LIBERAL
GOVERNOR OF CONNECTICUT NO TO DO
PRECISELY THAT. WHY DID THE SAN
DIEGO BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
UNANIMOUSLY PASSED A RESOLUTION.
URGING THIS BODY URGING THE
GOVERNOR TO DO EXACTLY WHAT MY
ORIGINAL BILL. WOULD DO HERE
TODAY. IF THIS BENEFITS WOULD
NOT BE PASSED ON TO CONSUMERS
THEN WHY DID OUR OWN LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST THE NONPARTISAN OFFICIAL
APPOINTED UNANIMOUSLY BY THIS
BODY WHY DID OUR LEGISLATIVE
ANALYSTS SAY THAT IT WOULD OR
WHY HAVE GAS PRICES DECLINED IN
THE STATES THAT HAVE SUSPENDED
THEIR GAS TAX FOR WHY IT IS EVEN
GOVERNOR NEWSOM PROPOSING TO
HOLD OFF ON ANOTHER THREE CENT
INCREASE TO THE GAS TAX THIS
YEAR IS IT BECAUSE GOVERNOR
NEWSOM WANTS TO GIVE GAS
COMPANIES OIL COMPANIES. A THREE
CENT WINDFALL. IF THIS BILL IS
SOMEHOW GOING TO TAKE FUNDING
AWAY FROM ROADS THEN WHY DOES
THE PLAIN TEXT OF THE OF THE OF
THE BILL SAY THAT IT WILL NOT.
SO WE HAVE TO PROPOSALS IN FRONT
OF US. WE HAVE ONE THAT WOULD
CUT OUR STATE'S GAS TAX WE HAVE
ANOTHER THAT WOULD RAISE TAXES.
I PREFER MY VERSION. NOW I AM
NOT GOING TO CRITICIZE ALEX LEE
. YOU ALL HAVE HAYES THIS POOR
GUY SINCE THE MOMENT HE GOT TO
THE LEGISLATURE AND TODAY IT IS
A NOTHER EXAMPLE THAT MAKING HIM
DO THIS MAKING HIM DO YOUR
BIDDING. WE KNOW THAT YOU KNOW
HE DOESN'T WANT TO DO IT BECAUSE
HE WON'T EVEN PUT HIS NAME ON
THE BILL I FEEL SORRY FOR HIM WE
CAN ALL REMEMBER A MEMBER OF
THIS COMMITTEE. BERATING HIM
FROM THE DIESS. SHORTLY AFTER HE
ARRIVED IN THE LEGISLATURE. AND
SO THIS SPEAKS TO MORE THAN AN
ISSUE. OF DEMOCRAT VERSUS
REPUBLICAN. REPORTER I REALIZE
THAT THE AUTHOR OF THIS BILL
WANT TO TURN EVERYTHING INTO A
CAMPAIGN COMMERCIAL FIRST
USUALLY FAIL CONGRESSIONAL
CAMPAIGN BUT- ASKING TO STICK TO
THE MERITS OF THE CONVERSATION
IN THE MERITS OF THE BILL AND
NOT GET SIDETRACKED BY
UNNECESSARY PERSONAL ATTACKS ON
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE. THANK
YOU. YOUR POINT IS WELL TAKEN
MISTER KILEY CAN YOU. STOP WITH
THE PERSONAL COMMENTS AND TRY TO
STICK TO THE MERITS OF YOUR OF
THIS BILL ENDING A PERSONAL COME
. I'M TALKING ABOUT EXACTLY WHAT
HAS JUST TRANSPIRED. IN FRONT OF
THIS COMMITTEE. I MISTER KILEY
YOU'VE EXCEEDED THE NORMAL
AMOUNT OF TIME THAT WE GET
PEOPLE TO CLOSE SO IF YOU CAN
TRY TO. CLARA AND THANK YOU. IF
IT IS YOUR BASIC DECENCY. AND
YOU KNOW I THINK THAT WE CAN
HAVE OUR DIFFERENCES WE CAN HAVE
OUR DIFFERENCES OF POLICY. BUT
WHAT HAPPENED WITH THIS BILL I
MEAN. IT WAS SITTING ON THE DESK
GATHERING DUST FOR OVER TWO
MONTHS I INTRODUCED IT. ON
JANUARY TWELFTH THAT'S THE
REASON WE TRY TO BRING IT TO THE
FLOOR FOR A VOTE. BECAUSE WE
WERE GIVEN HERE. SO THEN AFTER
WE DO THAT YOU FINALLY DECIDE TO
GIVE IT A HEARING AND OF COURSE
I KNEW YOU'RE GONNA DO THIS.
YOU'RE NOT PARTICULARLY CLEVER
ABOUT IT. I YOU BROUGHT THE
PARLIAMENTARIAN WITH YOU BY THE
WAY IS A IS A WONDERFUL PERSON
AND DOES HER JOB. VERY WELL. I'M
AND SO I KNEW WAS GONNA HAPPEN.
I EVEN TRIED TO TALK TO THE
CHAIRMAN FOR HIM TO SEE IF SHE
WOULD. SAY SOMETHING ABOUT IT
BUT NOW. I THERE WAS NO
DISCUSSION OF THAT SO I THINK
THAT. THE ISSUE HERE IS REALLY
ONE OF BASIC DECENCY AND THE
ISSUE A POLICY PERSPECTIVE IS
ONE THAT I WOULD HOPE WOULD JUST
BE KIND OF A SLAM DUNK LIKE
PEOPLE ARE REALLY IN PAIN.
PEOPLE NEED RELIEF IT'S HURTING
THE POOREST CALIFORNIANS THE
MOST I'VE TRIED TO PROVIDE A
FORM OF RELIEF THAT WILL BE
IMMEDIATE. IT WILL BE EFFECTIVE
IT'LL HELP OUT A LOT OF PEOPLE I
THINK IT'S UNFORTUNATE THAT THAT
IS BEING. USED AS A VEHICLE TO
JUST BUY POLITICAL GAMES BUT I
CAN ASSURE YOU THIS. BASED UPON
THAT PASSION THAT WE HEARD FROM
SOMEONE NUMBER FONG- JANET
NGUYEN. LAURIE DAVIES FOR MANY
OTHERS IN THIS LEGISLATURE WE
ARE NOT GOING TO BE DETERRED BY
THESE POLITICAL GAMES WE'RE
GONNA CONTINUE TO FIGHT TO DO
THE RIGHT THING FOR THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA THE TURN THE STATE
AROUND. SO I URGE A NO VOTE ON
THE AMENDMENTS THAT- MY
COLLEAGUES I'M WILLING TO PUT
HIS NAME ON AND I URGE A YES
VOTE ON THE ORIGINAL BILL BUT I
AM PROUD TO HAVE MY NAME ON.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
CAN WE HAVE A ROLL CALL PLEASE.
AB SIXTEEN THIRTY EIGHT TO PASS
AS AN AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS FRIEDMAN HI
FRIEDMAN IPHONE. FONG NO BERMAN
BERMAN I CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM
NO DALY. DAVIES DAVIES NO GIPSON
GIPSON I KALRA OVER I LI LI I
BLEW. HELLO I. NAZARIAN WHEN NO
O'DONNELL. WARD WARD I WICKS
WICKS I. HE. EIGHT FOUR EIGHT
FOUR THAT BILL IS OUT. WE WILL
MOVE ON. TO MS BURNER FOR ABOUT
THE BILL. OF SEVENTEEN THIRTEEN.
YES WELL NOW WE HAVE GREAT
THINGS TO MOVE TO BIKES- MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- AB SEVENTEEN THIRTEEN
WOULD MAKE INTERSECTIONS SAFER
FOR BICYCLISTS DRIVERS AND
PEDESTRIANS BY ALLOWING
BICYCLISTS TO TREAT STOP SIGNS
AS YIELD SIGNS WHEN APPROACHING
AN INTERSECTION SPECIFICALLY THE
BOAT WILL OUT INDIVIDUALS
EIGHTEEN YEARS OF AGE AND OLDER.
TO YIELD WHEN APPROACHING A STOP
SIGN AN INTERSECTION A RECENT AS
RECENTLY AMENDED THE BILL DOES
THE FOLLOWING AND MAKES A SIX
YEAR PILOT PROJECT INSTEAD OF
THREE YEAR SIEGE B. DOES NOT
ENOUGH TIME TO ANALYZE THE DATA
WE HAD AND THAT'S CONVERSATIONS.
LIMITS THE STOP AS YOUR TO TWO
LANE ROADS WITH STOP SIGNS AT
ALL CORNERS THIS IS TO MERA MORE
SPECIFICALLY THE DELAWARE YIELD
WHICH THIS BILLS BASED ON THAT
RESULT RESULT IN A 23% REDUCTION
IN BY CAR COLLISIONS- AND ADDS
THAT MINORS WHO FAILED TO STOP
AT STOP SIGNS WILL GET A WARNING
TICKET FOR THE FIRST OFFENSE.
VEHICLE CODE TWENTY ONE EIGHT OH
FOUR ALREADY PROVIDES A CLEAR
LEGAL DEFINITION AN EXPECTATION
OF THOSE REQUIRED TO YIELD AT
INTERSECTION. UNDER THIS CODE
SECTION THE DRIVER OF ANY
VEHICLE INCLUDING BIKES
APPROACHING AN INTERSECTION WITH
A YIELD SIGN MUST YIELD TO THE
RIGHT OF WAY OF ANY VEHICLES OR
PEDESTRIANS AND ENTERED THE
INTERSECTION AB SEVENTEEN
THIRTEEN YEARS OF COMMON
UNDERSTANDING OF A YIELD SIGN TO
ALLOW BICYCLISTS APPROACHING AN
INTERSECTION WITH A STOP SIGN TO
SLOW DOWN AND YIELD TO ANY CARS
AND PEDESTRIANS. ALREADY IN THE
INTERSECTION. IF IT IS ONLY IF
AND ONLY IF IT IS SAFE TO DO SO
A BICYCLE CAN THEN PROCEED
THROUGH THE INTERSECTION WITHOUT
MAKING A COMPLETE STOP I WANT TO
BE CLEAR THAT SEVEN AB SEVENTEEN
THIRTY IS NOT A BILL AUTHORIZED
BY SCHOOLS TO DO A ROLLING STOP.
BLOW THROUGH A STOP SIGN A
ROLLING STOP AND BLOWING THROUGH
A STOP SIGN IS THE LEGAL NOW AND
WILL CONTINUE TO BE ILLEGAL
UNDER MY BELT ROLLING STOP IS
NOT YIELDING. THE GOAL OF AB
SEVENTY THREE THIRTEEN IS TO
MAKE BICYCLES BEHAVIOR
PREDICTABLE FOR DRIVERS AS THEY
APPROACH AN INTERSECTION ALL
ROADS LEAD TO BE SAFER FOR ALL
ROAD USERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE IN WITH US I
THINK ON THE LINE I HAVE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL JIM BURROWS
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA.
ASSOCIATION OF BICYCLE
ORGANIZATIONS. THANK YOU A TWO
MINUTES PLEASE. HELLO MY NAME IS
JIM ROSS AND THE PRESIDENT OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
BICYCLING ORGANIZATIONS
PROVIDING THIS COMMENT TO
SUPPORT AB SEVENTEEN THIRTEEN
THIS CHANGE THE CALIFORNIA
BECAUSE OF SERVE TO HELP MAKE
BICYCLING IN CALIFORNIA SAFER.
MORE CONVENIENT IN A MORE LIKELY
CHOICE FOR TRAVEL IN CALIFORNIA
I HEARD YESTERDAY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE HAVE TO IN THIS IS
IN OPPOSITION- WE HAVE SOMEONE
FROM THE CALL CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR CHILDREN'S SAFETY
AND HEALTH IN PERSON. THAT
INDIVIDUALS HERE IF YOU WANT TO
COME UP TO THE CHAIR FOR YOUR
TWO MINUTES THANK YOU VERY MUCH
YOU CAN JUST INTRODUCE YOURSELF
I DON'T HAVE YOUR NAME I'M SORRY
ABOUT THAT. I'M SORRY CAN YOU
PUSH THE BUTTON PLEASE. THERE WE
GO. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS GOOD AFTERNOON I'M KATHY
BRINK AND I'M WITH THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR
CHILDREN'S SAFETY AND HEALTH. OF
THIS IS A BILL THAT WE
UNFORTUNATELY HAD TO OPPOSE LAST
YEAR AS WELL. OUR OUR JOB FOR
THE PAST THIRTY YEARS HAS BEEN
TO WORK ON REDUCING
UNINTENTIONAL CHILDHOOD
INJURIES. AND EVEN THOUGH- AND
WE APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT
CHILDREN HAVE BEEN TAKEN OUT OF
THE BILL THE PROBLEM WITH
CHILDREN AS THEY MIMIC. THEIR
SIBLINGS THEY MIMIC THEIR
PARENTS THEY MIMIC OTHER BICYCLE
RIDERS AND WE ARE. REALLY
CONCERNED ABOUT TEACHING THEM
THAT IT'S OKAY TO ROLL THROUGH A
STOP SIGN. OF THE GOVERNOR MADE
A POINT OF LAST YEAR WHEN HE
VETOED THE ORIGINAL BILL. THAT
SAYS. OF FATALITIES AND SERIOUS
INJURIES HAVE BEEN ON THE RISE
ON THE STATE'S ROADS SINCE TWO
THOUSAND TEN. THE STATEWIDE
INTEGRATED TRAFFIC RECORD SYSTEM
SHOWS THAT SINCE TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN. THERE WERE THREE
THOUSAND FIFTY NINE CRASHES
INVOLVING BICYCLES AND
INTERSECTIONS IN WHICH THE
PRIMARY COLLISION FACTOR. WAS
FAILURE TO STOP AT THE STOP
SIGN. A WE BELIEVE VERY STRONGLY
THAT STOP MEANS STOP. AND THAT
THE CONFUSION THAT THIS WILL
CAUSE FOR DRIVERS WOULD LEAD TO
ADDITIONAL FATALITIES AND
SERIOUS INJURIES. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- AND ON THE PHONE WE HAVE
ERIN READ FROM A REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
HIGHWAY PATROLMEN OPERATE IF YOU
CAN FIND MISTER REED. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- ERIN READ EVERYTHING
C. H. P. WE WANT TO IDENTIFY
WITH THE COMMENTS MADE BY KATHY
BRINK AND- WE TOTALLY AGREE WITH
HER POSITION- YEARS EXPECTING
CHP OFFICERS. AND OTHER LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS TO ENFORCE
THE LAW AND- AND I APPRECIATE
THE FACT THAT YOU'RE SAYING IS
FOR EIGHTEEN YEAR OLD. AND OLDER
HOW DOES AN OFFICER KNOW
SOMEBODY THAT. EIGHTEEN
SEVENTEEN SIXTEEN THEY'RE
WEARING A HELMET SOMETIMES
YOU'RE WEARING MASKS IF IT'S
VERY HARD TO TELL IN IN THE ONUS
IS ON. THE OFFICER DID YOU MAKE
THAT DETERMINATION- IT IS IT
THAT YOU'RE PUTTING THEM IN A-
DIFFICULT POSITION- TO TRY AND
DO THAT- IT'S ALSO. YOU KNOW THE
STATISTICS. DON'T STOP. PEOPLE
ON TELEVISION FROM. HE READ. OF
THREE TO- CRASHES IT IS SERIOUS
AND THAT'S HAPPENING NOW- IT'S
ONLY GONNA GET WORSE AT IT THIS
IS A PILOT. IT INSTEAD OF JUST
ONE LEGAL BY THE NUMBER OF YEARS
WE SHOULD BE LIMITED AND
LOCATION. IT IS A STATEWIDE
EVERY THAT THERE'S HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF MILES OF ROADWAY
THERE COVERED BY THIS BILL
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF ROADS
THAT ARE TWO LANE ROAD- BOTH
INCORPORATED CITIES AND
UNINCORPORATED AREAS OF OUR
STATE THIS BILL SHOULD BE
LIMITED. TO A FEW LOCALITIES SO
IT CAN BE TESTED- IT IS WAY WAY
TOO BROAD WHERE IT FOR THOSE
REASONS WERE POST. THANK YOU
WILL NOW GO TO ANYONE IN THE
ROOM WHO IS- WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
ON THIS BILL FOR AGAINST. GO
AHEAD SIR BILL MCGOVERN
COALITION FOR CLEAN AIR AND A
BICYCLE COMMUTER IN SUPPORT.
WHAT WHAT ONE MOMENT TO- DO WE
HAVE THE MICROPHONE ON FOR THE
PUBLIC WAS IN ON. OKAY SO I MAKE
SURE SORRY I DIDN'T HEAR IT.
YEAH THANK YOU VERY MUCH. DAN
ALISON OF ICICLE WEST IN SUPPORT
. THANK YOU SEE NO MORE
TESTIMONY IN THE ROOM CAN WE GO
TO THE PHONES FOR TESTIMONY FOR
AND AGAINST AB SEVENTEEN
THIRTEEN. SO TO SPEAK AND NOT IN
FAVOR OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
WE'LL GO FIRST TO LINE THREE
SEVENTY SIX GO AHEAD. AT A
HEARING YES WE CAN. THE
INTERLUDE NORTHWEST WOULD NEVER
COUNCIL- SUPPORT. LINE TO NINETY
SEVEN. I DEFINITELY WANT COMING
UP THE CALIFORNIA BICYCLE
COALITION CAL BIKE IN SUPPORT.
NINE THREE SEVENTY ONE. THANK
YOU MY BRIDE. CUSTER COUNTY
SEVENTEEN THIRTEEN OPPOSITION.
LINE. ONE ELEVEN. AND ACTIVISTS
OVER THE NEXT TO TRIAL WE HAVE A
SUPPORT THE COMMANDED TO SIXTEEN
YEARS OLD POSITION. NINE FOUR
EIGHTY SEVEN. HI THIS IS ABOUT
THE FISH ON BEHALF OF BY CULVER
CITY AND WE SHARE THE SUPPORT
AMENDED TO SIXTEEN YEARS OLD.
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS ROGER
DICKINSON ON BEHALF OF CIVIC
WELL FORMERLY. THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMISSION IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. LINE. ONE EIGHTY SIX.
NINE ONE EIGHTY SIX GERMANICUM
SHOP A BICYCLE INCLUSION WE
SUPPORT. LINE. FOR EIGHTY ONE.
RECALLING LOS ANGELES BICYCLIST
IMPORTERS AMENDED TO FIFTEEN AN
OLDER. LINE. THREE SIXTY NINE.
IN OPPOSITION. ONE SEVEN ONE
THREE. ONE MORE LINE IN Q. ONE
MOBILE WHAT WE PROVIDE THERE MY
NUMBER. LINE. FOR EIGHTY TWO. HI
JOSH COOPER FROM NORTH HOLLYWOOD
SUPPORT OF AMENDED TO SIXTEEN
YEARS OLD. WE HAVE NO FOR THE
LINES IN Q. AND A MAY PROCEED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE'LL TAKE
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. I THINK
WE HAVE MOLD UP DID YOU WANT TO
SPEAK MISTERS ERIN GO AHEAD
PLEASE. THAT'S YOUR WHICH WON
THE MIKE IS BUT I'LL TAKE THIS
ONE. MISA MISA BURNER HARBATH AP
SHEET THE THAT YOU BRING THIS
BILL FORWARD I'M ALWAYS JUST
VERY HESITANT ABOUT BILLS THAT
TRIED TO ADDRESS AN ISSUE ONE
SIZE FIT ALL. AND I APOLOGIZE I
DIDN'T GET A CHANCE TO TALK TO
YOU ABOUT THIS BEFORE TODAY- I
WAS HOPE I DON'T KNOW IF YOU'D
BE WILLING TO ENTERTAIN THE IDEA
OF AT LEAST MAKING IT BASED ON
JURISDICTIONS BECAUSE- NOT ALL
COUNTIES ARE THE SAME NOT ALL.
JEWISH LOCAL JURISDICTIONS ARE
THE SAME. I DON'T KNOW IF THIS
WOULD WORK NECESSARILY WELL. IN
LOS ANGELES. AND I APPRECIATE
THE FOLKS THAT ARE CALLING IN.
AS WELL FROM LA BUT THE REALITY
IS THAT THERE ARE A LOT OF BLIND
INTERSECTIONS. I DON'T KNOW IF
SOMETHING LIKE THIS WOULD WORK
WELL IN A PLACE IN A DENSE AT
PLACE LIKE LOS ANGELES. UP BUT I
KNOW THAT IN. SPACE WISE 90% OF
THE REST OF THE STATE IT'LL WORK
JUST FINE. I AND I UNDERSTAND
THAT BUT MAYBE WE CAN. TAILOR IT
SO THAT LOCAL JURISDICTIONS CAN
PARTICIPATE IN THIS SAID THAT
THOSE THAT DON'T FEEL IT'S
APPROPRIATE. DON'T HAVE TO.
SEVEN I RESPOND. TO YOUR RESPOND
IN YOUR CLOTHES SO ME TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANY OTHER COMMENTS YEAH
MISTER- MISTER O'DONNELL. I
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR NOT. I
WISH I COULD SUPPORT THIS TODAY
BUT I'M JUST NOT THERE THIS IS A
PARENT AND A TEACHER BROWN KIDS
A LOT AND I THINK WHEN SOMETHING
IS CONFUSING AT LEAST TO AN
UNSAFE SITUATION HAS BEEN HAS
BEEN HAS BEEN ALLUDED TO BY ONE
OF THE- SPEAKERS EARLIER.
BECAUSE WE'VE GOT A SITUATION
HERE WHERE. YOU KNOW SOMETIMES
YOU GOTTA STOP SOMETIMES YOU
DON'T STOP WITH THIS GROUP HAS A
STOP THAT GROUP DOESN'T HAVE TO
STOP TYPE THING AND I JUST THINK
THAT'S GONNA LEAD TO CONFUSION
CONFUSION LEADS FOR DANGER SO
FOR THAT REASON FOR THOSE
REASONS I CANNOT BE SUPPORTER
OF. TODAY THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
COMMENTS. I'LL JUST MAKE MY
COMMENT BEFORE YOU CLOSE WHICH
IS I SUPPORTED THE PREVIOUS BILL
AND I WAS SORRY TO SEE IT BE
TOWED YOU KNOW I'VE SEEN THAT
READ THAT 96% OF CYCLISTS
ALREADY USE THESE ROLLING STOPS
AND THAT SHOWS YOU THAT THERE'S
SOMETHING WRONG WITH THE WAY
THAT WE'VE ENGINEERED OUR
STREETS FOR CYCLISTS BECAUSE IT
IS NOT JUST DIFFICULT TO
CONSTANTLY COME TO A COMPLETE
STOP WHEN YOU'RE ON A BICYCLE
AND PUT YOUR FOOT DOWN. BUT IN
SOME CASES DANGEROUS BECAUSE IT
IT YOU HAVE THAT YOU'RE BECAUSE
YOU'RE SO MUCH SLOWER WHEN
YOU'RE MOVING INTO THE
INTERSECTION AND I THINK THAT
LEGALIZING THIS NOT ONLY STOPS
OF. THE THESEVERY PUNITIVE
TICKETS THAT ARE GIVEN SOMETIMES
FOR THIS- AND IT WOULD ALLOW-
THE POLICE TO FOCUS ON THE TRULY
DANGEROUS. BEHAVIOR FROM
CYCLISTS. BUT ALSO GIVES CARS
MORE CERTAINTY ABOUT WHAT THEY
SHOULD EXPECT IN TERMS OF
CYCLIST BEHAVIOR- SO. I AM
SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR STATE YOUR STICK
IT TO WITNESS- AND BRINGING THIS
BACK TO US. EVEN THOUGH IT'S IN
A DIFFERENT FORM WITH THAT I
INVITE YOU TO CLOSE. THANK YOU
SO MUCH GUYS I'LL TRY TO ANSWER
ALL YOUR QUESTIONS- THE REALITY
IS- FROM WHAT THE OPPOSITION
SAID. WE'RE CURRENTLY DOING
NOTHING TO MAKE CYCLING AND
INTERSECTIONS SAFER FOR
CYCLISTS. OF THE DELAWARE YIELD
SPECIFICALLY USES YIELDING NOT
ROLLING THROUGH AND APPLYING
THROUGH STOP SIGNS. AS A VERY
SAFE TECHNIQUE THEY DID A PILOT.
STATEWIDE AND DELAWARE IS A
SMALL STATE BUT WASHINGTON ALSO
HAS OF A SEATTLE WHICH IS A VERY
URBAN AREA. AND THE OVERSIGHT
23% REDUCTION AND BIKE CAR
COLLISIONS AT THOSE
INTERSECTIONS. SO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER NECESSARY AND WE LIMITED
THE BELT TO ONLY TWO LANE ROADS
WHERE THEY'RE AT- STOP SIGNS AT
ALL- CORNERS. SO THIS WHEN
APPLIED AT BLIND INTERSECTIONS
OR TO A STOP STORY OF A
THOROUGHFARE THIS WOULD WOULDN'T
LIMIT IT TO WHAT DELAWARE DINES
AT THE DELAWARE YOU KNOW THAT
WE- MARK PROXIMITY THAT. THE
REASON YOU HAVE A PROBLEM WITH
REGIONALIZATION RESENT
REGIONALIZATION SO SAY WE WANT
TO JUST DO A PILOT SAN DIEGO
COUNTY RIGHT YOU'RE LIKE TASHA
FROM SAN DIEGO. THEY ALL LIKE
BIKING OF SAN DIEGO MAYBE THEY
SHOULD DO THAT WE CONSIDER THIS
OPTION THE PROBLEM ISN'T COMING
FROM LA. DOESN'T EXPECT A
BICYCLIST TO YIELD IN SAN DIEGO
COUNTY AND THEY COME DOWN.
YOU'RE NOT INCREASING THE SAFETY
OF THE BICYCLIST. YOU HAVE TO DO
IT STATEWIDE SO THE OF
PREDICTABILITY. WE HAVE RULES
THAT TO CLEARLY DIFFERENTIATE AT
EIGHTEEN. EIGHTEEN AND BELOW
HAVE TO WEAR A HELMET. WE
CLEARLY HAVE RULES AND CYCLING
AROUND WHAT MINERS ARE REQUIRED
TO DO AND WHAT ADULTS ARE
ALLOWED TO DO. AND THIS WAS SAY
THIS PILOT WILL BE AROUND ADULTS
AND THEREFORE YOU GIVE THE
PREDICTABILITY. TO DRIVERS A
WHAT THE BICYCLIST BEHAVIOR S.
AND THAT IS THE KEY THAT RESOLVE
THIS 23% REDUCTION AND BIKE CAR
COLLISIONS. IN DELAWARE AND I
THINK IF WE DO THIS AND WE DO
THE SIX ARE PROBABLY WE'RE GONNA
SEE THE SAME DATA. IN FACT THE
NATIONAL PHONE TO GET THE
APPRECIATION OF THE NATIONAL
TRAFFIC. HEALTH AND SAFETY.
REPORT IS LISTED IN YOUR- BILL
ANALYSIS HAS THE SCENE THERE HAS
BEEN NO SIGNIFICANT INCREASE. IN
THE EIGHT STATES THAT HAVE. THIS
LAW. THEY HAVE NOT SEEN AN
INCREASE AND BY CAR COLLISION IF
ANYTHING THEY'VE SEEN A- IT'S
NOT THAT. THING BECAUSE WE'RE
LACKING DATA ONE THING OUR BILL
WILL DO IS ALSO GIVE A VERY REAL
BUS THE- DATA. TO OUR- CYCLING
COMMUNITY AND OUR- TRAFFIC
COMMUNITY SO THAT WE CAN SAY
THIS ACTUALLY REDUCES IT I WILL
NOT RUN THIS BILL. IF I THOUGHT
IT PUT ANYBODY'S LIFE IN DANGER.
I DO THIS AS A CYCLIST I YIELD
THROUGH STOP SIGNS I DON'T ROLL
THROUGH STOP SINCE A YOU'LL TO
STOP SENSE. BECAUSE MY PRIMARY
GOAL IS A CYCLIST IS NOT TODAY.
AND SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE BUT TODAY. THANK YOU WITH A
QUICK CANAVERAL CALL PLEASE. AB
SEVENTEEN THIRTEEN TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS FRIEDMAN I
FRIEDMAN IPHONE. FONG NO BERMAN
BERMAN I CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM
I DAILY DAILY I DAVIES DAVIES NO
GIPSON. KALRA KALRA I LI LI I
BLEW BLOOM I NAZARIAN. NAZARIAN
NOT VOTING WHEN. NO WIN NO
O'DONNELL- DONALD NOT VOTING.
WARD WICKS. SEVEN TWO. THANK YOU
THAT PULLS OUT WILL LEAVE THE
ROLE OPEN THANK YOU OKAY WE NOW
HAVE MISTER GRAYSON WITH TWENTY
THREE FIFTY. WELCOMING YOU MAY
PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE I AM PLEASED TO
PRESENT AB TWENTY THREE FIFTY
WHICH WILL CREATE A CONSUMER
REBATE PROGRAM FOR CONVERTING
CARS INTO ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES
AS CALIFORNIA DRIVERS SHIFT
TOWARDS A CLEANER FUTURE
CONSUMERS AND THE CAR INDUSTRY
HAVE BEGUN CONVERTING USED
GASOLINE POWERED VEHICLES AND
HYDROGEN OR ELECTRIC ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES. MAJOR
AUTOMAKERS INCLUDING FORD AND
GENERAL MOTORS HAVE UNVEILED
ZERO EMISSION QUOTE UNQUOTE
CRATE MOTORS THEY CAN BE USED TO
REPLACETHE ENGINE IN A GAS
POWERED VEHICLE ONE MANUFACTURER
OFFERS COMPLETE RETROFIT KITS
FOR A CLASSIC VOLKSWAGEN BEETLE
FOR JUST UNDER EIGHTEEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS THAT'S TEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS CHEAPER THAN SOME OF THE
MOST INEXPENSIVE ELECTRIC CARS
ON THE MARKET. TO MEET
CALIFORNIA'S CONSUMERS DEMAND
FOR MORE AFFORDABLE CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION OPTIONS THE STATE
NEEDS NEW AND CREATIVE WAYS TO
MAKE SEVEN OWNERSHIP MORE
ACCESSIBLE AND MORE AFFORDABLE
BY CREATING A CONSUMER REBATE
PROGRAM FOR CONVERTING USED
GASOLINE POWERED CARS INTO ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES AB TWENTY
THREE FIFTY WILL HELP THE STATE
MEET THIS THAT MEET ITS
AMBITIOUS CLIMATE GOALS. MY
WITNESS IS CHRISTIAN ROBINSON
WITH THE SPECIALTY EQUIPMENT
MARKET ASSOCIATION. OKAY YOUR-
WITNESS IS BY PHONE SO IF WE CAN
OPERATOR PLEASE FIND CHRISTIAN
WROTE ROBINSON. FOR TWO MINUTES
. SHE. HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME.
YES. FRIEDMAN LIKE YOUR FONG AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK WITH YOU TODAY ABOUT AB
TWENTY THREE FIFTY WHAT TO
CREATE A NEW PROGRAM TO
INCENTIVIZE CONSUMERS TO CONVERT
GASOLINE OR DIESEL POWERED
VEHICLES INTO ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES OR TWO THOUSAND DOLLAR
REBATE WHILE ENSURING THE 25% OF
THOSE REBATES GO TO INDIVIDUAL
SELLABLE ELIGIBLE FOR CLEAN CARS
FOR ALL. MY NAME I KRISTEN
ROBINSON I'M THE DIRECTOR STATE
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS AT THE
SPECIALTY EQUIPMENT MARKET
ASSOCIATION WHICH IS
HEADQUARTERED IN DIAMOND BAR
CALIFORNIA. THEME OF THE
NATIONAL TRADE ASSOCIATION THAT
REPRESENTS MORE THAN SEVENTY
FIVE HUNDRED MOSTLY SMALL
BUSINESSES NATIONWIDE INCLUDING
OVER FIFTEEN HUNDRED THE GOLDEN
STATE THAT MANUFACTURE MARKET
AND SELL SPECIALTY AUTOMOTIVE
AFTERMARKET PRODUCTS INCLUDING
APPEARANCE PERFORMANCE
RESTORATION AND TECH PRODUCTS
FOR CARS AND TRUCKS. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GRAYSON MENTIONED TO THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAS
AMBITIOUS GOALS FOR IMPROVING
AIR QUALITY IN REMOVING
POLLUTING VEHICLES FROM THE
ROAD. INCLUDING AIMING TO HAVE
ALL NEW CAR SALES PZ EVEY BY
TWENTY THIRTY FIVE. IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE THAT WAS CONSTITUTED
12% OF THE VEHICLES IN THE
STATE. ADDITIONALLY THE STATE
HAS INTERMEDIATE GOAL IN
INTERMEDIATE CALL HAVING FIVE
MILLION SEVEN HUNDRED BY TWENTY
THIRTY. AT THE END OF TWENTY
TWENTY THAT NUMBER STOOD AT
APPROXIMATELY SIX HUNDRED THIRTY
FIVE THOUSAND. UNFORTUNATELY IN
THE CURRENT MARKET PLACE HE
DAVIS ARE OUT OF REACH FOR MOST
CONSUMERS. ACCORDING TO A RECENT
REPORT FROM BLOOMBERG COUPLE
ONLY 15% OF DRIVERS CAN AFFORD A
NEW STAFF. AN INDIVIDUAL SPENDS
10% OF THEIR MONTHLY PAYMENT OF
VEHICLE A GROSS ANNUAL PAY OF A
HUNDRED AND TEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS. PER HOUSEHOLD IS NEEDED
TO AVOID OF FORTIS APPS TODAY
THE AVERAGE HOUSEHOLD INCOME IN
CALIFORNIA SEVENTY NINE
THOUSAND. WHILE IT CONSISTS
CONSIDERING THESE FACTORS
TOGETHER TWO THINGS ARE CLEAR
CONSUMERS NEED MORE OPTIONS WHEN
CONSIDERING IT'S A FUTURE I NEED
SOME FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE TO
MAKE IT HAPPEN. AB TWENTY THIRTY
FIVE TACKLES BALLS. BUT THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THEME SHOW LOS
VEGAS WHICH WAS THE LARGEST
AUTOMOTIVE TRADE SHOW IN NORTH
AMERICA SINCE THE PANDEMIC
BEGAN. SAID CONVERSION STOLE THE
SHOW. INCLUDING VEHICLES POWERED
BY CHEVY'S EACH CRATE AND FORD'S
ILLUMINATOR ELECTRIC CRATE
MOTORS CHEVY THECREED INCLUDES
AN ELECTRIC MOTOR BATTERY SYSTEM
AND TRANSMISSION THAT CAN BE
INSTALLED IN THE VEHICLE. WELL
FOR THE NOMINATOR COSTS JUST
UNDER FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS. AND
I SHOULD MENTION THE BIRD THE
INITIAL PRODUCTION RUN IN THE
FOURTH GRADE- PENSION SOLD OUT
ALMOST IMMEDIATELY. CONVERTING
OLDER CARS AND CLASSIC VEHICLES
AND IS AS USING MOTORISTS LIKE
THE ONES DESCRIBED JUST
DESCRIBE. WHAT CONSUMERS TO
PROVIDE PRESERVE CALIFORNIA'S
RICH CAR CULTURE WHILE LIMITING
CARBON EMISSIONS. HOWEVER THERE
IS NO STATE SUPPORTED PROGRAM TO
INCENTIVIZE CAN RUNNING GASOLINE
OR DIESEL POWERED VEHICLES
TRYING TO HYDROGEN OR
ELECTRICITY. TO MEET THE
CONSUMER'S DEMANDS AND CREATE
MORE AFFORDABLE WAYS TO CREATE
CLEAN TRANSPORTATION THE STATE
NEEDS NEW AND CREATIVE WAYS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MENTIONED. TO
MAKE THAT OWNERSHIP MORE
ACCESSIBLE. MAYBE TWENTY THIRTY
FIVE HELP ACCOMPLISH THAT GOAL.
BLUES WRITTEN TO ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WE HAVE NO
OPPOSITION ON FILE SO WE'RE
GONNA GO TO SEE THIS ANYONE IN
THE HEARING ROOM WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK FOR OR AGAINST. THE BILL.
SEEING NONE OPERATE CAN BE PLAY
OPEN UP THE PHONE LINES A B.
TWO. THREE FIFTY. SO TO SPEAK IN
FAVOR OPPOSITION OF AB TWENTY
THREE FIFTY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. MADAM CHAIR WE
HAVE KNOWN QUEUED UP FOR THE FOR
THE FROM THE HOMELANDS THANK YOU
WILL GO BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
WE HAVE A MOTION. AND A SECOND
ANY QUESTIONS CONCERNS. THE
SERVICE WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NAY VOTE
GREAT CLOSING OKAY I WILL BE
SUPPORTING YOUR BILL GREAT IDEA
CANAVERAL CALL PLEASE. AB TWENTY
THREE FIFTY DO PASSED TO NATURAL
RESOURCES FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN
IPHONE. FONG I BERMAN.
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM AYE DALY
DALY I DAVIES DAVIES I'D GIPSON
. KALRA KALRA I LEE THE I. BLOOM
BLOOM I NAZARIAN. NAZARIAN I
WENT. WHEN I O'DONNELL O'DONNELL
I WORK. WICKS. ELEVEN ZERO
ELEVEN ZERO THAT THOSE OUT WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN THANK YOU
REGISTER TING WE ARE HERE FOR
YOUR BILLS FIRST UP IS AB TWENTY
SIXTY ONE YOU CAN PERCEIVE ONE
READY THANK YOU. THANK MELCHER
FIRST LET ME JUST THANK YOU AND
YOUR COMMITTEE STAFFER- WORKING
WITH MY STAFF ON THE BILL AB
TWENTY SIXTY ONE. REQUIRES
CHARGING COMPANIES TO PROVIDE
DATA TO THE STATE ON THE
RELIABILITY OF THEIR CHARGERS.
SHOULD THE USE PUBLIC FUNDS AND
AGAIN THAT'S A VERY IMPORTANT
DISTINCTION SHOULD USE PUBLIC
FUNDS TO DEPLOY THEM INCLUDING.
A REPAIR FUNDING. RIGHT NOW WITH
HER TRYING TO DEPLOY MORE EVEY
CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE ALL OVER
THE PLACE AS OUR EVEY DRIVER
I'VE HAD. DIFFICULTY HAVE FOUND
CHARGING STATIONS THAT OFTEN
DON'T WORK OFTEN AREN'T RELIABLE
SO IMPORTANT THAT AS WE ARE
SPENDING A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT
BILLIONS OF STATE DOLLARS. AND
WE'RE ASSURING THE RELIABILITY
OF THE STATIONS BUT ALSO. THAT
THE THERE IS DATA AND THERE IS
ANALYSIS TO ENSURE THAT WE ARE
PROPERLY DEPLOYING THEM- BUT
THAT. THANK YOU ARE TOO TWO
QUICK WITNESSES OF THE OF
MISTER- WILLIS AND MISTERI.
QUICK IS PERFECT US SO IF WE CAN
GO TO YOUR FIRST WITNESS. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS CORBELS
ON BEHALF OF FLOW HERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT WE ARE EVEY CHARGING
STATION PROVIDER THAT'S BEEN IN
BUSINESS FOR OVER TEN YEARS WE
THINK ASKING FOR THE STATE IS A
VERY REASONABLE REQUEST ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE AND
COMPANIES LIKE OURS ALREADY
COLLECT THE DATA WE HAVE THIS AT
OUR FINGERTIPS. AND CAN BE
PROVIDED SO THAT WE CAN
UNDERSTAND HOW RELIABILITY IS
IMPACTING EVEN ADOPTION IF AT
ALL SO STRONGLY RESPECTFULLY
URGE YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND- YOUR
OTHER WITNESS PLEASE. AARON
THANK YOU I'M THE CEO OF A
COMPANY CAR CHARGER HOPE- WE ARE
A TECHNOLOGY COMPANY THAT
ENABLES ON DEMAND REPAIR OF THE
V. CHARGING STATIONS AND WE ALSO
HIRE LOCALLY. I'M CURRENTLY
WORKING ABOUT ELEVEN STATES I'M
ACROSS THE UNITED STATES AND WE
RECENTLY FOUND IN STATES SUCH AS
CALIFORNIA AT THE CURRENT PUBLIC
INFRASTRUCTURE CAN BE FOUND
OFFLINE ARE BROKEN 30% OF THE
TIME. AND GIVEN CALIFORNIA'S
GOALS OF THE PLOY A TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND CHARGING STATIONS
BY TWENTY TWENTY FIVE IMPLANTS
THE PLAY UPWARDS OF ONE POINT
TWO FIVE MILLION BY TWENTY
THIRTY FIVE WE BELIEVE THAT THIS
AMOUNT OF INOPERABLE CHARGING
STATIONS WILL SIGNIFICANTLY
UNDERMINE ALL OF OUR EFFORTS.
I'M IS SO WE STRONGLY- WOULD
LOVE FOR YOU ALL TO- SUPPORT THE
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU WE DO
HAVE ONE WITNESS REGISTERED IN
OPPOSITION- CREAM TO RECEIVE
FROM THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF REALTORS. IS NOT IN THE ROOM
OPERATOR CAN YOU SEE IF HE IS ON
THE LINE. ONE MOMENT PLEASE. AND
I DO HAVE INDICATION THEY MIGHT
NOT BE ABLE TO HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
TESTIFY BUT I JUST WANT TO MAKE
SURE. I DO NOT SEE THAT
PARTICIPANT- HAVING DIALED IN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SO WE'LL GO
TO- SUPPORTER OPPOSITION IN THE
ROOM. BILL MCGOVERN COALITION
FOR CLEAN AIR SUPPORT. THANK YOU
AND SEEING NO ONE ELSE CAN WE
OPEN UP THE PHONE LINES FOR
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO AB
TWENTY SIXTY ONE. THANK YOU TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
OF AB TWENTY SIXTY ONE PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME
. WE WILL FIRST GO TO LINE. FOUR
EIGHTY FIVE GO AHEAD PLEASE
CLICK THERE AMERILA CALIFORNIANS
ARE MENTAL BATTERIES IN SUPPORT. PINE. FIFTY SIX. YUP WE'VE
LOST LINE FIFTY SIX FIVE FIFTY
SIX IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO RE
QUEUE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. GO
AHEAD AND. YES GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS CLEAN
GREASY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS- WITH AN OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION- JUST SEEKING A
CLARIFYING AMENDMENT VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR IN THE
COMMITTEE- CONSIDERING OUR
CONCERNS AND- BUT UNFORTUNATELY
AT THIS TIME MUCH RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOU KNOW THE DO
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S
CONSIDERATION VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU SO MUCH. LINE FOR NINETY
EIGHT GO AHEAD. NINE FOUR NINETY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO
GO AHEAD PLEASE. HI ERICA ROMERO
ON BEHALF OF THE VALLEY CLEAN
AIR NOW IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
SIXTY ONE THANK YOU. LYING. TO
NINETY FIVE. YES THIS ON BEHALF OF THREE FIFTY
BAY AREA ACTION IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. LINE. FOR
SEVENTY ONE. WE ARE HERE MANAGER
COMMITTEE MEMBERS HEIDI SUPPORT
WITH AMPLY POWER IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY SIXTY ONE
THANK YOU. NINE THREE SEVENTY
ONE. DOCUMENT FRAUD PLASTER
COUNTY OPPOSED. TO TWO ZERO SIX
ONE. LINE FOR SEVENTY FOUR. NINE
FOUR SEVENTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. LINE FOR SEVENTY FOURS
DROPPED YOU MAY PROCEED THERE
ARE NO ON OTHER LINES IN Q.
THANK YOU ALL GO BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY. THIS IS A THIS
THANK YOU QUICK QUESTION IN
REGARDS TO- WHAT KERR WAS
TALKING ABOUT WITH THIS- APPLY
TO PRIVATE HOMEOWNERS. BUT NOT
NOT TO OUR KNOWLEDGE UNLESS THEY
RECEIVED A PUBLIC SUBSIDY THAT'S
MY UNDERSTAND THAT WOULD NOT. SO
ONLY IF IT WAS PUBLIC SUBSIDY
THAT THEY HAD I THINK I ACTUALLY
EVEN MORE SPECIFIC ITS STATE
MONEY WHICH I DON'T BELIEVE THAT
THEY DO GET. OKAY THANK YOU
THANK YOU. AND WE'RE WORKING ON
THAT AND THEN MEANT TO MAKE TO
CLARIFY THAT THOSE OF THEM AND
THEN SAY HE'S HE WAS DISCUSSING.
OKAY SO I'M GONNA TAKE THAT THAT
THAT'S A NO. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
. ANYONE ELSE. WELL I THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD I
THINK IT'S ALWAYS IMPORTANT THAT
WE HAVE METRICS ON HOW PUBLIC
DOLLARS ARE SPENT IN A VERY
BASIC METRIC IS KNOWING WHETHER
THE INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WE PAY
FOR IS WORKING OR NOT AND HOW
IT'S WORKING SO I DO A URGE YOU
TO CONTINUE WORKING WITH THE C.
C. AS YOU MOVE FORWARD TO MAKE
SURE THAT THIS IS ALL WORKABLE
BUT I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THE BILL FOR IT I'LL BE
SUPPORTING IT TODAY WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE NO DISRESPECT
YACHTS RIVA. THANK YOU CAN WE
ROLL CALL PLEASE. AB TWO ZERO
SIX WANTED TO PASS TO UTILITIES
AND ENERGY FRIEDMAN I FRIEDMAN
HI FONG. FONG I BERMAN
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM I DAILY
DAILY I DVIES DAVIES I GIPSON.
KALRA KALRA I LEE LEE I BLOW
BLOOM I NAZARIAN NAZARIAN I WENT
. WHEN I DONALD. DONALD I WORK.
WICKS. ELEVEN ZERO ELEVEN ZERO
THE BILL IS OUT WILL LEAVE THE
ROLE OPEN AND NOW TO A TRULY
EXCEPTIONAL BILL AB TWENTY ONE
FORTY SEVEN MR TANG WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR- AB TWENTY ONE FIVE FORTY
SEVEN IS OUR FREEDOM TO WALK ACT
AGAIN THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT
AND THE COMMITTEE'S HELP OUT
WITH THE BILL- WE ARE BRINGING
BACK OUR BILL TO MAKE SURE THAT
PEOPLE CAN SAFELY WALK ACROSS
THE STREET WITHOUT FEAR OF
CITATION- RIGHT NOW LAST YEAR'S
BILL ACTUALLY STRUCK OUT TH
PROVISIONS IN THE CODE THIS YEAR
WE JUST CLARIFIED THAT THE BILL.
PROHIBITS LAW ENFORCEMENT FOR
STOPPING INDIVIDUALS FOR JAY
WALKING UNLESS THERE IS
IMMEDIATE DANGER OF A COLLISION
OR MOVING VEHICLE AGAIN ONE OF
THE REASONS THAT WE ARE DOING IT
IS GOING TO MAKE OUR STREETS
SAFER I WE WANT TO CONTINUE TO
INCENTIVIZE PEDESTRIANS TO WALK
AND CROSS THE STREET CAN'T THINK
OF A BIGGER DISINCENTIVE TO
GETTING A CITATION ARE WE ALSO
KNOW THAT AFRICAN AMERICANS IN
THE STUDIES THAT WE HAVE AFRICAN
AMERICANS ARE FIVE TIMES MORE
LIKELY BE CITED THAN ANYBODY
ELSE THERE AND THEN JUST LASTLY
ON WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT.
WHEN LAW ENFORCEMENT IS
INTERFACING WITH INDIVIDUALS
THAT- SITUATION DOESN'T BECOME
PRECARIOUS WE UNFORTUNATELY HAVE
HAD INSTANCES WHERE LAW FOR
SPORTS CITING PEOPLE FOR JAY
WALKING AND THEY HAVE LED TO
FATALITIES SO AGAIN- WE WANNA
HAVE LAW ENFORCEMENT FOCUS ON
THE ISSUES THAT WE THINK ARE
SERIOUS SIR IN THIS IS
DEFINITELY NOT ONE OF THEM
WITHOUT RESPECT REYES VOTE ON A
B. TWENTY ONE FORTY SEVEN THANK
YOU WE HAVE TO WITNESSES AND
SUPPORT FIRST ON THE TELEPHONE
ANGIE SCHMITT IF- THE OPERATOR
COULD FIND. THE SMITH PLEASE.
FOR TWO MINUTES. HI CAN YOU HEAR
ME. YES HI OKAY SO MANY
MANAGEMENT I'M NOT HER BOOK
CALLED RIGHT AWAY THAT WAS
PUBLISHED IN TWENTY TWENTY IT
ASK YOU COULD STAND LAW- I WROTE
THE BOOK ON PEDESTRIAN SAFETY SO
I'M CALLING FROM OHIO JUST TO
SAY I SUPPORT THIS IN A PERSONAL
CAPACITY I ALSO WORK AS A
CONSULTANT WITH AMERICA WALKS IN
THERE STRONGLY SUPPORTED AS
WELL- WE KNOW THAT PEDESTRIAN
DEATHS ARE RELATED TO STRUCTURAL
PROBLEMS THAT HAVE TO DO WITH
INFRASTRUCTURE INEQUALITY- FOR
EXAMPLE IN LOS ANGELES ABOUT 6%
OF THE STREETS- THE STREET
NETWORK REPRESENTS 70% OF
SERIOUS INJURIES AND FATALITIES.
AND WE ALSO KNOW THAT A LOT OF-
LOWER INCOME NEIGHBORHOOD THE
NEIGHBORHOOD THE COLOR ARE
UNDERSERVED WITH THAT KIND OF
STATE THE INFRASTRUCTURE
INCLUDING CROSSWALKS THAT ARE
NEEDED NOT ONLY TO KEEP THEM
SAFE BUT TO ABIDE BY THE LAW AS
IT'S WRITTEN RIGHT NOW SO THERE
IS A RECENT STUDY BY- MARCEL
MORAN OUT OF UC BERKELEY.
FINDING WIDE VARIATION IN
CROSSWALK COVERAGE NEIGHBORHOOD
TO NEIGHBORHOOD- SOME
NEIGHBORHOODS HAD AS WELL WITH
7% CROSSWALK COVERAGE COMPARED
TO SOME WEALTHIER- WHITER
NEIGHBORHOODS WHERE IT WAS
COMPLETE 1100% SO AGAIN THAT WAS
RELATED TO RACE AND CLASS AND WE
SEE THAT KIND OF- PATTERN SORT
OF ACROSS THE COUNTRY AND IT'S
DEFINITELY PREVALENT IN
CALIFORNIA- SO WE WOULD REALLY
URGE- WE URGE YOU TO CONTINUE
LEADING THE WAY FORWARD ON THIS
KIND OF- LEGISLATION AND- IF I
CAN BE A RESOURCE TO ANYONE ON
THE COMMITTEE- FEEL FREE TO
REACH OUT. THANK YOU MUCH NEXT
WE IS SAROS ALSO ON THE PHONE-
OPERATOR IF YOU CAN PLEASE FIND
MISTER SORRY.
OPERATOR ARE YOU THERE. MISTERS
MISTER STARS IF YOU COULD PLEASE
MAKE SURE YOUR PHONE IS ON MUTE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. WE DO HAVE
JASON SERVICES LINE CONNECTED
HOWEVER HE IS NOT RESPONDING TO
US. OKAY WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO
OPPOSITION- WE HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA'S WORST MOM WHAT
MADAM CHAIR YES ONE MOMENT
PLEASE WHILE I TRY TO BE HERE
INTERNALLY OKAY. MISTER STARS IF
YOU COULD PLEASE TRY YOUR CALL
NOW. CAN YOU HEAR ME NOW YES
THANK YOU. OKAY GREAT HELLO MY
NAME IS USERS I'M A RESIDENT OF
AUTO AND I'M CURRENTLY HOMELESS
I'M HERE TO URGE YOU TO VOTE YET
YES ON AB TWENTY ONE FORTY SEVEN
THE FREEDOM TO WALK BACK. THANKS
SO MANY WHO HAS BEEN CITED FOR
JAYWALKING I'M WELL AWARE OF HOW
THESE LAWS MAKE IT EASY FOR
POLICE ARREST PEOPLE AND HOW
THEY GIVE RISE TO COLLATERAL
CONSEQUENCES. WHEN I WAS
STARTING IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN THERE ARE NO CARS
NEARBY I WAS CROSSING THE STREET
RIGHT NEAR A WELL KNOWN PARK FOR
HOMESTREET QUICK. I KNEW IT WAS
CHANGE. I WAS CITED ANYWAYS IN
THE POLICE OFFICER BLOCK TRAFFIC
WHILE CITING A LOT OF PEOPLE
WATCHED I WAS MADE TO FEEL LIKE
A CRIMINAL. IT IS THE ANSWER
DIDN'T STOP ME FOR JAIL ON. STOP
ME BECAUSE I LOOKED OF PLACE. I
AM SOME BAGS WITH ME IT WAS
OBVIOUS THAT I WAS HOME. THAT
MADE ME A TARGET IN HIS EYES.
WHILE CALIFORNIANS JAY WALKING
EVERY DAY AND NEVER GET CITED
LOWER INCOME PEOPLE AND PEOPLE
OF COLOR FRIEDMAN TARGETED FOR
JAYWALKING. IN RELATED
CITATIONS. WOULD BE TO MAKE THIS
CLEAR SACRAMENTO NEARLY 50% OF
JAYWALKING CITATIONS WERE GIVEN
TO BLACK PEOPLE EVEN THOUGH
BLACK PEOPLE ONLY MAKE UP ABOUT
20% OF THE POPULATION.
BAKERSFIELD 90% 90% OF
JAYWALKING CITATIONS WERE
DISTRIBUTED IN NEIGHBORHOODS.
THE MEDIAN INCOMES BELOW THIRTY
EIGHT THOUSAND DOLLARS. THERE'S
A HOMELESS PERSON I HAVE TALKED
THE IMPACT OF THE DISPARITIES IN
RECENT YEARS I'VE RECEIVED
FOURTEEN TRAFFIC INFRACTIONS IN
EACH CASE. I WAS A PEDESTRIAN.
THE GROUNDS FOR THE CITATIONS
ARE TRIVIAL THE CONSEQUENCES
WERE NOT. WAIT TO USE THE
COLLUDED A SINGLE TREE WALKING
CITATION CAN AMOUNT TO NEARLY
FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS. PLUS OF
THEIR OWN ADDRESS THEY CAN LEAD. TO LICENSE SUSPENSIONS. YOU
WALKING LAWS NEED TO BE. IN
THEIR FORM CAN SHIP REYES AND HE
- PEAK. AND MANY THE SKILLS. I
HEALTH STREET. YOU HAVE THE
POWER TO CHANGES. HERE YES ON A.
B. ONE SEVEN THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NOW WILL GO TO THE COLOR
STATE SHERIFFS SO. FOR TWO
MINUTES PLEASE. OPERATOR WE'RE
GETTING SOME KIND OF A FEED CAN
YOU MAKE SURE THAT YOUR MUTED.
BY LINE'S BEEN MUTED. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS WHO
SHALL MUTCHLER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION I RESPECTFULLY IN
OPPOSITION TO AB TWENTY ONE
FORTY SEVEN ALAS WE ARE WE
OPPOSED AB TWELVE THIRTY EIGHT
BECAUSE IT WOULD HAVE REMOVED
PREDICTABILITY AND CLARITY WHEN
IT COMES TO TRAFFIC SAFETY RULES
THAT HAVE BEEN ESTABLISHED FOR
PEDESTRIAN AND MOTORIST SAFETY.
ARE WE ARE CONCERNED AB TWENTY
ONE FORTY SEVEN WOULD HAVE A
SIMILAR PRACTICAL EFFECT- BY
SIGNIFICANTLY LIMITING WHEN A
PEACE OFFICER MAY STOP AT
PEDESTRIAN FOR A VIOLATION OF
ONE OF THE AFFECTED SAFETY LAWS.
LIMITING ENFORCEMENT OF
CALIFORNIA'S LAWS THAT ARE
DESIGNED TO AVOID TRAFFIC
COLLISIONS AND IMPROVE THE
SAFETY OF ALL WHO USE OUR
ROADWAYS WILL ONLY EXACERBATE
THE EXISTING PROBLEM FURTHER
ONLY PERMITTING ENFORCEMENT WHEN
A REASONABLY CAREFUL PERSON
WOULD REALIZE THERE IS AN
IMMEDIATE DANGER IGNORES THE
REALITY THAT OFTENTIMES
PEDESTRIANS AND MOTORISTS FAIL
TO RECOGNIZE THE PRESENCE OF
IMMEDIATE DANGER AND ARE ONLY
PROTECTED BUT HEARINGS TO CLEAR
LAWS UNDER A PRESUMPTION THAT
VIOLATIONS WILL BE SANCTIONED.
FOR THESE REASONS RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE THANK YOU. THANK YOU I
WAS THERE ANYONE IN THE ROOM
WISHING TO TESTIFY FOR OR
AGAINST. THE B. TWENTY ONE FORTY
SEVEN. HI DAN ALLISON A PERSON
WHO WALKS IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
I DON'T SEE ANYONE ELSE IN THE
HEARING ROOM OPERATOR CAN YOU
PLEASE OPEN UP THE PHONES FOR
TESTIMONY FOR OR AGAINST AB
TWENTY ONE FORTY SEVEN. TO SPEAK
AT THE END TESTIMONY FOR AGAINST
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME
. WILL FIRST GO TO LINE FOR
NINETY SIX GO AHEAD. HI THERE-
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
CRYSTAL I'M FROM THE LAWYERS
COMMITTEE FOR CIVIL RIGHTS O
THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA WERE
CO SPONSORS OF AB TWENTY ONE
FORTY SEVEN JUST ONE OF THE TOP.
PERFORMING ORGANIZATIONS AND
SUPPORT OF THE FREEDOM TO WALK
THAT WALK FACT YOU CAN SHOP THE
LIVING ST CALIFORNIA BY MENTAL
VOTERS. BURSTYN A BARBER COUNTY
BICYCLE COALITION AND COALITION
PERCENT OF DESPICABLE
TRANSPORTATION MARIN COUNTY
BICYCLE COALITION SANTA MONICA
SPOKE SANTA MONICA CA STREETS
LIVE TELEVISED INLAND EMPIRE BY
CANALYS LOS ANGELES COUNTY
MICHAEL COLLISION ALMOST DONE
STREETS FOR ALL. PLANNING AND
CONSERVING- CONSERVATION THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER AND PUBLIC. COUNCIL
CULTURE FOR YOUR SUPPORT THANK
YOU. LINE. FOR EIGHTY. NINE
FORTY FIVE GO AHEAD PLEASE. WILL
MOVE ON TO LINE TO NINETY SEVEN
. HELLO STEVE WELCOME BACK TO
CALGARY BICYCLE COALITION- IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY ONE FORTY
SEVEN THANK YOU. LINE. FOR FORTY
SEVEN. GOOD EVENING DANIEL BROWN
ON BEHALF OF SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT. LINE.
FIVE ZERO THREE. HELLO THIS IS
JOHN WITH THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TWO ONE.
LINE FIVE ZERO FOUR. HI THIS IS
BARBARA FISHER- FROM- BY CULVER
CITY CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT.
BLIND. ONE ELEVEN. VETERANS
PATROL IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
DECRIMINALIZATION OF WALKING.
NINE FIVE ZERO FIVE. HELLO
JOSHUA COOPER BURKE HOLLYWOOD
CALIFORNIA- IT IT VOICING STRONG
SUPPORT. EACH LINE FIVE ZERO
TWO. BY ROBERT GOULET WALKER IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THE LINE.
FIVE ZERO NINE. NINE FIVE ZERO
NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN GO AHEAD
PLEASE. YES GO AHEAD PLEASE.
EIGHT O'CLOCK. MADAM CHAIR WE
HAVE NO OTHER LINES INTO AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU WILL GO BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE DOES ANYONE HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. ALL
TO SAY THAT- I UNDERSTAND THAT.
THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE NERVOUS
ABOUT THIS BUT ALSO AS SOMEONE
WHO WALKS THERE ARE PLENTY OF
TIMES WHEN BECAUSE OUR ROADS ARE
OFTEN NOT DESIGNED OR ENGINEERED
FOR PEDESTRIANS IT'S VERY VERY
DIFFICULT. TO COMPLY WITH SOME
OF THE TRAFFIC RULES THERE BEEN
TIMES WHERE I'VE HAD TO WALK
SOMETIMES AND IF EVER IF I WAS
NOT GOING TO J. WALK. AFTER WALK
A HALF A MILE OUT OF MY WAY
BECAUSE THERE'S NO CROSS A LEGAL
CROSSWALKS FOR INSTANCE IN AN
AREA. THERE ARE TIMES WHEN I
WALK AROUND THIS CITY WERE I
FEEL UNSAFE STANDING ON A CORNER
AT NIGHT WHERE I FEEL A LOT
SAFER CROSSING WHEN I CAN SEE
FOR MILES AT THERE'S NO CARS
AROUND. BUT I'M A WOMAN WALKING
BY MYSELF IN DOWNTOWN SACRAMENTO
AND I'D RATHER JUST KEEP MOVING
SO THERE'S REALLY GOOD REASONS
WHY SOMETIMES PEDESTRIANS ARE
SAFER- BY USING THEIR COMMON
SENSE- ESPECIALLY WHEN THE
STREETS ARE NOT DESIGNED FOR
THEM SO WHEN WE GET TO THE POINT
WHERE WE DESIGN ALL OF OUR
STREETS FOR PEDESTRIANS AND HAVE
CONVENIENT SAFE CROSSWALKS
EVERYWHERE. AND LIGHTED AREAS
AND YOU KNOW THEN I THINK IT'S A
DIFFERENT STORY BUT RIGHT NOW WE
REALLY PENALIZE ARE PEDESTRIANS-
MANY MANY TIMES BY THE LACK OF
GOOD ENGINEERING FOR THEM AND WE
SHOULD ALLOW THEM TO USE THEIR
COMMON SENSE SO I REALLY.
SOMEONE WALKS A LOT I APPRECIATE
YOU BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD
AND I'LL BE SUPPORTING IT TODAY
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. I USE
THAT AS MY CLOTHES AND- JUST
RESPECT YES PROPER. THANK YOU
CLEAR ROLL CALL PLEASE. AB TWO
ONE FOUR SEVEN DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS FRIEDMAN. HI
FRIEDMAN IPHONE. FONG NO BERMAN
. CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM NOT
VOTING DALY AYE DAILY I DAVIES
DAVIES NO GIPSON. KALRA KALRA I
LI LI I BLEW BLOOM I DATE AND IS
THERE IN. NAZARIAN I WENT. WHEN
NO O'DONNELL WELL DONALD I WORK
. WICKS. SEVEN THREE. THANK YOU
THAT BILL IS OUT THE COMMANDER
THANK YOU WERE GOING TO MOVE ON
NOW TO ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
THREE EIGHTY EIGHT THE APPROVAL
YOU MAY COME AND- BEGIN WHEN
YOU'RE READY.
THANK. THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS
TODAY I'M PROUD TO PRESENT AB
TWENTY THREE EIGHTY EIGHT WHICH
AIMS TO INCREASE TRAFFIC SAFETY
TO OUR DRIVERS ACROSS CALIFORNIA
. YOU'RE SICK SECRETARY
TRANSPORTATION HEAT BOOK- JUDGE
BUT A JUDGE RELEASED A REPORT
THIS YEAR THAT REMAIN I DON'T
REMIND US OF A TRAGIC FACT. THAT
WE ALL KNOW TOO WELL. YOUNG NO
NO THIS DRIVERS SUFFER FROM THE
WORST RATE OF FATAL CAR CRASHES
COMPARED TO ANY OTHER GROUP.
INTO OFTEN THEY HAVE PASSENGERS
THAT DIAL LONG THEM ALONG THEIR
SIDE. FELLOW DRIVERS AND
PEDESTRIANS THAT ARE INJURED AND
KILLED ON THE OTHER END OF THE
CRASH SO AB TWENTY THREE ADA IS
ATTEMPTING TO ADDRESS TWO OF THE
MOST IMPORTANT FACTORS TO REDUCE
THE CATASTROPHIC CRASHES.
INCREASING TRAINING AND REDUCING
DISTRACTIONS. EVERY STATE IN THE
NATION HOUSE SOME OF SOME FORM
OF GRADUATED DRIVER'S LICENSE
PROGRAM OR GDL. IT'S BEEN KNOWN
THROUGH TO SUCCESSFUL REDUCE
FATAL CRASHES FOR. A NOTE NO
VOICE DRIVERS WHO ARE WHO ARE
LEARNING TO GET BEHIND THE WHEEL
FOR THE FIRST TIME.
UNFORTUNATELY OUR YOUNG ADULTS
ARE NOT REQUIRED TO GO THROUGH
THIS PROGRAM ONCE THEY TURN
EIGHTEEN. THIS IS BECOME A
LARGER PROBLEM DUE TO THE REPORT
BUT THE DMV THAT MORE AND MORE
TEENAGERS ARE WAITING UNTIL THEY
TURN EIGHTEEN BEFORE THEY GET
THEIR LICENSE. MAJORITY OF THOSE
WHO ARE WAITING. BUT WHO ARE
WAITING DO SO BECAUSE OF
FINANCIAL REASONS RELATED TO THE
COST OF DRIVING. WELL WE HELP
PEOPLE DEAL. HE DELAYING GETTING
THEIR DRIVER'S LICENSE. MORE
REPORTS ARE COMING OUT THAT
SHOWS THAT EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY
YEAR OLDS FIRST TIME DRIVERS ARE
4260% MORE LIKELY TO BE INVOLVED
IN A FATAL CRASH CAN COMPARE TO
THE SIXTEEN THE SEVENTY YEAR OLD
COUNTERPARTS. THIS IS A MAJOR
DEMONSTRATION OF THE COST OF
GETTING BEHIND THE WHEEL WITHOUT
RECEIVING THE BENEFITS OF IT OF
THIS GDL PROGRAM. EXPANDING THE
GDL PROGRAM TO EIGHTEEN TO
TWENTY YEAR OLDS. FIRST TIME
DRIVERS AS AB TWENTY THREE
EIGHTY EIGHT DOES IT IS
ESTIMATED TO SAVE HUNDREDS OF
YOUNG LIVES EVERY YEAR. HUNDREDS
OF LIVES EVERY YEAR AND MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS FOR OUR HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM. NEW JERSEY HAS ALREADY
MADE THIS CHANGE TO THEIR
PROGRAM AND HAVE SEEN AN INSTANT
BENEFIT. THIS HAS BEEN A LONG
STANDING UP OP OBJECTIVE OF THE
STATE'S STRATEGIC HIGHWAY SAFETY
PLAN. THAT IS SUPPORTED BY
GROUPS RANGING FROM TRAUMA
HOSPITAL. TRAFFIC SAFETY EXPERTS
INSURANCE GROUPS FIRST
RESPONDERS IN MANY OTHERS. THERE
HAS BEEN NO RE REPORTED
OPPOSITION OR NECESSARY
EXEMPTIONS ARE IN THE PLACE OF
THOSE WHO WERE WHO HAVE RECEIVED
COMMERCIAL LICENSE AND YOUNG
ADULTS WHO WERE DRIVING TO AND
FROM WORK IN ORDER SCHOOL. WITH
ME TO TESTIFY TODAY. IS PAT AT
PAINS AND PUT IT PRESIDENT THE
SAFE PRESIDENT OF SAFE MOVES THE
LARGEST TRAFFIC SAY PROGRAM FOR
SCHOOL KIDS SHE IS ALSO
PRESIDENT OF THE NOR ROSE HYNES
FOUNDATION NAMED IN HONOR OF HER
DAUGHTER WHO DIED IN EIGHTEEN
DRIVER- CRASH COLLISION
COLLISION. ALSO HERE IS EVETTE
CHINESE REPRESENTED IMPACT TEEN
DRIVERS A NATIONAL RENOWNED TEEN
AND YOUTH DRIVING SAFETY PROGRAM
WHO WILL ALSO SPEAK TO THE
IMPACT OF LOSING HER SISTER IN
EIGHTEEN INVOLVED CRASH. IN
NINETEEN INVOLVED CRASH BESIDES
ME IS STEVE BORROW STATE PROGRAM
DIRECTOR OF THE CIA COALITION OF
CHILDREN'S SAFETY AND HEALTH AND
A FORMER EMT PARAMEDIC WHO WILL
BE ABLE TO HELP ADDRESS SOME OF
THE QUESTIONS HERE. THANK YOU
WILL GO TO YOUR WITNESSES FOR UP
TO TWO MINUTES APIECE- THERE YOU
GO THANK YOU I LIKE TO START BY
THANKING THE AUTHORED FOR BEING
SO SUPPORTIVE AND INSTRUMENTAL
IN LEADERSHIP IN THIS LINE I
ALSO WANT TO THANK THE MEMBERS
IN THE CHAIR FOR HEARING OUR
STORIES. AND UNDERSTANDING WHERE
THIS ISSUE IS
ONLY TO MYSELF BUT PARENTS-
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA AS HE
MENTIONED- NOR WAS NINETEEN
YEARS OLD- WHEN SHE WAS HIT BY
ANOTHER NINETEEN YEAR OLD DRIVER
OF THE NINETEEN YEAR OLD DRIVER
WHO HIT NORA WAS TRAVELING IN
THE CAR WITH FOUR OTHER
TEENAGERS SHE WAS TRAVELING ON A
ROAD- THAT WAS POORLY DESIGNED
AND LOST CONTROL THE CAR AND T.
BONE MY DAUGHTER. AND SHE WAS
INSTANTLY KILLED UP NORA I JUST
WANT TO SPEND A MINUTE A TALK
ABOUT NORA NORA WAS ONE OF THOSE
KIDS WHO I WAS A GREAT
HUMANITARIAN SHE ON A DEVOTED
TIME AT TWELVE YEARS OLD WORKING
IN A ORPHANAGE IN GUATEMALA SHE-
EDUCATED KIDS AT MY NONPROFIT
WHICH I'VE BEEN DOING FOR FORTY
YEARS- TEACHING OTHER YOUNG
CHILDREN ABOUT THE DANGERS OF
CROSSING THE STREET HOPING THAT
THEY WOULD BECOME A BETTER TEAM
DRIVERS AND I HAVE TO SAY AFTER
NOR WAS KILLED AFTER FORTY YEARS
OF DURING TRAFFIC SAFETY. I DID
THOUGHT I WOULD TURN MY BACK ON
TRAFFIC SAY BECAUSE I THOUGHT
THAT WAS A CRUEL JOKE CLAMMY
AFTER FORTY YEARS OF MY LIFE
SAVING OTHER PEOPLE'S CHILDREN
THE LOSE MY BELOVED DAUGHTER HER
BROTHER WILL IS HER TWIN AND
HE'S NOW TAKEN UP THE MANTLE OF
TEACHING- DRIVER SAFETY TWO
TEAMS TO HIGH SCHOOLS OF THE
OTHER THING I WANTED TO MENTION
THAT NO WHAT NO PARENT CAN
IMAGINE THIS HAPPENING TO THEM
UNTIL IT HAPPENS TO YOU. AND I
SPENT MY LIFE SAVING OTHER
PEOPLE'S CHILDREN AND I SEE AB
TWENTY THREE EIGHTY EIGHT IS A
WAY THAT NORRIS DEATH CAN MEAN
SOMETHING TO OTHER PARENTS I
WOULDN'T WISH THIS ON ANYONE
FROM AND HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF YOUNG DRIVERS IN THE PAST YOU
WOULD BE GETTING THEIR LICENSE-
WHEN THEY'RE SIXTEEN ARE NOW
WAITING AND THEY HAVE NO
EDUCATION I DO WANT TO SAY THAT
THE YOUNG GIRL WHO. HIT I'VE
I'VE ACTUALLY INVOLVE TURN THE
FOUNDATION SHE ADMITTED THAT SHE
HAD NO DRIVER SAFETY EDUCATION
SHE GOT HER LICENSE AT EIGHTEEN
AND SHE STARTED DRIVING. SHE
REGRETS NOT HAVING THAT
EDUCATION SHOOT SOMETHING SHOW
LIVE WITH WITH THE REST OF HER
LIFE. BUT I THINK WITH THE
PASSING OF AB TWENTY THREE
EIGHTY EIGHT WE CAN REDUCING
INJURIES AND DEATH AMONG FIRST
TIME DRIVERS BY CLOSE TO FIFTY
FIVE PERCENT. I OFTEN THINK THAT
NORD BE ALIVE TODAY HAD THIS
LAW. PASSED WHEN SHE WAS ALIVE.
HELP ME ENSURE THAT NO OTHER
PARENT HAS TO GO THROUGH THE
PAIN AND SUFFERING THAT MY
FAMILY IS GOING THROUGH MANY
LOST NOR. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU THE NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. HELLO I'D LIKE
TO START BY THANKING THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OF THE UP WITH
THE LAST FOR WORKING WITH US
TODAY AND MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS FOR HEARING US AND OUR
STORIES TODAY. MY NAME IS A BIT
TRY THIS AND I'M AN ADVOCATE FOR
TEEN SAFE DRIVING BECAUSE MY
LITTLE SISTER IF SEE BECAME ONE
OF THE- YOUNG PEOPLE WE LOSE
ANNUALLY AND PREVENTABLE CAR
CRASHES. IN CALIFORNIA ALONE WE
COULD FILL EIGHT LARGE YELLOW
SCHOOL BUSES WITH THE AMOUNT OF
YOUNG PEOPLE WE LOSE ON
CALIFORNIA ROADWAYS. IT'S IT WAS
A FUN LOVING SEVENTEEN YEAR OLD-GIRL SHE WAS OUTGOING SHE LOVED
LIFE SHE WAS THE KIND OF PERSON
WHO HAD SUCH A LARGE PERSONALITY
THAT SHE WAS FRIENDS WITH
EVERYONE SHE MET- SHE WAS THE
KIND OF PERSON THAT. WOULD COME
AND TELL YOU A JOKE TO MAKE YOUR
DAY BETTER WHEN YOU'RE HAVING A
BAD DAY- IT'S C. WAS A TYPICAL
TEENAGER REALLY MUCH LIKE THE
TEAMS YOU HAVE IN YOUR LIFE- SHE
HAD GOALS AND DREAMS SHE WANTED
TO GRADUATE HIGH SCHOOL EARLY SO
SHE COULD GO INTO A MEDICAL
ASSISTING PROGRAM AFTER WHICH
SHE WANTED TO GO TO COLLEGE TO
BECOME A REGISTERED NURSE SHE
WANTED TO SAVE LIVES. JUST LIKE
TEENAGERS SHE MADE POOR CHOICE
OF. GOOD CHOICES AND POOR
CHOICES. UNFORTUNATELY SOME OF
THOSE CHOICES COST HER LIFE. ON
A LABOR DAY WEEKEND IT'S AND HER
FRIENDS CHOSE TO GO TO THE BEACH
AND ON THE WAY BACK. THEY WERE.
HAVING A GOOD TIME THEY WERE
SINGING AND DANCING THAT WAS PLAYING IN THE
CAR. DISTRACTING THE DRIVER THE
EIGHTEEN YEAR OLD. WHO WAS
DRIVING. AND- THEY WERE JUST
HAVING A GOOD TIME. WHILE THEIR
FRIENDS BUT ALONG THE HIGHWAY.
THE CHOICES MADE IN THAT CAR
THAT NIGHT ALONG WITH THE
DRIVERS IN EXPERIENCE LED TO A
SINGLE VEHICLE ROLLOVER IF HE
DIED AT THE SAME. AND THIS COULD
HAVE BEEN PREVENTED. WE LOSE.
NEARLY FOUR THOUSAND TEENS
ANNUALLY TO SOMETHING THAT IS
1100% PREVENTABLE AND NOVICE
DRIVERS THROUGH THE AGE TWENTY
YEARS OLD HAVE THE HIGHEST CRASH
RATES INVOLVING SERIOUS INJURIES
AND DEATHS OF OUT OF ANY AGE OF
DRIVERS ON THE ROAD CALIFORNIA'S
VDL PROGRAM WILL ENSURE YOUNG
DRIVERS. HAVE THE DRIVER
EDUCATION AND EXPERIENCE THEY
NEED TO DECREASE SPREADING RISKS
AND RISKS TO EVERYONE ELSE
SHARING THE ROAD WITH THEM.
CURRENTLY ONLY SIXTEEN AND
SEVENTEEN YEAR OLDS- MUST GO
THROUGH ART ST STUDIO PROGRAM
EVEN THOUGH EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
AND TWENTY YEAR OLD NOVICE
DRIVERS HAVE CRASHED RATES OVER
40% HIGHER THAN FIRST TIME
DRIVERS WHO HAVE BEEN THROUGH G.
B. L. PERHAPS IF THE EIGHTEEN
YEAR OLD DRIVER IN THE CRASH
THAT KILLED IF HE WOULD HAVE
GONE THROUGH THE GDL AND WASN'T
ALLOWED TO HAVE PASSENGERS IN
HER CAR MY SISTER WOULD STILL BE
HERE. IT IS TOO LATE FOR ITS IN
OUR FAMILY. BUT YOU CAN STILL
SAVE COUNTLESS LIVES BY
SUPPORTING AB TWENTY THREE
EIGHTY EIGHT. AND WHO KNOWS
MAYBE THE LIFE THAT YOU COULD BE
SAVING IS SOMEBODY THAT YOU LOVE
. THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND I WANT TO THANK BOTH OF YOU
FOR COMING IN PERSON AND SHARING
YOUR VERY POWERFUL STORIES WITH
US VERY VERY IMPACTFUL. I'M WE
DON'T HAVE ANY OPPOSITION ON
FILE SO I'M GONNA GO TO THE
COMMITTEE TO SEE IF ANYBODY HAS
ANY QUESTIONS. MISTER O'DONNELL
. A JUST A COMMENT- YOU SHOULD
THE AUTHOR BIG HEART THAT
PRESHEAF THE STORIES VERY MUCH
AS A HIGH SCHOOL TEACHER I'VE
SEEN TOO MUCH TRAGEDY WITH CARS
IN MY OWN FAMILY I'VE SEEN TOO
MUCH TRAGEDY WITH VEHICLES. THE
CHALLENGE I HAVE WITH THIS
APPROACH TODAY IS FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE. IS IT SOMEWHAT
UNFAIRLY TARGETS LOW INCOME
FOLKS. IN MY FAMILY WE HAVE THE
RESOURCES TO GET MY DAUGHTER
THROUGH DRIVER TRAINING WHEN SHE
WAS SIXTEEN AND GET OUR LICENSE.
AND SO. RISE TWICE WHERE I SEE
THE UNFAIR IMPACTS ARE ON THOSE
FAMILY THOSE PEOPLE. WHO DON'T
HAVE THE RESOURCES. TO GET THIS
TYPE OF TRAINING AT AN EARLY AGE
I MEAN WE CAN SEND PEOPLE OFF
THE WATER WE CAN'T LET THEM
DRIVE A CAR. I'M A LITTLE BIT
CHALLENGE WITH THAT TODAY. AN
OFFICIAL WANTED TO RESPOND TO
THAT OR NOT WHY DON'T WE WHY
DON'T WE WAIT TILL THE CLOSING
WILL WAIT UNTIL HIS CLIENT LET
HIM RESPOND THANK YOU. MR WARD.
IF THANK YOU FOR I BRING THIS
BILL FORWARD- THERE'S JUST A GUT
CHECK THAT JUST DOESN'T FEEL
RIGHT FOR ME- KNOWING THAT
EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY ONE YEAR OLDS
WHO HAVE MATURED BEYOND FIFTEEN
OR SIXTEEN OR SEVENTEEN- ARE NOW
ENTERING THE WORK FORCE HAVE I
KNOW YOU HAVE SOME EXEMPTIONS
BUILT IN HERE- BUT STILL HAVE TO
GO FOR SOME OF THE SAME
REQUIREMENTS AS WELL- AND I'M
WONDERING ARE THERE ANY OTHER
STATES THAT HAVE THIS LIMIT AS
WELL- FOR PDL UP TO TWENTY ONE.
IT WILL WILL HAVE TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE QUOTE OF THE
QUESTION I HAVE- BECAUSE IT'S
JUST IT IT DID FEELS LIKE
SOMETHING IS JUST A BIT A BIT
ASKEW HERE AND I'M- I'M I'M
WAITING ON THIS RIGHT NOW I
FULLY APPRECIATE AND UNDERSTAND-
AND YES I THINK. YOU KNOW
YOUNGER DRIVERS IN GENERAL- CAN-
POSE- MAYBE MORE IRRESPONSIBLE-
A DECISION MAKING IN THE SUMMERS
THAT WOULD THAT WOULD THAT
DECISION MAKING. NECESSARILY GET
BETTER- WITH THE MY REQUIREMENTS
OF GOING THROUGH- YOU KNOW THE
COURSE WORK AND A PERIOD OF
HAVING A PROVISIONAL DRIVER'S
LICENSE. I'M UNCLEAR. WHAT
PLANTS ARE LIKE YOU OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. OKAY I'M
FINE WITH YOU ASKING YOUR- YOUR
ADVISORS OR ANY OF YOUR SPONSORS
FOR ANY TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE IF
YOU WANT DURING YOUR CLOSING FOR
THESE QUESTIONS SO THE SPEECH
RIGHT HERE SIR. YEAH MY NAME IS
STEVE BARROW I'M THE STATE
PROGRAM DIRECTOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR
CHILDREN'S SAFETY AND HEALTH. I
WAS IN THE M. T. TWO PARAMEDIC
AND JUST FOR FULL DISCLOSURE I
SAID ON OUR STATE CMS COMMISSION
- THE TWO QUESTIONS THAT WERE
ASKED- NEW JERSEY HAS ENTERED IS
A VERY GOOD EXAMPLE OF A STATE
THAT HAS. MOVED ITS YEAH IT'S
GDL PROGRAM COMPONENTS UP.
THROUGH AGE TWENTY AND THEY'VE
HAD A REMARKABLE- READ REDUCTION
JUST LIKE THE RESEARCH SHOWS. IN
THE NUMBER OF FATAL CRASHES AS
WAS STATED. EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
AND TWENTY YEAR OLDS WITHOUT GDL
HAVE 4260% HIGHER. FATAL CRASH
RATES THAT'S PRETTY SIGNIFICANT
IN OUR STATE THAT TRANSLATES
INTO AN EXTRA FIVE HUNDRED-
YOUTH IN THE GROUND IN THE BOX.
AND SO IT IT DOES DOES MAKE
QUITE A BIT OF A DIFFERENCE. ON
THE OTHER ISSUE THAT THIS BILL
ADDRESSES IS THAT. WHEN I WAS
YOUNG. WE USED TO GET OUR
LICENSE WHEN WE WERE FIFTEEN
SIXTEEN YEARS OLD SEVENTEEN
YEARS OLD. 45% OF OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE DO NOT GET THEIR LICENSE
UNTIL EIGHTEEN NINETEEN AND
TWENTY. AND SO THERE THEY DON'T
GET THE BENEFIT OF ANY OF THE
TRAINING THE BILL DOES. TAKEN TO
A APPRECIATION THAT WE'RE
DEALING WITH YOUNG ADULTS
THEY'RE NO LONGER TEENAGERS ARE
MOVING INTO ADULTHOOD. SO THE
BURDEN OF PROVISIONAL LICENSE
PERIOD THE DRIVER EDUCATION
PERIOD EVERYTHING IS CONDENSED
THE OTHER THING THAT WE'VE
ADDRESSED- TO SPEAK TO. OUR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER O'DONNELL'S
ISSUE IS THAT- IS OUR LOW INCOME
THERE IS A PROVISION IN THIS
BILL THAT DOESN'T EXIST IN JUDY
ALL RIGHT NOW AND THAT SAYS IF
YOU'RE FROM A LOW INCOME. FAMILY
THIS IS A TWO HUNDRED DOLLAR
EFFORT TO GET THROUGH GDL ALL
LICENSE DRIVER EDUCATION SCHOOLS
IN CALIFORNIA UNDER THIS BILL
WOULD HAVE TO ALLOW YOU TO PAY
OVER TWELVE MONTHS NO FEES NO
INTEREST RATES. SO YOU CAN
SPREAD THAT OUT AND I WOULD ASK
YOU TO TAKE INTO CONSIDERATION.
IF YOU'RE GOING TO GET A LICENSE
. GETTING TRAINED TO BE A SAFER
DRIVERS NOT THE BIGGEST COST.
THE BIGGEST COST TO YOU IS GOING
TO BE OWNING A CAR PAY FOR GAS
PARKING INSURANCE. MAINTAINING
THAT PARK THIS IS A MICRO COSM
OF PRICE TO PAY ESPECIALLY WHEN
YOU THINK OF. THE EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN AND TWENTY YEAR OLDS
HAVE 4260% HIGHER FATAL CRASH
RATES WHEN THEY DON'T HAVE JUDY
ALL PROGRAM. SO I'M AND I'M
AVAILABLE TO ANSWER OTHER
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
PROGRAM THANK YOU I DON'T SEE
ANY OTHER. QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
SO WHAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
I WOULD I MEAN AS A FATHER OF
FOUR THREE MY DAUGHTERS ARE. BUT
I AND I LIKE THANK YOU GUYS FOR-
THE TESTIMONY NINE. TODAY AT. I
WOULD NEVER WANT TO BE IN THEIR
SHOES. BUT I STILL FEEL LIKE I'M
WHEN I'M WITH MY TWENTY ONE YEAR
OLD BY A NINETEEN YEAR OLD.
WELCOME STILL INSTRUCTOR I'VE
ALWAYS WANT TO KEEP TRYING TO
TEACH OF. BECAUSE YOU THINK THEY
KNOW AND THEN WHEN YOU'RE IN THE
CAR THEY HATE WHEN FATHERS IN
THERE BECAUSE I'M STILL TEACHING
UP TRIED TAP. I'M TRYING TO HELP
THEM. BUT. T. HERE THAT THE THAT
WE CAN LOWER THE PERCENTAGE RATE
HERE THAT WE CAN SAVE LIVES.
TODAY AND TO MAKE THAT CHANGE
OTHERS NOT JUST BECAUSE OTHER
STATES ARE SEEING OR DOING IT.
BUT WE CAN DO THAT. I MEAN I'VE
I'VE BEEN THERE IN THAT CAR TOO
MANY TIMES AND I HATE. IF I GET
A CALL IT'S ONE O'CLOCK IN THE
MORNING AND I'M GOING OH MY GOD
PLEASE. I HOPE IT'S NOTHING
NOTHING BAD AT THE TRAGIC. IT'S
USUALLY LIKE A I'M TRYING TO GET
INSIDE THE DOOR WHATEVER IT IS
RIGHT. SIDE LIKE I IN RELIEF. I
DON'T WANT TO SEE THE STORY
AGAIN WE DON'T WANNA SEE WE WANT
TO LOWER THAT NUMBER DOWN. AND
BY DOING THIS I GIVEN THE
TRAINING- WE WILL. SO WITH THAT-
VENTURE ASTRONAUT THANKS SO I
APPRECIATE THIS BILL AND THE
FACT THAT WE'VE SEEN A HUGE
INCREASE IN. OF SERIOUS INJURIES
AND DEATHS IN THE LAST COUPLE OF
YEARS IN A ROW SHOWS THAT WERE
IN THE MIDDLE OF A PUBLIC HEALTH
CRISIS. AND LIKE YOU SAID WE'VE
SEEN THESE EFFORTS- HE DIVIDENDS
AND OTHER STATES. I APPRECIATE
BRING THIS BEFORE AND I'LL BE
HAPPY TO SUPPORT OF TODAY. WE
HAVE A ROLL CALL PLEASE- I'M
SORRY DO WE HAVE A MOTION. WE
HAVE A MOTION IN MANY MANY
SECOND SO WE HAVE A ROLL CALL
PLEASE AB TWENTY THREE EIGHTY A
DO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
FRIEDMAN AYE FRIEDMA AYE FONG.
FONG NOT BOOTING. BERMAN
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM AYE DALY
AYE DALY AYE DAVIES DAVIES I
GIPSON. KALRA KALRA I LEE. LEARN. HELLO I THIS AREA. THIS AREA I
WENT. WHEN NOT VOTING O'DONNELL
O'DONNELL NOT VOTING. FORD WARD
I WICKS. EIGHT ZERO IT'S YOUR
THE BILL IS OUT WILL LEAVE THE
ROLE OPEN AND NOW I'M GOING TO
BE PRESENTING MY BILLS BECAUSE
WE SAVE THE BEST FOR LAST. AND
MR FONG WILL BE CHAIRING. THANK
YOU BETTER CHAIR. WE WILL NOW
MOVE TO FILE ITEM ELEVEN. A TEN
THEN AB TWENTY THREE THIRTY SIX. FILE A PLEASE PROCEED WHEN
YOU'RE READY. WITH AB NINETEEN
OH NINE STRUCTURE. ARE MOVING TO
TWENTY AB TWENTY THREE THIRTY
SIX FILE ITEM ELEVEN. EACH YEAR. THANK YOU MEMBERS I'LL MOVE
APPROVAL. THANKS WE HAVE A
MOTION AND OPEN MY SAYING I'M I
CAN AUTO DIAL HERE. IT'S A LONG
DAY- IT'S WHICH STARTED IN A
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT CITY- SO.
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN I
CARRIED TWENTY THREE SIXTY
THREE ZERO TRAFFIC FATALITIES
TASK FORCE WHICH ASK HOSTED TO
COME UP WITH RECOMMENDATIONS ON
HOW TO SLOW DRIVERS DOWN ONE OF
THOSE BILLS PASSED LAST YEAR AB
FORTY THREE WHICH I THINK MOST
OF YOU IF NOT ALL OF YOU VOTED
FOR. ABOUT GIVING CITIES
FLEXIBILITY TO SET SPEED LIMITS
AND THIS IS THE COMPANION PIECE
TO THIS WHICH HAS TO DO WITH HOW
TO ALLOW OUR CITIES TO HAVE MORE
FLEXIBILITY IN HOW THEY ENFORCE
OUR SPEED LIMITS WHAT THIS BILL
DOES IS WITH A PILOT PROGRAM IN
A SMALL NUMBER OF CITIES IT
WOULD ALLOW FOR CAMERAS IN. IN
CERTAIN LOCATIONS BEING IN HIGH
INJURY NETWORKS OR WHERE THERE
IS VULNERABLE POPULATIONS TO
ENFORCE SPEED LIMITS USING SPEED
CAMERAS NOW THERE ARE MULTIPLE
SAFEGUARDS EMBEDDED IN THIS BILL
FOR INSTANCE YOU HAVE TO BE
GOING AT LEAST ELEVEN MILES AN
HOUR OVER THE SPEED LIMIT
BECAUSE WE'RE LOOKING FOR THE
MORE EGREGIOUS DRIVERS. THE
MONEY THAT'S GENERATED IN FINES
HAS TO GO RIGHT BACK INTO THAT
VERY SAME COMMUNITY FOR PHYSICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE TO MAKE THOSE
ROADS SAFER SO IT GENERATES
REVENUE NOT FOR GENERAL FUND NOT
NIPPED UNITIVE WAY BUT TO
ACTUALLY DO IMPROVEMENTS ON
THOSE DANGEROUS ROADS. THE
TICKETS ARE IN THE BEGINNING OF
THE OF WHEN THE CAMERAS ARE
DEPLOYED OR WARNINGS TO PEOPLE
AND THEN WHEN WE START TO GIVE
THEM THEIR FIFTY DOLLAR TICKET
THEY STARTED FIFTY DOLLARS
COMPARE THAT TO A REGULAR SPEED
LIMIT THAT'S REGULAR SPEED
TICKET GIVEN BY AN OFFICER WHICH
CAN BE HUNDREDS OF DOLLARS. THE
TICKET GOES TO THE CAR KIND OF
LIKE A PARKING TICKET SO IT
THERE'S NO POINT IN ANYONE'S
LICENSE- BUT IT DOES NOTIFY
PARENTS THAT THEIR CHILDREN MAY
BE ARE EGREGIOUSLY SPEEDING OR
RECKLESSLY DRIVING WHEN THEY
MIGHT NOT OTHERWISE KNOW SO WE
HAVE TRIED TO BUILD EQUITY AND
SAFEGUARDS AND GUARD RAILS INTO
THIS PROGRAM I NEVER REALLY DONE
THIS AND ALSO THE CITIES HAVE TO
WARN PEOPLE WHEN THEY'RE COMING
INTO HIS OWN OR THE SPEED
CAMERAS ARE BEING USED. BECAUSE
OUR INTENTION IS TO TAKE THE
MOST DANGEROUS STREETS IN A
COMMUNITY AND SLOW PEOPLE DOWN
IT'S NOT TO PUNITIVE REALLY MOVE
AROUND THE CITY AND GET TICKETS
OUT. IT'S TO ACTUALLY IMPROVE ON
THE SAFETY OF THOSE ROADS AGAIN
THIS IS A PILOT PROGRAM TO
COLLECT DATA ON IT. WE KNOW IN
OTHER CITIES WHEN THIS HAS BEEN
USED IN OTHER STATES THAT IT HAS
SIGNIFICANTLY DECREASED. THE
NUMBER OF DRIVERS THAT ARE
RECKLESSLY DRIVING AND SPEEDING.
IT'S PERFECT TO USE IN AREAS
WHERE WE HAVE STREET RACING WE
ALL KNOW THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT IS
GOOD AS THEY ARE CAN'T BE
EVERYWHERE AT ONCE. AND IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT THAT WE GIVE
COMMUNITIES THE TOOLS THAT THEY
NEED TO ENFORCE OUR LAWS. THIS
IS DONE IN A NON PUNITIVE WAY I
THINK IT'S SENSIBLE WE'VE BEEN
LISTENING TO ALL OF THE
STAKEHOLDERS AND WE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THOSE. WHO
HAVE RESERVATIONS ABOUT THE
PROGRAM- BUT WE DO HAVE
WITNESSES. YOU'RE IN TODAY- WITH
US FIRST WE HAVE MAYOR SAM LOOK-
LICCARDO FROM SAN JOSE. AND THEN
DOCTOR REBECCA PLEVEN WHO'S A
TRAUMA AND SURGICAL CARE- CARE
DOCTOR AT ZUCKERBERG SAN
FRANCISCO GENERAL HOSPITAL.
THANK YOU JEFFREY AND WE WILL
STAR IN THAT ORDER WILL GO TO
YOU- AT. THE SATURDAY MAYOR AND
THEN WILL PROCEED TO DR ELEVEN.
OPERATOR THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ARE YOU ABLE TO HEAR ME. YES.
I'M SORRY BY HERE FONG ARE YOU
ABLE TO HEAR ME A YES PLEASE
PROCEED. WELL GREAT THANK YOU
FOR GIVING- BUT SURE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY ON BEHALF OF THE
MORE THAN ONE MILLION SANDERS
ANSWERED SERVICE MAYOR. I WANT
TO THANK CHAIRPERSON FRIEDMAN
FOR HER LEADERSHIP IN OFFERING
AB TWENTY THREE THIRTY SIX TO
ALLOW CALIFORNIA CITIES TO PILOT
AUTOMATED SPEED ENFORCEMENT TO
ENHANCE SAFETY ON OUR ROADS. IN
MY CITY SAN JOSE AS IN CITIES
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA WE SEEN
HORRIFIC INCREASE IN AUTO
RELATED DEATHS. AND WE KNOW FROM
OUR DATA 30% OF THOSE AUTO
FATALITIES. SPEEDING POLICY KEY
PARTS OF THAT COLLISION
AUTOMATED SPEED ENFORCEMENT
CLEARLY WORKS A TWENTY SEVENTEEN
TO STUDY FOR THE NATIONAL
TRANSPORTATION SAFETY BOARD
CONFIRMED WHAT SEVERAL U. S.
CITIES HAVE ALREADY FOUND WITH
AUTOMATED SPEED ENFORCEMENT
REDUCING TRAFFIC FATALITIES. BY
BETWEEN FORTY SIX AND 71% CITIES
LIKE PORTLAND NEW YORK
WASHINGTON DC. CALIFORNIA LAW
PROHIBITS CITIES FROM USING THIS
TOOL TO MAKE OUR ROADS SAFER
HOWEVER. YET 62% ASSEMBLY AND
SURVEYED BY EMC RESEARCH LAST
MONTH STATED DAY QUOTES SUPPORT
THE USE OF SPEED CAMERAS. TO
IMPROVE STATE STREET SAFETY.
SUPPORTED EVEN HIGHER AMONG OUR
LATINO MEDINA RESIDENTS BECAUSE
HALF PERCENTAGE TRAFFIC DEATHS
AND SERIOUS INJURIES OCCUR ON
ONLY 3% OF OUR STREETS
OVERWHELMINGLY LOCATED AMONG THE
MOST DIVERSE NEIGHBORHOODS IN
EAST AND CENTRAL SATURDAY. SO TO
IN OUR NEIGHBORING CITIES WERE
BLACK OAK WONDERS ARE TWICE AS
LIKELY TO BE KILLED OR SEVERELY
INJURED IN A TRAFFIC CRASH. AS
OF THE RESIDENTS AND 60% OF
TRAFFIC TAX AND SHIPPING CHOOSE
GO OCCURRED IN NEIGHBORHOODS AND
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR WITH THE
CITY'S LOWEST INCOMES. WE
APPLAUD THE AUTHOR STAFFERS TO
ADDRESS EQUITY CONCERNS IN AB
TWENTY THREE THIRTY SIX BY
REDUCING FIND IMPLEMENTING
DIVERSION PROGRAMS FOR LOW
INCOME VIOLATORS. AND PROTECTING
PRIVACY TO STRICT LIMITS ON
STORAGE AND USE OF THIS DATA.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF
THIS CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
LEGISLATION FOR THE CITY'S URBAN
COMMUNITIES LIKE MINE THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. WITH PARTICULAR
ATTENTION LEADERSHIP IN SUPPORT
OF TWO MEMBERS OF OUR LOCAL
DELEGATION ASSEMBLYMEMBERS.
KALRA KILEY THANK YOU. I THINK
YOU MAY ONE GO TO DOCTOR LEVIN.
PLEASE PROCEED. ELEVEN THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS
THE COMMITTEE AND I'M DOCTOR
REBEKAH PLAN AND THEN I MET
TRAUMA SURGEON AND YOU POSITION
AT THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
SAN FRANCISCO AND BAKER BURKE
SAN FRANCISCO GENERAL HOSPITAL.
AND I'M HERE TONIGHT IN MY
INDIVIDUAL CAPACITY NOT AS A
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA OR TO BE A TOUCHY.
EVERY YEAR OVER FOUR HUNDRED SAN
FRANCISCANS ARE STRUCK BY A CAR
WHILE WALKING. CYCLING OR RIDING
A TRANSPORTATION DEVICE. AND
THAT MEANS THAT EVERY DAY THE
TRAUMA SURGERY TEAM AT SAN
FRANCISCO GENERAL CARES FOR A
PEDESTRIAN OR A CYCLIST WHO WAS
HIT BY A CAR. FOR ME AND FOR MY
TEAM THE IMPACT OF TRAFFIC
VIOLENCE IS A REALITY THAT WE
ENCOUNTER EVERY SINGLE DAY AT
WORK. WE KNOW THAT HOW FAST OUR
CARS TRAVELING MATTERS. SPEED
AFFECT WHETHER THE VICTIM OF THE
COLLISION LIVES OR DIES WHETHER
THEIR INJURIES ARE DEVASTATING
OR RELATIVELY LIFESTYLE. AND I
DON'T MEAN TO MINIMIZE THE
IMPACT OF EVERY TRAFFIC
COLLISION BECAUSE EACH ONE IS A
TRAGEDY BUT AS A TRAUMA SURGEON
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN TWENTY
AND THIRTY OR FORTY MILES PER
HOUR CAN BE THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN LIFE AND DEATH OR THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN. BROKEN BONES
AND THE DEVASTATING BRAIN INJURY
OR INTERNAL BLEEDING. FOR
PATIENTS WHO DO SURVIVE THEIR
INJURIES MANY FACE A LONG
RECOVERY AND SOME NEVER RETURNED
TO THEIR PREVIOUS LEVEL AND HOW.
THIS REALITY IS CATASTROPHIC NOT
JUST MY PATIENTS BUT ALSO TO
THEIR FAMILIES FRIENDS AND
COMMUNITIES. AS MENTIONED WE
ALSO KNOW THAT TRAFFIC INJURIES
ARE AN ISSUE OF EQUITY SAN
FRANCISCO WE'VE IDENTIFIED THE
12% OF THE STREETS WERE OVER 70%
OF SEVERE AND FATAL TRAFFIC
COLLISIONS OCCUR. THE CARD I
JUST MENTIONED OVER HALF THE
STREETS RUNNING THROUGH
NEIGHBORHOODS THAT ARE INHABITED
BY SENIORS LOW INCOME RESIDENTS
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AND PEOPLE
WHO RELY ON THE WLKING AND
PUBLIC TRANSIT AS THEIR PRIMARY
MEANS OF TRANSPORTATION.
INCREASING DRIVER SPEED IN THESE
COMMUNITIES OF CRITICAL TO
PROTECTING SOME OF OUR MOST
VULNERABLE CITIZENS. I'M HERE
TONIGHT BECAUSE OF THE TRAUMA
SURGEON I DON'T WANT TO CARE FOR
VICTIMS OF TRAFFIC VIOLENCE. I
WANT ALL CALIFORNIANS TO BE ABLE
TO SAFELY MOVE AROUND THEIR
CITIES TEND TO ENJOY HE HELP
AND COMMUNITY BENEFITS. OF
WALKING AND CYCLING WITHOUT FEAR
OF INJURY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WILL NOW PROCEED
OPPOSITION. WE HAVE THE ACLU-
BAKER CREAM A MOTOR MOTOR
APOLOGIZE FOR THAT- WILL GO
TERRY THE ACO FIRSTAND THEN
WE'LL GO TO THE ELECTRONIC
FRONTIER FOUNDATION. CATALINA
SANCHEZ. SO IF WE CAN FIND BECCA
MAY PROCEED READY BACK IN MY
MATTER ON BEHALF OF ACLU
CALIFORNIA AND ACTUAL
OPPOSITION. THERE ARE OTHER
MEANS OF REDUCING DEBATE.
ALEXANDER BUT DO NOT IMPLICATE
PRIVACY IN EQUITY INCLUDING.
THOSE HIGHLIGHTED IN THE BILL
ITSELF. YOU KNOW TO BE PAID
TOPICS ARE AND TRAFFIC CALMING
MEASURE. YET MANAGEMENT CENTER
THE THEY'RE CHRISTIAN THE BILL
INSTEAD RELIES ON SURVEILLANCE
THE AUTOMATED ENFORCEMENT AND
INCREASED TICKETING. DR AFTER
GETTING PRIVACY I COULD BECAUSE
I ONE BUT THERE'S ANOTHER. HARD
OF PROVIDING MEANINGFUL ACTION.
WE RECOGNIZE THAT THESE TRAFFIC
CALMING MEASURES I DID MENTION
TO COST THE MONEY HOWEVER AB.
TWENTY THREE THIRTY SIX ALTHOUGH
HAVE CAUGHT. GOOD EVENING YOU
CAN PAYMENT HAVE ABOUT AB TWENTY
THIRTY HAMPERS THE BURDEN
HONORABLE HELD. FOR EXAMPLE THE
DRAMATIC INCREASE IN TICKETING
THAT AB TWENTY THREE THIRTY
THAT. WOULD GO AGAINST THE
RECENT REFORMS THE CALIFORNIA
PICKETING MARC TO REDUCE THE
WELL DOCUMENTED ECONOMIC HARM
CARBON AFTER GETTING A TICKET
EARLY FOR COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
WOMEN OF COLOR PARTICULARLY
BLACK IN MY NEXT WOMEN ARE
ESPECIALLY LIKE YOU CAN STOP. AB
TWENTY THREE THIRTY SIX WE HAVE
MADE AND THE BATTLEGROUND OF THE
CONFLICT I TEACH AND- I LOVE THE
WEATHER NANKERVIS IDEATION.
WHILE THE BILL INCLUDES SOME
EQUITY PROVISION THEY'RE
OUTWEIGHED BY THE DUE PROCESS
PROBLEMS AND I THINK PROTECTION.
FOR EXAMPLE DESPITE REQUIRING
TICKET BE PAID OR ACTED WITHIN
THIRTY DAYS OF MAILING A NOTICE
OF VIOLATION. THE BILL HAS NOT
REQUIRED BUT I THINK IT WAS VERY
CLEAN AND LACKED ANY ALLOWANCE.
FOR EXTENSIONS OF TIME. THERE
ANY WHO MAY THE DEATH OR NOT
HAVE A RESOURCE TO PAY THE FINE
WILL NOT BE ABLE REGISTER
VEHICLE. DRIVERS WHO NEED TO USE
VEHICLE GET TO WORK PROPERLY
OFFICE SCHOOL FOR OTHER LET ME.
WILL CONTINUE DO SO REGARD OF MY
TO. BECAUSE THEY TO YOU THEM.
BUT THEN PULLED BACK DOWN MARKET
AND AGAIN. DOWN LEGAL ACTION
SPIRAL. ANOTHER HE SHALL YIELD
CALLING FOR ACTUALLY IN THE
NORTH OPPOSITION YEAH. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WILL NOW TO THE
CHRONIC FROM FOUNDER. THE
PROCEED. SHE REMEMBERED CATALINA
SANCHEZ CORBIN KINDER AM REFER A
FRIENDSHIP A WITH INTERSECT BOB
TO AND IF I MADE A QUICKLY ALSO
ADD NEED TO ON BEHALF OF PRIVACY
RIGHTS CLEARINGHOUSE WELL WE
APPRECIATE EFFORTS TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THE PRIVACY CONCERNS
WITH THE SURVEILLANCE TECHNOLOGY
IN AB TWO THREE THREE SIX THE
BILL DOES NOT ADEQUATELY PROTECT
PRIVACY IN ORDER TO TRACK THE
APPROPRIATE BALANCE BETWEEN
PERSONAL PRIVACY AND GOVERNMENT
TRANSPARENCY SURVEILLANCE DATA
LIKE THAT WHICH WOULD BE
COLLECTED UNDER AB TWO THREE
THREE SIX INCLUDE A LOT OF
PERSONAL DATA THAT IS INCREDIBLY
SPECIFIC ABOUT EACH INDIVIDUAL.
YET AB TWO THREE THREE SIX
LEADERS ACCOUNTABLE COMMUNITIES
UP TO THE MERCY OF LOCAL
MUNICIPALITIES TO DRAFT AND
COMPLY WITH PRIVACY
CONFIDENTIALITY REQUIREMENTS
THAT WOULD PROTECT DATA FROM
UNAUTHORIZED ACCESS AND THIRD
PARTY DATA SHARING RATHER THAN
PROVIDING STRONG PRIVACY
PROTECTION- CONDITIONALLY DOES
BELIEVE IT UP TO THE CITY TO
DETERMINE FOR THEMSELVES THE
CRITERIA UNDER WHICH THE
PROGRAMS ARE BEING PICKED UP
WELL THE FOLLOWING STATEMENT
JUSTIFY CONTINUED USE OF
DOWNTURN- BASED ON WHATEVER
BENCHMARK THAT THE PARTS THEIR
CONTINUED USE OF THE SYSTEM.
ALTHOUGH SURVEILLANCE CAN ALSO
BE EASILY MISUSE CAN LEAD TO THE
EROSION OF COMMUNITY TRUST AND
COSTLY LAWSUITS AS WELL AS
DISCOURAGING PEOPLE FROM GOING
ABOUT THEIR DAILY LIVES AND I'M
THINKING THERE'S AND LIBERTIES
MORE AND MORE BECAUSE I NAY LPR
INFORMATION COULD BE SHARED WITH
OTHER DOES REQUIRED BY STATE LAW
SHOULD EIGHTY TWO THREE THREE
SIX AND AB TWENTY ONE NINETY TWO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER I'M RAMOS. BOTH
BECOME LAW AB TWO THREE THREE
SIX COULD ALLOW FOR SETTING UP
OF A SPEED TRAP OUTSIDE OF THE
SCHOOL SURE IN THE LICENSE PLATE
DATA WHAT I FOR EXAMPLE OR
SETTING UP WITH THE TOP OUTSIDE
ABORTION CLINIC OR GENDER FOR ME
CLEAR CONNECT AND IT'S AGAIN
SHARING THE L. CONFIRMATION WITH
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND OTHER STATE
THEY'RE CRIMINALIZING- COMING TO
CALIFORNIA FOR THE SERVICE THAT.
THEIR ALTERNATIVE METHODS FOR
REDUCING SPEED RELATED TRAFFIC
COLLISIONS THAT DO NOT RAISE THE
PRIVACY CONCERNS INHERENT
INCREASING USE OF SURVEILLANCE
TECHNOLOGY BUT THE LEGISLATURE
SHOULD PURSUE. THOSE INSTEAD
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY. WE
WILL NOW GO TO- TESTIMONY- IN
SUPPORT. OF BILL AND THE CHAMBER
OR NOT. AND COMMITTEE- PLEASE.
DAN ALISON INSTEAD. MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS JOSHUA SHOP FOR SAN
FRANCISCO MAYOR LONDON BREED WHO
STRONGLY SUPPORT AND IS TRYING
TO WORK TO REDUCE THE ACTUAL
INCIDENCES OF DEATH AND SEVERE
INJURY FOR THE BLACK AND BROWN
WOMEN AND MEN IN HER COMMUNITY
AND OTHERS WHO ARE KILLED BY
SPEEDING. THANK YOU AND URGE
YOUR SUPPORT. MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS ANDREW ANTS WE ON BEHALF
OF THE CITY OF BEVERLY HILLS IN
SUPPORT AND IF THE OPPORTUNITY
PRESENTED ITSELF. BEVERLY HILLS
WILL BE HONORED TO BE INCLUDED
IN THIS MEASURE. I THANK YOU
MUCH WILL GO IN PERSON- ANYONE
AND THAT WANTS TO SPEAK AN OPETH
OR DOES THE- AND OPPOSE THIS
BILL PLEASE COME FORWARD. BEFORE
WE GO TO THE PHONE LINES. C.
NONE OF. WILL GO TO THE PHONES.
IF YOU ARE. OPPOSE OR SUPPORT
PLEASE- QUEUE UP AND- THE
OPERATOR PLEASE PROCEED. YES IF
YOU ARE SPEAK INSPIRA POSITION
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO WILL GO TO
FIRST TO LINE TO NINETY SEVEN GO
AHEAD- GETTING EXISTING BALK ON
THE OF THE CALGARY BY SOME
COALITION SUPPORT. IN ADDITION
TO IBM IN CHARACTER EDUCATION
COMMISSION ALSO SUPPORTS A BILL
AND FUTURE MOMENTS TO EXPAND A
PILOT PROGRAM TO INCLUDE. ANY
JURISDICTION IN ALAMEDA COUNTY-
REPORT YOUR SUPPORT FOR THE BILL
THANKS. LINE. FIVE HUNDRED.
JERRY MEMBERS SYLVIA TILLY
SHOPPING AFTER THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
THREE THREE SIX THE CITY CAUGHT
TWO HUNDRED AND EIGHTY NINE
PEOPLE KILLED IN ALMOST FIFTEEN
HUNDRED PERSON SEVERELY INJURED
IN TRAFFIC CRASHES INCLUDING
FOUR HUNDRED AND EIGHTY SIX
PEDESTRIANS THIS BILL WILL
PROVIDE A MUCH NEEDED TOOL TO
REDUCE THESE TRAFFIC RELATED
DEATHS AND INJURIES ON OUR CITY
STREETS. THANK YOU. NINE FIVE
TWENTY THREE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN VERSUS IS ROUGH BUCKLEY
ON BEHALF OF SANTA CLARA VALLEY
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY IN
SUPPORT. NINE FIVE TWENTY. NINE
FIVE TWENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN GO
AHEAD PLEASE. HEARING NOTHING
WILL MOVE ON TO LIVE LINE. FIVE
TWENTY EIGHT. HI THERE THIS IS A
PUBLIC FISH FROM- BY CULVER CITY
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORTED THIS
MEASURE IN THIS PILOT PROGRAM.
THANK YOU. LINE FIVE TWENTY FIVE
. HI MY NAME IS MICHAEL J.
INTIMIDATED PATTERSON THANK THE
DISCO AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL
AND ALSO TO PUT SUPPORT
AMENDMENTS TO FURTHER SATISFY
THE ELECTRONIC FRONTIER
FOUNDATION'S CONCERNS THANK YOU
. NINE FIVE THIRTY. HI MY NAME
IS ENSURING A QUESTION BY REMOTE
MEMORY WALK THEM THIS CALL AT
THE PORT AB TWO THREE THREE SIX
THANK YOU. LINE. FOR NINETY
FOUR. THE V. THIRTY MINISTER AND
MEMBERS ROSANNA CARPACCIO LEN ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF ALAMEDA
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU. LINE.
FIVE TWENTY SEVEN. HELLO MY NAME
IS JEANETTE LEBLANC I AM A
MEMBER OF SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA
FAMILIES FOR SAFE STREETS I LOST
MY SON TO A PEDESTRIAN CRASHES
SPEEDING DRIVER AND I SUPPORT A.
B. TWO THREE THREE SIX. NINE
FIVE THIRTY FIVE. NINE FIVE
THIRTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN GO
AHEAD. WILL MOVE ON TO LINE. FOR
TWENTY SIX. TRANSACTION ON
BEHALF OF THE TEAMSTERS MONOGAMY
TRANSIT UNION IN OPPOSITION.
LINE. ONE ELEVEN. MARC RICH ON
BEHALF OF STREETS FOR ALL
SUPPORTING THE BILL. SCHLEIN.
FIVE FIFTEEN. GOOD EVENING MR
COLOR WALKING IN CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION OF BAY
AREA GOVERNMENTS AS WELL AS THE
METROPOLITAN TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION EXPRESSING OUR STRONG
SUPPORT FOR ASSEMBLY BILL TWO
THREE THREE SIX THANK YOU. LINE. FOR FIFTY SIX. HELLO MY NAME
IS SETTLED BERMAN NUMBER OF
STUDENTS GO BAY AREA FANTASY
STREET FROM ACROSS TO ADDRESS
TRAFFIC FROM SAN FRANCISCO I
SUPPORT A. B. TWO THREE EIGHT
THREE SIX. LINE FOR NINETY THREE. NINE FOUR NINETY THREE PLEASE
PICK UP YOUR HANDSET OR CHECKING
ME TEACHER. LINE. FIVE THIRTY
TWO. NINE FIVE THIRTY TO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. LINE. ONE FORTY- THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO SEE MY
NAME IS- JAMES JONES PHD I'M A
MEMBER OF THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY
AREA FAMILIES FOR SAFE STREETS
AND THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA- BOB
DONNAN FOR SAFE STREETS I'M A
CRASH SURVIVOR AND I SUPPORT A.
B. TWENTY THREE THIRTY SIX.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. LINE FIVE
TWENTY FOUR. H. HELLO MY NAME IS
STRUCTURE COOPER FROM NORTH
HOLLYWOOD- AS A PSYCHOLOGY
PROFESSOR IN I AM STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT. LINE. FIVE THIRTY
EIGHT. MY NAME IS ALLEY
GALLAGHER I'M WITH SAN FRANCISCO
BAY AREA FAMILIES FOR STATE
STREET AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT AB
TWO THREE THREE SIX THANK YOU.
NINE FIVE TWENTY SIX. HELLO MY
NAME IS LAURIE MARKOWITZ AND I'M
A MEMBER OF FAMILIES FOR SAFE
STREETS I LOST MY SON TO A CRASH
AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT A. B. TWO
THREE THREE SIX THANK YOU. NINE
FIVE THIRTY NINE. HELLO MY NAME
IS JULIE MITCHELL I'M A MEMBER
OF THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA
FAMILIES FOR SAFE STREETS I LOVE
MY SON DYLAN TO THE CRASH AND I
SUPPORT AB. TWO THREE THREE SIX.
NINE FIVE TWELVE. GOOD EVENING
TURN MEMBERS EARLY SHALL BE ON
BEHALF OF OAKLAND MAYOR LIBBY
SCHAAF ASSEMBLY DON'T TWENTY
THREE THIRTY SIX THANK YOU.
QUESTIONABLE YEAH L. FIVE TWENTY
GO AHEAD PLEASE. STE STE STE STE. K. FINE FIVE TWENTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS JUDY
MCPHERSON IN THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF WHAT KAREN SISCO AND
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT EACH YEAR
THREE THREE SIX. OPERATORS. NINE
FIVE THIRTY TWO. I OKAY ALAMEDA
CITY COUNCIL MEMBER JOHN KNOX
WHITE FALLING IN THE SPORT AB.
MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE NOWHERE
ELSE IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME. OKAY
BUT I. RIGHT WITHOUT. NEXT CALL
. YEAH NINE FOUR ZERO THREE IS
IN Q. YES MY NAME IS JOHN MOLE I
AM A SURVIVOR OF A COLLISION IN
SAN FRANCISCO A DRIVER WHO WAS
SPEEDING. I A AND SENIOR MEMBER
OF SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA
FAMILIES FOR SAFE STREETS AND I
STRONGLY ENCOURAGE YOU TO
SUPPORT ASSEMBLY BILL. TWO THREE
THREE SIX. LINE FOR FIFTY SIX.
HELLO MY NAME SAID ALTHOUGH I'LL
REMEMBER OF SAN FRANCISCO BAY
AREA FAMILYSEARCH THE STREET ON
THE CRASH SURVIVOR OF TRAFFIC
VIOLENCE INSTANCES GOVERNMENT
SUPPORT AB. TWO THREE THREE SIX.
MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE NO OTHER
LINES INTO AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU OPERATOR WILL TAKE EVASIVE
COMMITTEE ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. A MISTER
WARD. I WANT TO THANK HEARING
FOR THIS BILL- VERY SUPPORTIVE
OF THESE AT- TECHNOLOGY
TECHNOLOGICAL MEASURES I'M TO BE
ABLE TO. HAVE THE INTENDED
EFFECT YOU'RE YOU'RE YOU'RE
SEEKING HERE- AND I JUST WANT TO
ENCOURAGE AS IT MOVES FORWARD-
IN MY CITY WE HAD AUTOMATED RED
LIGHT CAMERAS- THAT WENT
HORRIBLY WRONG AND ABSOLUTELY
DESTROYED PUBLIC TRUST IN THESE-
THERE WERE. CONTRACTS THAT FAVOR
DE UM CAN'T BE- THE OWNERS OF
THE SYSTEMS- THAT- ACTUALLY HAD
MIS CALIBRATION WHERE THEY WERE
GOING OFF MAYBE A HALF A SECOND
OR EVEN A FULL SECOND BEFORE THE
LIGHTS TURNED RED- THAT THE-
AMOUNT OF FUNDS WERE COVERED-
MORE THAN 55% WENT BACK TO THE
COMPANY SO THERE WAS A- PERVERSE
INCENTIVE FOR THEM TO BE ABLE
TO. HAVE THAT KIND OF- FEATURE
IN THERE AND THE PRIVACY ISSUES
CAME UP TO THERE WAS NEVER
GUARANTEED IN THESE KIND OF
CONTRACTS A CD BILL LOT OF THAT
IN HERE AS WELL AND I DEEPLY
APPRECIATE THAT TO EVERY EXTENT
THAT YOU'RE WORKING ON SOME OF
THE EQUITY ISSUES. TO MAKE SURE
THAT WHILE WE KNOW FROM OUR OWN
DATA THAT WE SEE HIGHER
INCIDENCE OF- HIGH RATES OF A
TRAV I RESPONDED- IN CERTAIN
COMMUNITIES THAT THIS ECHNOLOGY
ALSO IS- EMPLOYED FAIRLY-
THROUGHOUT. THE THROUGHOUT THE
COMMUNITY. SAID THANK YOU FOR
DOING THIS I'M HAPPY TO MOVE THE
BILL. BUT I GUESS RECORD WE HAVE
A MOTION AND A SECOND- ASSEMBLY
RELAXED THANK YOU- ONE I ALSO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
FOR THE SPELLING OF CITY OF
OAKLAND IS- IS VERY HELPFUL IN
THRILLED THAT THIS WILL GET
PASSED AND I KNOW THE CITY
BERKELEY ALSO WOULD LOVE TO BE
ADDED IF THE PER TIME IS EVER
AVAILABLE- BUT WOULD ALSO LOVE
TO BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR. I
THANK YOU. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS. NO I SEEN NONE OUR
MOTION SECOND MA'AM SIX A PLEASE
HELLO WELL ACTUALLY WHICH WAS
THIS WERE HAPPY TO ADD YOU AS A
CO AUTHOR AND I KNOW THAT
BAKERSFIELD IS ALSO ASKED TO BE
INCLUDED IN THE BILL AND WILL
KEEP THAT IN MIND AND WE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH US PEOPLE
WHO HAVE CONCERNS TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE BOSS IS BEST CAN BE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THE VENTURE.
A MASSACRE PLEASE HELLO AB TWO
THREE THREE SIX DO PASSED TO
PRIVACY AND CONSUMER PROTECTION
FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN IPHONE.
FONG NOT VOTING. BERMAN BERMAN I
CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM NOT
VOTING DALY DALY I DAVIS. DAVIES
I GIPSON GIPSON AYE KALRA. KALRA
I LEE. BLOW BLOOM I NAZARIAN.
NAZARIAN AYE WHEN. WHEN NOT
VOTING O'DONNELL. MODANO NOT
VOTING FOR. WARD I WICKS WIXII.
ZERO TEN ZERO- KEEP THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS- WE ARE
THAT THREE MORE BILLS LEFT A MAN
JERRY WOULD NOW PROCEED TO- AB.
NINETEEN OH NINE. THANK YOU THIS
IS OUR ON THE BIKE BILL WHICH
MAKES A SERIES OF VERY SMART
CHANGES TO MAKE CYCLING SAFER IN
CALIFORNIA. AND I DO HAVE TWO
VERY BRIEF WITNESSES DAMIEN
CRABBET AND OFFER GRAHAM BURKE.
WE'LL GO TO DEMAND FOR. FIRST
AND THEN WE'LL GO TO OFFER SO
DAMIEN PLEASE PRETTY WELL READY
. HI CAN YOU HEAR ME OK YES
PLEASE PROCEED. THANK YOU AND
THANK YOU- TO THIS COMMITTEE FOR
ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK MY NAME IS
DAN AND CABINET I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF STREETS
ARE FOR EVERYONE OUR MISSION IS
TO MAKE ST PAPER ALL ROAD USERS
. FOR KIDS THE ELDERLY
PEDESTRIANS FOR DRIVERS CYCLISTS
AND MOTORCYCLISTS ALIKE. I
STARTED THIS ORGANIZATION AFTER
MY OWN TRAGIC COLLISION WHERE I
WAS HIT WHILE RIDING A BICYCLE
AND BECAUSE PARK. MAINTENANCE
THE CAR AND DRIVE TO NEARLY A
QUARTER OF A MILE FROM THE
STREET ONTO AND ON THE FIVE
FREEWAY. IN ONLY TWO MINUTES MY
RIGHT LEG ABOUT TWENTY POUNDS OF
FLESH WERE RIPPED OFF. THE DAY
THAT I KNOW THE SUBJECT FROM THE
GROUND UP IS AN UNDERSTATEMENT.
THE POINT TO DRESS IN AB
NINETEEN OH NINE ARE COMMONSENSE
AND SHOULD'VE BEEN ADDRESSED
YEARS AGO. HOWEVER THERE IS ONE
ASPECT OF THIS BILL THAT I WANT
TO HIGHLIGHT AND THAT IS
SOMETHING I FEEL VERY STRONGLY
ABOUT. AB NINETY NINE WOULD
REQUIRE CARS TO MOVE OVER ONE
LANE WHEN IT'S SAFE TO DO SO. A
POPULAR PERSON ON A BICYCLE.
THIS IS THE EXACT SAME LANGUAGE
IT'S ALREADY IN THE LAW
REGARDING PASSING STOPPED
EMERGENCY VEHICLES IT ALSO
COMMONSENSE. ONE OF THREE
DIFFERENT ONES MAIN PROGRAMS IS
CALLED STATE SUPPORT THAT HELP
THOSE HAVE BEEN SEVERELY INJURED
AFTER A TRAFFIC COLLISION TO GET
BACK ON THEIR FEET OR TWO SUPER
THOSE FAMILY MEMBERS WHO'VE LOST
A LOVED ONE TO DO IT. DUE TO
TRAFFIC VIOLENCE. I HAVE SO MANY
HORRIFIC STORY THAT THOSE HAVE
BEEN SEVERELY INJURED OR KILLED
WHILE RIDING A BICYCLE. EITHER
ENTRY TO RETALIATE THAT COULD
HAVE BEEN PREVENTED. IF DOES
PROVIDE PROVISIONS IN AB NINETY
NINE WERE ALREADY ADOPTED. MY
BRING UP JUST A COUPLE OF THE
STORIES. IN TWENTY NINETEEN
FOURTEEN YEAR OLD DIEGO
MARTINEZ'S WRITING AND BICYCLING
CENTRAL LOS ANGELES JUST A
STONE'S THROW AWAY FROM FIVE
MAJOR SCHOOLS WHEN HE WAS HIT
AND DRAGGED UNDER A CAR SEVERAL
CITY BLOCKS. HE SURVIVED BUT
SUFFERED LIFE CHANGING INJURIES
AND WE ARE STILL WORKING WITH
HIM IN THE FAMILY TODAY. FIFTY
TWO YEAR OLD MARKRAM WAS RIDING
HIS BICYCLE WITH A TWELVE YEAR
OLD BOY ON THE SIDE OF THE ROAD.
IN CINEMA COUNTY MISTER GRAHAM
WITH HIT AND KILLED A TWELVE
YEAR OLD BOY SURVIVED THE LOSSES
LIKE. THIS IS ON THE TWELFTH OF
MAY TWENTY TWENTY ONE. THIRTEEN
YEAR OLD COPIER GONZALEZ WAS
RIDING HIS BICYCLE ON THE FIRST
OF MARCH TWENTY TWENTY TWO IN
THE CITY OF RIVERSIDE. HE DIED A
FEW MINUTES AFTER HE WAS BEING
HIT AFTER HE WAS SENT. AND IN
THE CITY OF SILMAR NORTHERN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY. A TWELVE YEAR
OLD BOY AN EIGHT YEAR OLD GIRL
PROVIDING THEIR BICYCLES AND
THEY'RE BOTH HIT AND SEVERELY
INJURED. THIS HAPPENED
YESTERDAY. AT FOUR THIRTY THREE
PM. MANY OF APPROVED MANY GREAT
BILL THAT HELPS SAVE LIVES AB
NINETEEN OH NINE IS ONE OF THESE
GREAT BILLS MY RECORD I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT YOU
HAVE TO VOTE FOR ME TO THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS HERE TODAY.
THANK YOU. I THANK YOU VERY MUCH
I WILL NOW GO. TO OFFER GOING
BACK YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES. CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES PLEASE PROCEED.
GOOD EVENING JERRY MEMBERS MY
NAME IS DOCTOR OFF THE GROUND
THAT CAN IMPACT THE SAFETY SIGN
IS THE LECTURE OF THE CO
DIRECTOR OF THE UC BERKELEY
THINK TRANSPORTATION RESEARCH
AND EDUCATION CENTER AFFILIATED
WITH THE SCHOOL OF PUBLIC HEALTH
AND THE INSTITUTE OF
TRANSPORTATION STUDIES. I'LL BE
PROVIDING TESTIMONY ON HOW PARTS
OF AB NINETEEN OH NINE ALIGN
WITH THE STATE IT'S AN APPROACH
TO ROAD SAFETY WHICH IS THE SAID
THE PRINCIPLE THAT ELEMENTS THAT
CAN GUIDE OUR EFFORTS TOWARDS
BUILDING ITS SYSTEM ON WHICH NO
ROAD USER CAN BE. SUBURBIA
FATALLY INJURED. FIRST MOVING
BALL OF THE CLASS THREE BIKES ON
THE FACILITY DESCRIBE IN THE-
WOULD IMPROVE ALIGNMENT THE
PRINCIPLE OF THE STATE SET. IT
PROVIDES BETTER MODE GROUPINGS
IN CLASS YOU GUYS WILL BE
GROUPED WITH MOLD THAT HAVE.
SIMILAR MAGNITUDE OF KINETIC
ENERGY. AND IN THE LONG RUN GIVE
ME COURAGE MORE PRACTICE DESIGN
CONSIDERATION. FOR VULNERABLE
ROAD USER ENVIRONMENTS. SECOND
REQUIRING MOTIVI OPERATORS WENT
. OR PASSING A BICYCLE IN THE
SAME DIRECTION TO MOVE OVER A
LANE OF TRAFFIC WHEN POSSIBLE
AGAIN IMPROVE ALIGNMENT WITH
THIS EXTRA STROKES. IT WILL
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL REDUNDANCY OR
LAYERS OF PROTECTION TO THE
DESIRABLE PHYSICAL SEPARATION
BETWEEN MODES. FURTHERMORE WHEN
ROAD ROAD USERS DO MAKE A
MISTAKE PROVIDE A WIDER SAFETY
BUFFER AND WILL REDUCE THE
CHANCES OF A CATASTROPHIC
OUTCOME. BLACKLY ALLOWING
BICYCLE TO FOLLOW LEADING
PEDESTRIAN INTERVAL LPI.
INTERSECTIONS WOULD EXTEND THAT
BILLABLE PROTECTION THE BENEFITS
BUT THAT'S GAINES WHO ALSO
SERVES LIKE TO PUT. ALLOWING
BICYCLISTS AN ADDITIONAL DEGREE
OF PROTECTION FOR MOTOR VEHICLES
OUR RESEARCH HAS SHOWN THAT THE
IN THE CALIFORNIA MODE MAKES
BICYCLISTS ARE FOURTEEN POINT
NINE TIMES MORE VULNERABLE
RELATIVE TO OTHER MODES. AND
WOULD BENEFIT FROM ADDITIONAL
SAFETY IMPROVEMENTS ACROSS THE
DIFFERENT ELEMENTS. OF THE
SYSTEM THANK YOU. A VERY MUCH WE
DON'T HAVE ANY LISTED. SO NOW GO
TO IN PERSON- TEST OR IN PERSON
COMMENTS IF- YOU'RE IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL PLEASE COME FORWARD
. SEEING NONE IF YOU OPPOSED TO
THIS BILL PLEASE COME FORWARD.
C. NINE OPERATOR IF- PLEASE
QUEUE UP EVERYBODY AND IF YOU'RE
IF YOU WANT TO TESTIFY- WITH ME
TO PLEASE HER OR OPPOSE- PLEASE-
PLEASE PROCEED. LIKE A BIG IN
FAVOR OPPOSITION PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WILL FIRST GO
TO LINE FOR FORTY SEVEN GO AHEAD
. GOOD EVENING DINNER BROUGHT ON
BEHALF OF SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU THINK THE
OUT THERE AND MET COMMITTEE
STAFF ARE WORKING WITH THAT
EARLY ON TO ADDRESS OUR- INITIAL
CONCERNS WITH THE BILL THANK YOU
. LINE TO NINETY SEVEN REQUIRED
. I COULD EVEN SEE BALK AGAIN
I'LL BE HAPPY CAL POLY BICYCLE
COALITION EXPORT. NINE FIVE
TWENTY EIGHT. NINE FIVE TWENTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS
IS A OF THE FISH FROM BY CULVER
CITY- CALLING IN- STRONG SUPPORT
THIS BILL THANK YOU. LINE. ONE
ELEVEN. THIS IS MARK SO THAT YOU
CAN CHOOSE FROM ALL IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. NINE ONE
EIGHTY SIX. BY AND ONE EIGHTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN NOW. I'M
NOT SURE I GOT MY NUMBER
CORRECTLY BUT I'M JIM MANAGEMENT
SHOP A BICYCLE INCLUSION WE
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU
EACH. WE HAVE ONE MORE LINE IN
CUBA WE ONE MOMENT OKAY WE HAVE
NINE FIVE FORTY SIX GO AHEAD. HI
I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
NINETEEN OH NINE. THANK. YEAH WE
HAVE NO ONE ELSE NHIàU THIS TIME
. I THANK VERY MUCH WILL BRING
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS. SEEING NO
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. A MANAGER
WHICH I TOOK A DO WE HAVE A
MOTION SECOND. MOTIONS SECOND.
SECOND I WE DID AT THE BEGINNING
. A MANAGER WITH A CLOSE THIS IS
A GOOD BILL THAT I MAKE A LOT OF
GOOD CHANGES AND I REQUEST WE
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE. I THANK THE
THANK YOU VENTURA MEDICAID
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. AB
NINETEEN ZERO NINE TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS FRIEDMAN HI
FRIEDMAN I FONG. FONG NO BERMAN
BERMAN I CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I DALY. DAVIES DAVIES
NO GIPSON. GIPSON AYE KALRA
KALRA I LEE. HELLO BLOOM I
NAZARIAN NAZARIAN AYE WHEN. WHEN
NOT VOTING. O'DONNELL O'DONNELL
I AM BORED WARD I'VE WICKS. NINE
TWO. NINETY WILL KEEP THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS WE WILL
NOW PROCEED TO AB TWENTY THREE
SEVEN PLEASE PROCEED WE READY
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND A
TIRED MEMBERS. THANK YOU I'D
LIKE TO THANK MY COMMITTEE
STAFFER ALL OF THEIR WORK ON
THIS- THIS BILL HELPS TO MAKE
SURE THAT CALIFORNIA MEETS A GHG
REDUCTIONS EXPECTED UNDER SB
THREE SEVENTY BY THE SUSTAINABLE
COMMUNITIES BILL. THIS BUILDS
OFF THE REPORT THAT WAS DONE BY-
IN AB TWO EIGHTY FIVE REPORT
THAT STATES A MID COURSE
CORRECTION IS WARRANTED FOR
IMPROVING THE CHANCES OF SB
THREE SEVENTY FIVE SUCCESS ONE
OF THE MAIN RECOMMENDATIONS OF
THIS REPORT WHICH WAS COMPILED
BY MANY MANY VERY SMART PEOPLE
WHO ARE EXPERTS IN THIS FIELD.
WAS THAT IT A LIGHT WEIGHT WE
ALIGN TRANSPORTATION FUNDING TO
SUSTAINABILITY PERFORMANCE THE
BILL WILL REQUIRE A RB AND
CONSTRUCT CONSULTATION WITH OPR
TO REVIEW EACH REGIONAL
TRANSPORTATION IMPROVEMENT PART
OF THE PROGRAM AND DETERMINE ITS
CONSISTENCY WITH THE SUSTAINABLE
COMMUNITIES STRATEGY. AND THE
STATE'S CLIMATE GOALS STARTING
IN TWENTY TWENTY FIVE AND EVERY
TWO YEARS AFTER ANOTHER
RECOMMENDATION FROM THE REPORT
SAID THE FOCUS MPO PLANS ON
FUNDING B. R. M. T. REDUCING
PROJECTS AND I HOPE THAT THE-
ACRONYMS FOR ALL OF YOU AT THIS
LATE HOUR. THIS BILL REQUIRES A
RB TO REALLOCATE MONIES FROM
REGIONAL TRANSPORTATION PLANNING
AGENCY FROM FUNDING PROJECTS
THAT ARE INCONSISTENT WITH OUR
GOALS TO ONCE THAT ARE
CONSISTENT AT YOU KNOW RATHER
THAN CONTINUE GOING THROUGH
THIS- I WOULD GO TO MY WITNESSES
WHICH ARE BILL MCGAVIN FROM THE
COALITION FROM CLEAN AIR. MERIEL
OVERTURE FROM THE AMERICAN LUNG
ASSOCIATION AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR I. BOATS THAT WE
CAN CONTINUE OUR DISCUSSION WITH
THE NGOS TO ADDRESS ANY OF THEIR
LINGERING CONCERNS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU PLEASE RECEIVE OUR
GOOD EVENING BILL MCGOVERN WITH
THE COALITION FOR CLEAN AIR AND
I WILL BE BRIEF WE SUPPORT THIS
BILL BECAUSE IT WOULD
REINVIGORATE CALIFORNIA'S
EFFORTS TO MAKE OUR COMMUNITIES
MORE SUSTAINABLE AND PROVIDE
CLEAN MOBILITY. TO ALL OF OUR
RESIDENTS IN THOSE EFFORTS HAVE
NOT BEEN GOING WELL- AS THE
AUTHOR SAID OUR TRANSPORTATION
SPENDING IS OFTEN ACTUALLY
ACROSS PURPOSES. WITH OUR
EFFORTS TO REDUCE EMISSIONS. AND
IN IN FACT TRANSPORTATION
EMISSIONS ARE BY FAR THE BIGGEST
SOURCE OF AIR POLLUTION IN
CALIFORNIA AND THE BIGGEST
SOURCE OF GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS. POLLUTION FROM
TRAFFIC KILLS MORE PEOPLE THAN
TRAFFIC ACCIDENTS DO. AND THAT
SHOULD BE MOTIVATION ENOUGH TO
CHANGE WHAT WE'RE DOING- BUT
THERE'S ALSO THE FACT THAT IF WE
CONTINUE TO FAIL TO ACHIEVE
NATIONAL AIR QUALITY STANDARDS
IN CALIFORNIA. THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT CAN TAKE AWAY ITS
TRANSPORTATION FUNDING FROM THE
STATE. SO THIS BILL WOULD SEEK
TO RECTIFY THAT MISALIGNMENT
AND- WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR.
THANK YOU WILL NOW PROCEED TO
KILLING A CESSATION. YES PLEASE
PROCEED HERE YES THANK YOU- MY
NAME MONEY OUT SO I AM THE CLEAN
AIR ADVOCACY MANAGER FOR THE
AMERICAN LUNG ASSOCIATION IN
CALIFORNIA I JUST BRIEFLY WANT
TO ECHO THE COMMENTS MADE BY
BEING A COLLECTION FOR CLEAN AIR
AND THAT OUR SUPPORT FOR THIS
IMPORTANT BILL AND THE NEED TO
ADDRESS AIR POLLUTION AND
GREENHOUSE GASES AND
NIKOLAYEVICH TRAVELED- AT THE
KEY PUBLIC HEALTH PRIORITY- WE
URGE YOU TO MOVE AB TWENTY TWO
THIRTY SEVEN FOR AND ENSURE
CALIFORNIA MOVE IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION TOWARD HEALTHIER AND
MORE SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES FOR
ALL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. I
BELIEVE WE HAVE INDIVIDUALS ON
THE PHONE FOR TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS WILL NOW MOVE TO THE
OPPOSITION I BELIEVE WE HAVE THE
COVERAGE SO SESSION OF COUNCIL
OF GOVERNMENTS HERE- OF. IS IT
IS IT ON OKAY- GOOD EVENING I
LEFT MY LONG NOTES BACK THERE
ARE SO HOPEFULLY I'LL BE A
LITTLE SHORT FOR THIS ON BILL
HIGGINS AND THE EXACT ADDRESS OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
COUNCILS OF GOVERNMENTS WHICH
INCLUDES ALL THE REGIONAL
TRANSPORTATION PLANNING AGENCIES
AND ALL EIGHTEEN M. PO'S THE
RESPONSIBLE FOR IMPLEMENTING AND
ADOPTING A SUSTAINABLE
COMMUNITIES STRATEGY. WE
APPRECIATE THE- WORK AND EFFORT-
THE- THAT TE AUTHORS DONE-
UNFORTUNATELY THE AB TWO EIGHTY
FIVE REPORT THAT SHE CITED AS
THE BASIS FOR THIS BILL ON THIS
ISSUE IS FLAWED AND INCONSISTENT
WITH LAW IT SAYS THAT THERE ARE
REGIONAL TRANSPORTATION
IMPROVEMENT PROGRAMS WHICH WE
CALL TIPS ARE INCONSISTENT WITH
OUR REGIONAL TRANSPORTATION
PLANS WHICH A WHAT WE CALL OUR
TEEPEES. BECAUSE THE PERCENTAGE
OF. INVESTMENT THAT WE'RE DOING
FIRST TO ROADS TO TRANSIT. IT'S
NOT THE SAME AS IT IS WITH OUR
AND OUR OUR TEEPEES. THE PROBLEM
IS IT'S NOT THE SAME DOLLARS.
FOR EXAMPLE IF YOU'RE IN THE
SCAD REGION. THE L. A. METROS
OPERATION COSTS ARE IN YOUR RTP
BUT THE HIP. SO OF COURSE THE
TIP HASA BIGGER PERCENTAGE OF
ROAD INVESTMENT IN IT. BECAUSE
IT DOESN'T HAVE ALL THE
OPERATING COSTS OF TRANSIT THE
TDA FUNDS ARE IN. THE RTP BUT
THEY'RE NOT IN THE TIP SO WHEN
THIS BILL SAYS THAT IT NEEDS TO
BE CONSISTENT WITH. THE STATE
THE STATE TO BE CONSISTENT THIS
IS ALREADY A REQUIREMENT FEDERAL
LAW. FEDERAL LAW REQUIRES OUR
TIPS TO BE CONSISTENT WITH OUR
TEEPEES SO WE'RE A LITTLE BIT
CONCERNED ABOUT A STATE LAW THAT
DOES THE SAME THING AND THEN
CONNECTS IT TO THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSPORTATION PLAN ASTHE
DEFINITION. CLIMATE GOALS THE
CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION PLAN
IS A WONDERFUL DOCUMENT BECAUSE
IT TELLS US HOW WE GET TOWARD
TWENTY FIFTY GOAL. BUT BECAUSE
IT HAS TO GET TOWARD TWENTY
FIFTY GOAL INCLUDE SOME
ASSUMPTIONS THAT WE CANNOT
INCLUDE IN OUR FISCALLY
CONSTRAINED REGIONAL
TRANSPORTATION PLANS. INCLUDING
A PRICING INCREASE THAT IS EQUAL
TO ABOUT TWO DOLLARS AND TWENTY
FIVE CENTS A GALLON FOR GAS IN.
IF YOU WERE GOOD BECAUSE THE
ONLY WAY WE CAN GET TO THAT GOAL
IS TO PRICE SO PEOPLE DRIVE
WHAT'S- WE CAN'T BE CONSISTENT
WITH THAT BECAUSE THE WAY THE
AIR CONFORMITY LAWS WORKERS MR
MCGOVERN POINTED OUT. WE HAVE A
WE COULD RISK LOSING OUR FOR
FUNDING FOR NOT. CONSISTENT WITH
OUR AIR CONFORMITY GOALS WHICH
ARE PARTICULAR WHICH IS
DIFFERENT THAN GHGS. AND OUR
CLIMATE GOALS HE DID VERY WELL
WITHOUT NOTES- IT TO KEEP IT YOU
TWO MINUTES BUT POLLS HAVE
PLEASE WRAP UP PROJECT UP CLOSE
IT'S THESE CONSISTENCY ISSUES
THAT MAKES US SUPPOSE WE- AND
THAT'S WHY I'M HERE THANKS. I
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL NOW GO
TO IN PERSON- SUPPORT OPPOSITION
PLEASE PROCEED. OUR VICE CHAIR
OF FONG AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
I'M MARC WATTS REPRESENTING
TRANSPORTATION CALIFORNIA WERE
IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. AT
THIS POINT IN TIME WE BELIEVE-
WHO ESSENTIALLY GIVES OVER TO
THE A RP THE RESPONSIBILITY AND
VETO AUTHORITY. OVER A PROJECTS
THAT ARE CONTAINED IN A S. B.
THREE SEVENTY FIVE COMPLAINT
COMMUNITY S. C. S. HOUSE STOP
THEIR KRONOS LATE EVENING- AND
I'LL JUST EXPRESS OUR CONCERNS
ABOUT THE BILL WE CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THE AUTHOR. AND HER
STAFF WE HAVE A VERY GOOD
RELATIONSHIP GOING ON RIGHT NOW
SO THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY.
VERY MUCH. NEXT BIGGER. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR GUS QUORUM HAVE
THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY POLICY
COUNCIL IN SANTA BARBARA COUNTY
ASSOCIATION OF GOVERNMENTS- SAN
LUIS OBISPO COUNCIL GOVERNMENTS
IN TRANSPORTATION AGENCY FOR
MONTEREY COUNTY. VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE YOUR LEADERSHIP ON ON
THIS ISSUE MADAM CHAIR- WE ARE
IN OPPOSITION- BUT WE DO THINK
THAT THERE IS ROOM TO WORK
TOGETHER AND COLLABORATE. I
WOULD VERY MUCH APPRECIATE A
FOLLOW UP MEETING WITH YOU AND
THE SPONSORS. ARE SO THAT WE CAN
REALLYTRY TO ACCELERATE-
MEETING OUR OBJECTIVES BUT IT'S
NOT A ONE SIZE FITS ALL APPROACH
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
OPERATOR WILL GO TO THE PHONES
OF- ANYONE LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO YOU- AB
TWENTY TWO THIRTY SEVEN. PLEASE
PROCEED. AND TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE'LL GO
FIRST TO LINE FIVE FORTY EIGHT
GO AHEAD. THAT MAY BE BIKANER
MAKE. GO AHEAD PLEASE YEAH MY
NAME'S GREG ON THE SO THE SUN
AND I WANT TO I WOULD LIKE TO
SEE AB. ONE SIX THREE EIGHT
VOTED ON YES YEAH- FOR THE
SUSPENDING THE GAS TAX THAT'S
THE. LINE TO NINETY SEVEN GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING SHE BOUGHT
COMING UP THE CALVARY BICYCLE
COALITION IN SUPPORT. NINE ONE
ELEVEN. MICHAEL COMMITTEE ON
BAPPA STREET'S FAULT IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL. BY. NINETY EIGHT.
YES HELLO SILVIO FERRARI NAPA
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSE POSITION
BY VERY MUCH LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR THANK
YOU. BLIND. FIVE TWENTY EIGHT. I
DID NOT THE FISH ON BEHALF OF BY
CULVER CITY IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE BILL THANK YOU. THERE ARE NO
FURTHER LINES INTO AT THIS TIME
. I THANK VERY MUCH WHEN I BRING
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
QUESTIONS. WAS ADOPTED YEAH JUST
A QUICK COMMENT HERE AT ALL SURE
YOU I CANNOT SUPPORT SHARE WITH
YOU I CANNOT SUPPORT THIS TODAY
I'M AND I'M SUPPORTER I'M VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF REDUCING AIR
POLLUTION GREENHOUSE GASES
PARTICULATE MATTER ALL OF ALL
THOSE BUT- FROM MY PERSPECTIVE
WORSE IT TODAY AND I THINK WAS
VERIFIED BY SOME OF THE FOLKS
OUT THERE TALKING. IS IT FURTHER
AND POWERS UNELECTED BODIES. AND
FURTHER DISEMPOWER THE STATE
LEGISLATURE. SO FOR THAT REASON
I CANNOT BE SUPPORT OF THIS
TODAY THANK YOU. I THANK YOU ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
SEEING NINE MM CHAU JET CLOSE-
JUST- THIS IS A VERY WONKY BILL
THAT'S TAKING A LOT OF
CONVERSATIONS BETWEEN US AND THE
NGOS WE WANT TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THEM WE ARE THE ONES WHO
SET THE GOALS FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND YES WE HAVE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WHO- ARE INTERESTED
IN PRINT TRANSPORTATION PLANS
BUT A LOT OF THE FUNDING ALSO
COMES TO THE LEGISLATURE. SO I
THINK IT'S PROPER THAT WE HAVE
SOME ABILITY TO IMPACT THAT
REALLY WHAT THE ARGUMENT IS
ABOUT MOSTLY IS WHAT CONSISTENCY
MEANS UNDER THIS BILL AND THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT YOU KNOW I FEEL
CONFIDENT THAT WE CAN MAKE
HEADWAY ON AND I A VERY GOOD
RELATIONSHIP WITH EVERYONE WHO
TESTIFIED IN YOU KNOW I WOULD
ASK FOR THE PERMISSION TO
CONTINUE WORKING ON THIS ISSUE
AND MOVE IT THROUGH COMMITTEE O
CONTINUE THIS VERY IMPORTANT
DISCUSSION. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AMERICANS AS MEDICAID PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. AB TWENTY TWO
THIRTY SEVEN DO PASSED TO
NATURAL RESOURCES FRIEDMAN HI
FRIEDMAN I FONG. FONG NO BERMAN
BERMAN I CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM
NO DALY. DAVIES DAVIES NO GIPSON. GIPSON KALRA. KALRA I LEE.
BLOOM BLOOM I THIS AREA NAZARIAN
I WENT. WHEN NOAH O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL NOT VOTING. WARD WARD
I WICKS. SIX FOUR SIX FOUR WILL
HOLD THAT BILL OF THE RITUAL THE
ROLE OPEN FOR A ABSENT MEMBERS-
WILL NOW GO TO OUR LAST FILE
ITEM I HAVE FILE IMPORT FOURTEEN
TWO AB TWENTY FOUR THIRTY EIGHT-
YOU MAY PERCEIVE ME READY. Q.
THIS IS A FAIRLY SIMPLE BILL
ACTUALLY. THAT ASKS FOR US TO
PRIORITIZE. A GOOD
TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS THAT
PROTECT PEOPLE AND REDUCE OUR-
NEED TO DRIVE IN SINGLE
PASSENGER CARS AND I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WILL NOW GO TO- STE
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT I BELIEVE
WE HAVE. I MET PLAN- AND THEN
WE'LL START WITH CLIMATE PLAN
AND THEN WE'LL GO TO THE ENERGY
C. CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES PLEASE
PROCEED. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO THE
COMMITTEE ABOUT AB TWENTY FOUR
THIRTY EIGHT HI MY NAME IS ME
LOOK UP PARDON I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF CLIMATE PLAN AT
GATEWAY NETWORK OF ORGANIZATIONS
THAT CARE ABOUT TRANSPORTATION
LINE GLAND IT'S KIND IN EQUITY.
WE SPENT THE LAST FEW YEARS
WEIGHING IN ON MANY OF THE BOLD
AND AMBITIOUS PLANS THAT
CALIFORNIA'S FOURTH. WE'VE
ATTENDED EVERY WORKSHOP RELATED
TO THE CLIMATE ACTION PLAN FOR
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE.
ADMITTED EXTENT TO COMMONSENSE
HOUSING TRANSPORTATION PLANS AND
WE REGULARLY WE ENGAGING AGENCY
ABOUT HOW TO. MOVE OUR
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAMS TO
CLOSER TO REDUCING GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS. AND ACHIEVING OUR
CLIMATE GOALS. WE SEE AB TWENTY
FOUR. AB TWENTY FOUR THIRTY
EIGHT AS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
GROUND ALL OF THE PLANS AT ALL
OF THE HARD WORK WE'VE BEEN
WEIGHING IN- WE'VE BEEN. DOING
FOR THE LAST YEARS. WE HAVE BOLD
AND AMBITIOUS PLANS ON PAPER
THAT ARE ASPIRATIONAL QUEUE ALL
AROUND THE COUNTRY AND THAT BILL
IS NOT GOING TO CHANGE LOCAL. OR
NECESSARILY ACCURATE GOLD OR
MENISCAL IT'S JUST GOING TO MAKE
THE CALLS MORE ACTIONABLE AND
REALISTIC. NEXT STEPS. THAT WE
CAN ACHIEVE OUR CLINICAL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU FOR MUCH WILL GO
TO THE INNER C. R. CARTER WITH
IT. PLEASE PROCEED. GOOD EVENING
CHAIR NUMBERS CARTER RUBEN WITH
THE NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL I'M HERE TO EXPRESS
ENERGY SEE SUPPORT FOR AB TWENTY
FOUR THIRTY EIGHT WHICH WILL
ENSURE THAT CALIFORNIA'S EFFORTS
TO HALT CLIMATE CHANGE EXTEND
FOR LARGEST SOURCE OF GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS. THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR. THE MAJOR
INFUSION OF FEDERAL
TRANSPORTATION FUNDING IT
BOLSTERING OUR OWN EFFORTS IN
CALIFORNIA. THE NEXT DECADE
PRESENT A ONCE IN A GENERATION
MOMENTS REBUILD OUR
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
THE NEXT ENTRY. IT'S ESSENTIAL
THAT WE TAKE THIS MOMENT TO
ENSURE THAT THESE TRANSPORTATION
. STATION AND WELL MAINTAINED
TRANSPORTATION WITH THEM WELL
WORKING IN LOCKSTEP WITH OUR
CLIMATE GOALS. YOU MUST DO BOTH
PEOPLE SUPPORTING GOOD JOBS AND
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
AND OPERATION. AB TWENTY FOUR
THIRTY EIGHT WOULD REQUIRE THAT
CALIFORNIA'S TRANSPORTATION
INVESTMENT ALIGNED WITH OUR
CLINICAL BUT THE STATE HAS
ADOPTED AND CONSISTENTLY
REAFFIRM- DESPITE- THE GOLDEN
COMMITMENT. TO GROW COUNCIL
FOUNDED THE REMAIN SIGNIFICANT
MISALIGNMENT BETWEEN OUR
TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS FUNDED
BY THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
THE CLINICAL. THESE EFFORTS WILL
ENSURE THAT AS WE INCREASE OUR
INVESTMENT IN TRANSPORTATION
FUNDING PROJECT THAT PUT US ON
TE PATH ZERO MISSION ECONOMY
THAT WORKS FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS.
WE THANK CHAIR FRIEDMAN FOR HER
LEADERSHIP IN ADDRESSING CLIMATE
CHANGE AND WE ARE AS AN AYE VOTE
TODAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE I KNOW WE HAVE SOME OF
FOLKS THAT ARE ON THE PHONE TO
ANSWER TECHNICAL QUESTIONS WILL
NOW GO TO- THE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION I BELIEVE WE HAVE
MISTER WHAT'S- HERE FOR
TRANSMISSION CALIFORNIA. GOOD
EVENING HI MARC WATTS WITH
TRANSPORTATION CALIFORNIA. FIRST
I WANT TO SAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH TO THE AUTHOR AND HER
STAFF. IT'S BEEN A GOOD HOUR
WITH IS GOING THROUGH ALL THE
LITTLE DETAILS IN THE BILL THAT
ARE IMPORTANT TO US- SOME OF THE
ISSUES THAT WE- ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT. IS OF YOU KNOW TAKING THE
MAJOR BIG TRANSPORTATION
PROGRAMS AND HAVING THE
GUIDELINES. FOR THOSE MAJOR
PROGRAMS. ALIGNED WITH THE CAPS
I WHICH IS THE CLIMATE ACTION
PLAN. DEVELOPED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION AND AS WELL THE
CTP THE TRANSPORTATION PLAN. IT
MAKES SENSE FROM A PERSON FROM
ONE PERSPECTIVE BUT IT'S A
LITTLE LOOSE BECAUSE- FOR
EXAMPLE THE CAPITA IS NOT-
EMBEDDED IN A CODE OR A- ANY
KIND OF A STRUCTURE THAT
COULDN'T BE AMENDED SO LITTLE
CONCERN ABOUT HOW THAT MIGHT
WORK OUT THE FUTURE- AND I THINK
I. THINK OF THE STOP AT THAT
POINT BECAUSE WE HAD A GREAT
CONVERSATION WE A LOT OF WORK TO
DO TO GET THIS BILL INTO GOOD
SHAPE THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT BIGGER. I THANK MR SO
GUS CORN WE HAVE THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY POLICY COUNCIL SENSE
BECAUSE COALITION- SAME COMMENTS
APPLY ON TWO TWO THREE SEVEN AT
THE SAME WITH THIS BILL THE ONLY
THING I WANT TO MENTION IS THAT
I DO REPRESENT SEVERAL SMALL
COUNTIES THIRTEEN OF THEM HAVE
SELF HELP MEASURES WE CAN'T TAKE
CARE OF OUR INFRASTRUCTURE
WITHOUT THE PARTNERSHIP- IT'S
MUCH HARDER TO. TAKE A BIKE OR
TRANSIT IN SAN LUIS OBISPO THEN
IT IS A LOS ANGELES OF THE NEEDS
TO BE A SENSE OF PROPORTIONALITY
WOULD BE EMPTY REDUCTION SO
WHILE WE DO HAVE AN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION THERE'S
A LETTER THAT I UP LOADED THAT'S
FIVE PAGES LONG WITH SOLUTIONS
LOOK FOR WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR
AND OTHER STAKEHOLDERS HOPEFULLY
TO MAKE SOME. I THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. IT ANY OTHER SPEAKERS THE
WANT TO WEIGH IN ON THIS IN
PERSON HERE IN THE ROOM SEEING
NONE WILL GO TO THE PHONES
ANYONE WHO WANTS TO- A. N. ON AB
TWENTY FOUR THIRTY EIGHT.
OPERATOR PLEASE PROCEED. WELL
FIRST GOTO LINE FIVE FORTY FIVE
GO AHEAD. NORTHERN IRELAND
CALIFORNIAN BERMAN PROMOTERS IN
STRONG SUPPORT. NINE FIVE
SEVENTEEN. HELLO HELLO DONE
REPRESENT ACTION CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT. BLIND TO NINETY SEVEN-
STICKBALL COMING CAL POLY
BICYCLE COALITION IN SUPPORT.
NINE FIVE TWENTY EIGHT. PUBLIC
FISH FROM- ORGANIZER FROM CULVER
CITY IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. BLIND ONE ELEVEN. MARKET
RESEARCH ON BEHALF OF STREET'S
FAULT IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
NINE FIVE FIFTY. GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE BELIEVE THAT WENT IS
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATED GENERAL CONTRACTORS
OF CALIFORNIA A MEMBER OF THE
TRANSPORTATION CALIFORNIA
COALITION IN REGRETTABLY
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. MINE.
FIVE FIFTY ONE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR TODD BALLOON SIGN FOR THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION ALSO PROUD MEMBER
TRANSPORTATION OF TRANSPORTATION
CALIFORNIA OPPOSE THE MEASURE
THANK YOU. LINE. NINETY EIGHT.
GOOD EVENING THE OPRAH ARE YOU
HAPPY CALIFORNIA BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSE
POSITION. WE HAVE NO FURTHER
COMPLIANCE IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME
. THANK YOU OPERATOR WILL BRING
IT BACK TO THE CAN EVEN
QUESTIONS. MS DAVIS QUESTION FOR
YOU I KNOW I KNOW TWENTY
SEVENTEEN SB ONE WAS PASSED THAT
WAS WITH A FUEL AND VEHICLE
TAXES I THINK FIVE BILLION A
YEAR THESE TAXES WERE PROMISED
TO- MAKE SURE THEY WENT RIGHT TO
THE ROADS TO FIX THE ROADS. WITH
THIS PROJECT WOULD BE TAKING
MONEY FROM THESE OF FROM SB ONE
NO WHERE WOULD IT COME FROM KNOW
THAT THIS IS OTHER POTS OF MONEY
THAT'S USED FOR TRANSPORTATION
ONE THING THIS WILL DO IS A LINE
UP OUR TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS
WITH THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT NOW
IS WANTING US TO INVEST IN-
NAMELY TRANSIT THIS WOULD HELP
DIRECT FUNDS INTO. THOSE UNDER
INVESTED TRANSIT PROJECTS SO
WHICH OTHER PARTS WOULD COME
FROM ALL THESE OTHER
TRANSPORTATION POTS OUTSIDE OF
SB ONE- THERE'S A WHOLE. YOU
KNOW HOST OF THEM AS MOST OF SB
ONE IS IN A LOCK BOX IN TERMS OF
ROAD REPAIRS THAT SORT OF WORK.
OKAY THANK YOU FOR. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS I'LL JUST ADD MY
COMMENTS- THAT- I CERTAINLY- WE
SHARE THE CONCERNS OF THAT
POSITION I KNOW THAT YOU AND I
SPOKE- EARLIER TODAY. ABOUT THE
CONCERT AT. IS AN- ABILITY TO
MOVE. GOOD SERRA SAID IN A NINE
TO FIVE SO- CERTAINLY YOU WANT
TO CONTINUE. HAVING THIS
CONVERSATION AND TRYING TO WORK
OUT A LOT OF THOSE ISSUES SO
WITH THAT I PROBABLY CAN'T
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY. BUT
WHICH I TO CLOSE HERE WE'RE
GOING TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
ALL OF THE STAKEHOLDERS ON THIS
YOU KNOW WE ALL KNOW THAT WE
NEED TO MAKE SOME CHANGES IN HOW
WE INVEST IN CALIFORNIA IN
TRANSPORTATION. EVEN IF YOU
DON'T CARE ABOUT GREENHOUSE
GASES YOU SHOULD CARE ABOUT
CONGESTION AND THIS IS REALLY AN
ATTEMPT TO START TO CHANGE A
LITTLE BIT OF OUR FOCUS IN THE
STATE. AND IT'S AN ONGOING
PROCESS BUT YOU KNOW IT IS
NECESSARY TO ALIGN. OUR GOALS
ABOUT GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS
AND GHG YOU KNOW- CLIMATE CHANGE
WITH OUR TRANSPORTATION
POLICIES. THESE ARE FUNDING
FORMULAS THAT GO BACK SOMETIMES
THE NINETEEN FIFTIES SO IT'S
TIME TO START. YOU KNOW TAKING A
LOOK AT THEM AND THIS IS GOING
TO BE PART OF A PROCESS TO DO
THAT AND I WOULD REQUEST. THE
ABILITY TO CONTINUE HAVING THE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
STAKEHOLDERS TO THE PROCESS AND-
PUTTING AYE. THANK YOU. I THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR. UNANSWERED
DRAPERIES FEDERAL. AB TWENTY
FOUR THIRTY EIGHT TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS FRIEDMAN HI
FRIEDMAN I FONG. FONG NO BERMAN
BERMAN I CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM
NO DALY. DAVIES DAVIES NO GIPSON
. KALRA KALRA I LEE. BLOOM BLOOM
I. THIS AREA. NAZARIAN I WENT.
WHEN NO O'DONNELL. DONALD NOT
VOTING. WARD WARD I WICKS WICKS
HI. EIGHT FOUR THE VOTERS EIGHT
FOUR WILL KEEP THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS. I THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR. I THINK THAT
CONCLUDES THE FILE- BUT WE HAVE-
ABSENT MEMBERS AS ANY DATA ON-
ITEMS ON CONSENT- I THINK WE
TOOK UP CONSENT BUT PLEASE THE
BOOT GO THE ROLE. AND I WANT TO
THANK MR BLOOM FOR SUBSTITUTING
TODAY YOU PICKED A GOOD MEETING
SEVEN ON. AND IF THERE'S ANY OF
OUR MEMBERS WHO HAVEN'T VOTED ON
EVERYTHING WHO ARE HEARING THIS
PLEASE COME BACK INTO THE ROOM
TO VOTE AND SO. LET'S LET'S CALL
THE ROLL PLEASE. OKAY ITEMS ON
CONSENT CUNNINGHAM. THE SYRIAN.
NAZARIAN AYE CUNNINGHAM AYE
O'DONNELL. OKAY THAT IS ALL
FIFTEEN ZERO FILE ITEM ONE AB
SIXTEEN THIRTY EIGHT DALY. I'M
SORRY CURRENT VOTERS EIGHT FOUR
DAILY. THE VARIANT. NAZARIAN AYE
O'DONNELL. DONALD NOT VOTING
CURRENT VOTE. NINE FOUR. FILE
ITEM TO AB TWENTY FIVE SIXTY TWO
CURRENT VOTE EIGHT ZERO DALY.
GIPSON. O'DONNELL DONALD I HEARD
VOTE. NINE ZERO. FILE ITEM THREE
AB TWENTY TWO SIXTY FOUR CURRENT
VOTE TWELVE ZERO DALY. NAZARIAN. TWENTY TWO SIXTY FOUR. I
NAZARIAN AYE- O'DONNELL
O'DONNELL I. CURRENT VOTE.
FOURTEEN ZERO. FILE ITEM FOR AB
SEVENTEEN THIRTEEN CURRENT VOTE
SEVEN THREE DEEP GIPSON. HERE
WARD WARD I WICKS WIXII. FOR A
VOTE NINE THREE. FILE ITEM FIVE
AB TWENTY THREE FIFTY CURRENT
VOTE ELEVEN ZERO BERMAN BERMAN I
GIPSON. WARD. WARD I WICKS WICKS
I. FOURTEEN HER VOTE. FOURTEEN
ZERO. FILE ITEM SIX AB TWO ZERO
SIX ONE CURRENT VOTE ELEVEN ZERO
BERMAN BERMAN I GIPSON. WARD
WARD I WICKES WICKES I. CURRENT
VOTE. FOURTEEN ZERO. FILE ITEM
SEVEN AB TWENTY ONE FORTY SEVEN
CURRENT VOTE SEVEN THREE BERMAN
. BERMAN I GIPSON. WARD WARD I
WICKS WICKS I. FOR ABOUT. TEN
THREE. FILE ITEM MATE AB TWENTY
THREE EIGHTY EIGHT CURRENT VOTE
EIGHT ZERO BERMAN BERMAN I
GIPSON. LEE. LEASE NOT VOTING
WICKS WICKS I. KERBAL TEN ZERO.
FILE ITEM TEN TWENTY ONE TWENTY
CURRENT VOTE TWELVE ZERO
CUNNINGHAM. NAZARIAN WICKS WICKS
I. AS. TWENTY ONE TWENTY. YES
NAZARIAN I FOR A VOTE FOURTEEN
ZERO. FILE ITEM A LEVIN AB
TWENTY THREE THIRTY SIX CURRENT
VOTE TEN ZERO LI. LI I. FINAL
VOTE ELEVEN ZERO. FILE ITEM
TWELVE AB NINETEEN ZERO NINE
CURRENT VOTE NINE TO DALY. LEE
B. I WICKS WICKS I- VOTE. ELEVEN
TO. FILE ITEM THIRTEEN AB TWENTY
TWO THIRTY SEVEN CURRENT VOTE
SIX FOUR DAILY. GIPSON LEE B. I.
WICKS WICKS I- VOTE. EIGHT FOUR.
FILE ITEM FOURTEEN AB TWENTY
FOUR THIRTY EIGHT CURRENT VOTE
EIGHT FOUR DAILY. B. GIPSON. LEE
HE I. VOTE. NINE FOUR. YEAH.
MAJOR AND WE ARE JOURNAL.